TO CALL THIS MEETING TO ORDER.
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WE ARE PROCEEDING
BY SIGN IN ORDER.
I SEE CENTER WHITE CAO SKI HERE
--
ALTHOUGH SEVERAL LEYVA HAD
SIGNED IN FIRST I DON'T SEE HER.
GOING ONCE GOING TWICE.
ALRIGHT CENTER WIECKOWSKI
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DON'T --
รณ YEAH IT'S AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
TWO SP.
ONE SIX EIGHT TOM I WANT TO
START BY THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR EXCELLENT WORK
ON THIS BILL I WILL START BY
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS REQUEST IN
THE ANALYSIS WHICH WILL ALLOW
CALORIE CYCLE. TO JUST THE
MINIMUM MINIMUM CONTENT
STANDARDS DEPENDING ON MARKET
CONDITIONS AND SUPPLY IT WOULD
SHIFT THE FOCUS OF THE CAL
RECCLE STUDY FROM THAT FUHRMAN
EP OUR PROGRAM TO LOOKING AT
OTHER BOTTLE BILL PROGRAMS IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
I THINK SUCH A REPORT WILL HELP
US UNDERSTAND A WHAT OTHER
STATES SUCH AS OREGON ARE DOING
AND WHAT IS PROVEN SUCCESSFUL IN
WHAT IS NOT PROVEN SUCCESSFUL.
I THINK THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
HELP STRENGTHEN THE BILL AND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATIONS.
NOW S. B. ONE SIX EIGHT MAY HAVE
GONE FROM ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLEX PIECES OF LEGISLATION TO
ACTUALLY ONE OF OF THE MOST
SIMPLE LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR
HELD A SERIES OF STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS.
ARE ON RECYCLING --
THIS RECYCLING PROGRAM THE LA
JOH A ISSUED A DETAILED REPORT.
CAL RECYCLED ISSUED ITS WHITE
PAPER ON THE PROGRAM AND THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE WHICH S. SENATOR STONE
SERVICES BY STURE Y. WITH ME
HELD A HEARING ON THE PROGRAM.
TODAY I'M BEFORE YOU TO ADDRESS
TOO SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS AT THAT CAME OUT OF
ALL THESE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THAT WERE GOING ON FOR SO MANY
YEARS FIRST SP ONE SIXTY EIGHT
DIRECTS CAL RECYCLE TO ESTABLISH
MINIMUM.
CONTENT STANDARDS FOR ALL
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS CAL RECYCLE
IS BEST SUITED TO DETERMINE
THESE NUMBERS FUTURE RAY OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM
INCLUDING THEIR OWN SCIENTIFIC
EXPERTISE AND THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION PROCESS.
AS A KNOWLEDGEABLE IS WE ARE
HERE IN THE SENATE IN THE
ASSEMBLY I I DON'T KNOW IF ANY
OF US HAS THE EXPERTISE TO BE
ABLE TO KNOW.
OF WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
PERCENTAGE --
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE PERCENT
SHOULD BE I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT GIVEN CAL RECYCLE%
AUTHORITY TO SET THE MINIMUM
CONTENT STANDARDS?
DOES NOT EQUATE TO UNFETTERED
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY --
AS SOME MIGHT HAVE SUGGESTED IF
CAL RECYCLE FAILS TO SET
STANDARDS TO HELP FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL AND THE
BRICK AND THE RECYCLING GOALS OF
THE BOTTLE BILL WORK CAL RECYCLE
DOES NOT SET THE STANDARDS.
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
FLUCTUATING MARKET CONDITIONS AS
THIS COMMITTEE HAS SO
THOUGHTFULLY INCLUDED A AS A
PARAMETER THERE IS NOTHING THAT
PREVENTS THE LEGISLATURE FROM
GOING IN AND SITTING THOSE MEN
IN CONTEXT STANDARDS WE HAVE
THOSE.
THAT ABILITY NOW AND WE CAN
ACCESSIBILITY ACT IN THE FUTURE
WHAT WE'RE SIMPLY SAYING IS WHAT
THE EXPERTS HAVE THE FIRST CRACK
AT THIS.
ITEM AND THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
SHOULD BE DOING IT ADDITIONALLY
THE MINERAL CONTENT STANDARDS
WILL PRODUCE BOTH ECONOMIC.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THE
ECONOMIC BENEFIT IS CREATING
MARKETS FOR RECYCLES MATERIA
MATERIAL RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE OVERSEAS MARKET
PARTICULARLY CHINA AS A OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS.
ARM ARE NOW CLOSE TO MANY OF OUR
RECYCLED MATERIALS IT GENERAL
GENERATED FIRE MENTAL BENEFITS
BY REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES AS
ONE OF OUR WITNESSES WILL POINT
OUT.
A IN A INCREASE IN THE USE OF
RECYCLED COTTON PLASTIC GARB
BOTTLES BY 23% CAN REDUCE OF THE
RESULT IN GREENHOUSE GASES BY
10%.
I'M I HAVE MY CO AUTHOR A
SIMILAR STONE'S HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO ADD.
THAT SAY A FEW WORDS BEFORE WE
BRING HONOR THAT EXPERT
TESTIMONY ZEPA SHOP THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THE HONORABLE
LA COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI AND MYSELF --
IN PROMOTING THIS --
GOOD LEADS REQUIRE SOME --
RECYCLED UP PLASTICS GOING BACK
INTO OUR RECYCLING PROGRAM TO
HELP -- CAO
RECYCLE USE THEIR EXPERTISE AND
AND HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
ULTIMATELY IS SUCCESSFUL
REDUCING PLASTICS ARE GOING TO
LANDFILL IN.
AND REVIVE --
CAO RECYCLING PEOPLE'S ABILITY
TO BRING IN THE RECYCLABLES --
AS WE KNOW CHINA IS KINDA CLOSE
THE DOOR YOU OFFER RECYCLE
PLASTICS BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THEY'RE DUMPING A LOT OF VIRGIN
PLASTICS ON OUR MARKET WHICH IS
TOTALLY DISRUPTED OUR SYSTEM
THIS IS GOING TO BE A FIX IT I
THINK IT'S GONNA BE.
A POSITIVE ENVIRONMENT POSITIVE
FOR A LOCAL STORES HAVE TO DEAL
WITH NO CENTERS FOR PEOPLE.
TO BRING THEIR THE RECYCLABLES
AND I FIRMLY STAND WITH THE FOR
THE CHAIRMAN AND DRIVE OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE PROCEED
ANY FURTHER I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR ROLL CALL THE STATUS QUO.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI HERE THREATS
ISSUE HERE ACOSTA [inaudible]
CHAU.
CHAU HERE EGGMAN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
EGGMAN HERE [inaudible]
FLORA.
LOW MOAN MCCARTY MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
WINDOWS SERIOUS.
RISKIER STONE THEIR STONE HERE.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE QUORUM THEM
PROCEDURALLY --
FOR TODAY AS ALWAYS WE WILL --
ALLOW UP TO THREE WITNESSES ON
EACH SIDE --
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION A LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES
EACH [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HOPE THEY'LL BE MUCH SHORT OF
NOT MISTER CHAIR I MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
FIRST OF ALL WE'D LIKE TO ADD TO
SIT SAY THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
IN THAT CO AUTHOR.
APOLLO TREAT REPRESENTING CPR
SEE IT'S THE CALIFORNIA PLASTICS
RECYCLERS COALITION.
IT'S MADE UP OF FIVE OF THE
LARGEST OUR P. ET PLASTIC
RECYCLERS PROCESSORS IN
RECLAIMER IS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE FACILITIES AND SPEAKER
RENDON SAYS STREAK WE HAVE
FACILITIES AND SUSAN EGGMAN
STEPSISTER DISTRICT IN QUITE A
FEW OTHERS --
THESE COMPANIES TAKE PLASTIC
BOTTLE CONTAIN AND CONTAINERS
THEY MAKE THEM INTO NEW RECYCLED
P. ET MATERIAL CALLED OUR P. ET.
THEY IN FACT ARE THE ONES WHO
CLOSE THE LOOP ON PLASTIC
RECYCLING WITH ME TODAY IS ALEX
DALEK PRESIDENCY OVER DECAL
RECYCLING HE'S OUT OF SPEAKER
RENDON SISTER [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ON ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ALEX DELICATE NOW
COMPANY PROJECT RECYCLING AS
WELL AS OTHER COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA PLASTICS RECYCLED
COALITION.
HAVE INVESTED MILLIONS INTO
CALIFORNIA RECYCLING ECONOMY AND
CREATE IT OVERSIGHT WASN'T GREEN
JOBS.
WE HAVE HAD THE TECHNICAL
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FDA APPROVED
FOOD GRADE RECYCLED PLASTIC FOR
MANY YEARS.
BUT IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE
MANAGED TO SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF OUR PRODUCT IN
YOU CAN FIND BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
MADE.
FROM UP TO A 100% OF THE RECYCLE
BT ON THE SHELL OF CALIFORNIA
STORES.
ACOSTA FOR EXAMPLE THESE PLASTIC
BOTTLES CONTAINING RECYCLED PT
OUR PATH CAN VERY PROCESS BACK
INTO BEVERAGE CONTAINERS MANY
TIME OVER AND THAT SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF WASTE AND
CARBON FOOTPRINT.
OF PLASTIC PACKAGING HOWEVER OUR
INDUSTRIES AND CRISIS THAT HAS
BEEN FOR THE PAST SEVEN EIGHT
YEARS.
OUR PRODUCT RECYCLE PEACHY AS
MENTIONED BY SENATOR STONE
CONSIDERED BY BRAIN OWNERS AND
BEVERAGE CONTAINER MANUFACTURERS
TO BE A COMMODITY.
AND WE HAVE TO COMPETE ON PRICE
WITH THE HYPE HYDROCARBON BASED
VIRGIN PT INDUSTRY.
NO SUSTAINABLE PLASTIC RECYCLING
INDUSTRY CAN BE BUILT WITHOUT
SUSTAINABLE DEMAND INVERSION PT
IS USUALLY MUCH CHEAPER TO BUY.
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T EITHER
REQUEST RECYCLING INDUSTRY THAT
WOULD UTILIZE SUPPLY GENERATED.
WITHIN THE STATE IN WOULD
MANUFACTURE PRODUCTS USED IN THE
STATE WAS OUT REGULATORY SUPPORT
A SIGNIFICANT PART OF CALIFORNIA
PLASTICS RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND HIGHLY VALUED GREEN
MANUFACTURING JOBS WILL
DISAPPEAR THAT WILL BRING DOWN
PLASTIC COLLECTION RATES.
INCREASE IT UNCONTROLLED FLOW OF
PLASTICS WASTE OF WHICH WE KNOW
IS SIGNIFICANT PART WILL
EVENTUALLY BECOME OCEAN PLUS SIX
OR GO TO THE LANDFILL.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PLASTICS
RECYCLING COALITION ARE YOU I
NEED THE I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS MARK MURRAY
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE --
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD MANDATORY
MINIMUM RECYCLE CONTENT FOR NON
FOOD CONTACT PLASTIC CONTAINERS
IN PLACE FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
WE'VE HAD MINIMUM RECYCLE
CONTENT FOR GLASS CONTAINERS ALL
GLASS CONTAINERS WE'VE HAD
MINIMUM RECYCLE CONTENT FOR
NEWSPRINT EVERY NEWSPRINT
CALIFORNIA HAS RECYCLED HOT
CONTENT BECAUSE WE MANDATED.
IN NEWSPAPERS TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO.
AND SO THIS ISN'T A NEW IDEA CAL
CAL RECYCLE HAS RECENTLY
REPORTED ON THE SPECTRUM OF
RECYCLED CONTENT THAT'S BEING
USED BY BEVERAGE PLASTIC
BEVERAGE PRODUCERS TODAY.
AND AS ALEX NOTED WE HAVE THE
SPECTRUM FROM 1100% RECYCLED
CONTENT IN SOME BOTTLES. TWO
ZERO RECYCLE CONTENT ON AVERAGE.
THERE'S ABOUT 13%.
OF THE MATERIAL THAT WERE
COLLECTING FOR RECYCLING --
PLASTIC THAT WERE COLLECTED
RECYCLING THAT'S GOING BACK INTO
THESE BOTTLES.
WE HAVE A 75% COLLECTION RATE
THAT'S THE GAP WERE TRYING TO
SHRINK BACK GAP WERE TRYING TO
USE THIS MARKET BASED APPROACH
WHICH WE'VE ALREADY SUCCESSFULLY
DONE WITH OTHER MATERIALS.
PORT THE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
CLEAR THAT WE NO LONGER HAVE
THOSE CHINESE AND USE MARKETS
FOR RECYCLE PLASTIC FOR THE
PLASTIC THAT WE COLLECT
RECYCLING.
THIS IS OUR WAY OF CONTROLLING
OUR OWN DESTINY CREATING MARKETS
REDUCING THE THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT ARM UP THE PLASTIC BY
USING.
RECYCLED MATERIAL IN THE
MANUFACTURE OF THE NEW PLASTIC
BUTTER DRIVE OUT.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE SIR.
STATE YOUR NAME AND POSITION
ONLY THANK YOU.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
YOUR THE BAY IN THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY AND SUPPORT.
REPLANT ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF TOM AND
NORTH AMERICA STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE ABBOTT ON ON BEHALF OF
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION WILD COAST
IN THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MELISSA AND MO WITH CHAU YOUR
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL THE SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA AND
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO ON SPORT.
JUNE IRVINE ON BEHALF OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT WE NEED THE MARKETS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
GEN A PRICE FOR CALIFORNIA LEAD
CONSERVATION INTEREST SUPPORT.
CHUCKLED REPUBLIC SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
ARAB POTASH TERATOLOGY IN
ALRIGHT THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME.
FOR I THINK --
THINK GEE NERVOUS TESTIMONY WAS
FOR PEOPLE.
ESTA CRIME MICROBES IN HERE ON
BEHALF THE GLASS TAXIS.
TO EARLIER AGAIN M. IT'S AN
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS BY COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT BY THE WAY AND AND
POINT OUT.
WHAT WAS WRONG WITH THE BILL
BEFORE IT WAS AMENDED?
AMENDMENT AND I THINK I'M --
THAT THE AUTHOR IN AND IN THE
SUPPORTERS I'M IN.
KINDA MAKES MY CASE THE FOR
GLASS CONTAINERS BEING EXEMPTED
OUT OF THE BILL AND EVERYTHING
THAT WAS ALL THE TESTIMONY ON
THE BILL'S ABOUT CREATING
MARKETS FOR PLASTIC CAN AND
THAT'S FINE IF THAT'S WHAT.
YOU WANNA DO.
CLASS HOW THE MARKET THERE'S A
COMMODITY FOR RECYCLE GLASS.
AND GLASS CONTAINERS ON YOUR
1100% RECYCLABLE IN THAT BLASTED
HEATER MANUFACTURERS WANT AS
MUCH --
RECYCLE GLASSES THAT POSSIBLY
GIG THEY THAT THEIR INCENTIVE
IT'S THERE.
I'M LOWER FURNACE TEMPERATURES
SAVE THEM MONEY STATE IN ENERGY
COSTS LOWER THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
STATE CALIFORNIA HOUSE THAT NEED
IT ON IN STATE CALIFORNIA CLASS
PLANTS --
BUT NOT ALL GO HOME ANOTHER
GLASS PLATES AROUND THE WORLD
ARE IN EVEN ON THE PART OF THE
COUNTRY --
HAVE A BOTTLE BILL THAT SUPPORTS
AB A RECYCLE RECYCLED CONTENT A
TIME YOU KNOW WRITTEN AND EIGHT
AND AS I UNDERSTAND THE BILL
THIS BILL WOULD --
AFFECT FILLED AN UNFILLED
CONTAINERS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
MATTER WHERE THEY'RE MADE AND
WHAT HOUSE CURRY CYCLE MIGHT
HAVE SCIENTIFIC EXPERTISE TO DO
THIS --
THERE REALLY ISN'T MUCH
SCIENTIFIC EXPERTISE NEEDED A
GLASS BOTTLE IS 1100% RECYCLED
WHAT WHAT THEY NEED IS EXPERTISE
TO KNOW THE GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN.
THE COMMODITY MARKETS IN THOSE
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD IN
COUNTRY.
IF IF THERE'S THERE'S NO
RECYCLING SYSTEM NEARBY THERE'S
NOT GONNA A BOTTLE MANUFACTURER
IS GOING TO STRUGGLE TO MAKE A A
RECYCLED CONTENT BILL A BOTTLE.
SO ON WE JUST ASK YOU KNOW IF IF
IF THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
I'M CREATING A MARKET FOR
PLASTIC DIDN'T LOOK I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT FOR THAT THANKS.
MY NAME'S THEM CUTTING MORE THEM
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE THE PARCC
--
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL APPEARS
TO BE TO STIMULATE THE MARKET --
AT THE GREATEST IMPACT BECAUSE
THE LARGEST UP CRV CONTAINERS IS
THE P. T. BOTTLE --
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
THERE IS NO MARKET PROBLEM FOR
PT BOTTLES --
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS A
SET OF PRC SEE WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED THIRTY YEARS AGO.
AS A NUMBER OF PROFIT PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY ORGANIZATION.
COMMITTING TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF THE ENVIRONMENT
REDUCING SOLID WASTE THROUGH THE
RECYCLING OF PT CONTAINERS.
OUR PRIMARY OBJECTIVES ARE TO
INCREASE THE PUBLIC AWARENESS --
AND THE RECYCLING RATES FOR PT
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS AND TO
ENSURE STABLE AND USE MARKETS
FOR ALL THE PT COLLECTING
CALIFORNIA.
COME ALSO TO IN SCRIPT INCREASE
THE SCRAP VALUE PT AND TO REDUCE
THE COSTS OF COLLECTION AND ALSO
--
TO TO REDUCE THE COST OF THE
SYSTEM --
WHEAT PURCHASE OVER 40% OF THE
SCRAPPY T. BILLS THAT ARE
GENERATED IN CALIFORNIA.
A WE KNOW THERE IS NO MARKET
PROBLEMS WITH P. T. SCRIPT
BECAUSE WE LIVE IT EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
THAT'S A LOT OF MATERIAL THAT WE
HANDLE --
BECAUSE OF OUR WORK AND THE THE
BOTTLES GENERATING CALIFORNIA
WERE EVEN BEING SOLD TO CHINA --
THE IT USED TO BE A FIVE YEARS
AGO EIGHT YEARS AGO AT THE MOST
OF IT WAS SOLD BUT IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS THAT HAS REALLY
CHANGED AND NOW.
VERY VERY LITTLE OF IT ACTUALLY
WAS BEING SOLD TO CHINA --
WE ARE OPPOSED TO ONE SIXTY
EIGHT BECAUSE WHAT WE SEE IS THE
NEW ENORMOUS UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS BILL.
A WELL IT MIGHT HELP SOME PEOPLE
YOU HEARD A COUPLE OF PEOPLE IT
WOULD HELP --
IT IS CERTAINLY GOING TO HARM
OTHERS FOR EXAMPLE MANY
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES HAVE
INVESTED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
BUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO RECYCLE PT.
IN THE PACKAGING --
AS OPPOSED TO BOTTLES --
CRB BOTTLES OF THIS MANDATORY
APPROACH IT REALLY TARGETS A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THE N.
USES FOR P. T..
OF WHAT ABOUT THE NON CRV
BOTTLES THERE'S A LOT OF THE
* R. V. BOTTLES THAT ARE
USING RECYCLED CONTENT TODAY
THAT.
THE TWO THAT WOULD THEN BE A COP
PLACED OUT OF THE MARKET.
A BECAUSE IT'S LIKELY GOING TO
INCREASE THE COST OF THE BALES
TO UNSUSTAINABLE LEVELS AND IT'S
GONNA HARM A HUGE PORTION OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN BUILT IN THE STATE.
HOME THAT JADE THEY JUST DON'T
HAPPEN TO MAKE CRB BOTTLES AS
THEIR AND MARKET AND ASKING WHO
TRY TO WRAP UP I'M ALMOST DONE
HERE -- SO
WE THINK THAT --
IT WILL REDUCE THE QUALITYOF
THE BALES --
AND WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE
AN APPROACH THAT DOESN'T PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS ONE THAT --
THAT WILL MEET THE GOALS BY
USING FOR EXAMPLE THE PLASTIC
MARKET DEVELOPMENT PAYMENT THEM
PROGRAM WHICH WE THINK THAT IT
WOULD WORK BETTER AS AS A A
CARROT RATHER THAN A STICK.
THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST ON KHAKI WITH MCCUE CAP
CAN ASSIST IT'S ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
POSED.
REPLIED I CITY AUTHOR INTO THE
COMMITTEE HEARD LETTER OUT WAS
JUST AS A TAD BIT LEAKS OUT TO
MAKE THE ANALYSIS WE DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
I'M IN TERMS OF THE CONCERNS I
WE SHARE THE CONCERNS REGARDING
PROVIDING BROAD AUTHORITY TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
A TO SET UP I'M POST CONSUMER
CONTENT LEVELS --
ALTHOUGH WHO AND CERTAINLY THE
LEAD AND THAT ACTIVITY ON IT
LIMITS THE LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY
ONCE THAT AUTHORITY BROAD
AUTHORITY IS PROVIDED ON TO
DECIDE TO ALTER COURSE ON A
NUMBER OR ADDRESS CONFLICTING
REQUIREMENTS.
AS WELL AS ON TO ADDRESS
POTENTIAL IMPACTS FOR OTHER OUR
PRODUCTS SECTORS USING RECYCLED
CONTENT AS WELL.
ADDITIONALLY I AM AS WAS RAISED
BY A PRIOR SPEAKERS.
AND THERE'S A LACK OF CLARITY AS
TO WHAT PRODUCTS ARE WHAT I
CONTAINERS WOULD BE IN SCOPE IS
IT JUST THOSE THAT ARE UNDER THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER PROGRAM.
AS IT BEYOND THAT IS IT ALL
PACKAGING IN --
ENTIRELY ADDITIONALLY WITH
REGARD TO THE JUNE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT SO THAT PLACE ONEROUS
CERTIFICATION REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON MANUFACTURERS.
IMPOSES SEVERE PENALTIES ARE
CONCERNED THAT NOT ONLY WILL
THAT IMPACT CERTAINLY LARGE
MANUFACTURERS BUT SMALL
MANUFACTURERS AS WELL HAVING AN
IMPACT AND IS.
JUST ONE OF THE ISSUES AROUND
MAKING AYE HAVING THIS BE OUR
MANUFACTURING BREAKER FROM CMT'S
PERSPECTIVE.
OF FINALLY WITH REGARD TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF FOR CAL RECYCLE
TO PROVIDE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
APPROACH.
POTENTIALLY REPLACE THE BOTTLE
BUT WE DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT FOCUS HOW WE UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS OF THE LEGISLATURE WITH
COMMENCEMENT GOING CHALLENGES
WITH THE PROGRAM PERHAPS --
BUT IT DOESN'T AS CURRENTLY
CONSTRUCTED CONTEMPLATE AND HOW
THAT MIGHT DOES SOLVENCY ISSUES
CONSUMER CONVENIENCE WHAT HAVE
YOU MAY BE DRIEST MERELY JUST
AYE HOUSE FOR REPORT ON WITHOUT
KIND OF ANY.
THAT CLEARER PERSPECTIVE FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE ABOUT HOW TO
MANAGE ONE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM IN SOME OF THE
DETAILS THAT ARE PRETTY
CRITICAL.
BECAUSE OF WHAT FOR THOSE
REASONS I'M WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL ON A BOOK FOR TO
THE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WRITTEN JUST TO
COMBAT THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS JOE ACT ON
BEHALF THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED.
PAT RILEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CURRENTLY OPPOSE THINKS.
DENNIS SELBY ONLY HALF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS AMERICA
POST THANK YOU.
UNDERLYING CYPRESS CALIFORNIA --
I'D NOT INTENDED --
TO SPEAK TODAY ON THIS BILL
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT BUT
THE AUTHOR HAS MORE CONFIDENCE
IN THE OUR CONFIDENCE IN THE
TOWER CYCLE TO DO THIS.
IT WILL NOT WORK UNLESS YOU
IMPOSE STANDARDS OF COMPETENCE
ON CAL RECYCLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MS MELENDEZ.
AND I ASSUME YOU WON'T ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS ARE THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED IN YOUR CLOTHES
PERHAPS BUT I JUST WANT TO KNOW
--
I GUESS I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED AS
TO WHY WE ARE NOT PUTTING THESE
STANDARDS INTO STATUTE HAVE IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION RATHER
THAN CAL RECYCLE I KNOW YOU MADE
SOME COMMENTS THAT YOU THOUGHT
PERHAPS --
THE PROFESSIONALS WERE WARM AND
BEST LEFT TO MAKE THAT DECISION
--
I I DON'T KNOW THAT I AGREE WITH
THAT I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT
YOUR YOU KNOW THINKING WAS IN
DOING SO WE COULD WE COULD.
MISTER CHAIR WEEK WE COULD DO
THAT NOW LITTLE HOUSE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN COME IN AND SET
STANDARDS I LIKE 35% THE
EUROPEANS ARE GOING 260% ON GAS
WEAKENED SOMEBODY CAN INTRODUCE
APPEAR.
A BILL AND DO THAT I CHOSE NOT
TO DO THAT I I SAID I BELIEVE
THAT THEY HAVE SOME EXPERTISE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKING
THIS COMMITTEE ON THE STUDY.
CHANGES A PROBLEM EXTEND THE
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY AND SAYS
GO OUT AND LOOK AT OTHER STATES
FIND OUT WHAT'S WORKING WE'RE
NOT LOOKING FOR JUST EXTEND THE
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY AND AND
COME BACK TO US LET US KNOW.
IN SEE WHERE CAN WE FIX THE CAL
RECYCLE PROGRAM WHAT COULD WE BE
DOING BETTER ON ITS WITH SEARCH
TWO PRONGS THAT THIS ARM ON THE
ON THE CONTENT.
WE COULD THERE'S EVEN AFTER THIS
BILL IF WE COME BACK AND THEY
SAID BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
EUROPEANS ARE GOING 260% ON
GLASSES JUST LOOK AT CLASS WHERE
35% RIGHT NOW SO.
IF THEY CAME UP WITH A
RECOMMENDATION BASED ON AND THEN
SOMEBODY ELSE IS DOING AND SAID
WE THINK YOU SHOULD GET.
TO FORTY WE COULD COME IN AND DO
A BILL THAT SAYS WELL WE WANT TO
GET TO FIFTY AND TWENTY THIRTY
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT THERE'S
NOTHING THAT PROHIBITS.
ARE TAKING ACTION IN THE BILL.
I JUST THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
BETTER TO LET THE EXPERTS DO IT.
OKAY SO IF MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I
MAY JUST --
TO EXPAND UPON THAT CAL RECYCLE.
YOU KNOW IS FARR'S.
SOME OF THEIR PRODUCTS THAT THEY
ARE RECYCLING THERE ONE DAY
THEIR SOLVENT THE NEXT DAY
THEY'RE NOT THE UP AND DOWN
THERE OLIVER THE PLACE AND YOU
WANT TO GIVE THEM THE AUTHORITY
TO DECIDE.
WHAT WOULD BE BEST JUST?
FAR IS SEEN A WHAT LEVEL SHOULD
BE SET I'M JUST I'M WONDERING
WHERE THAT LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE
IS COMING FROM THE CONSIDERING.
PARTY I MEAN TO BE FAIR BUBBLE.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT I'M TAKING
IN THE COMMITTEE ALLOW CALORIE
CYCLE TO ADJUST IT BASED ON THE
PRICE OF OUR OIL BASED ON THESE
MARKET CONDITIONS WHICH THEY
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE SAID THAT'S
AN AMENDMENT THAT I ACCEPTED IN
THE IN THE BILL TODAY TO ALLOW
THEM TO DO THAT LITTLE.
THAT MODULATION SO IT'S NOT
STUCK IN BOULDER STONE I THINK
STILL WELL MAYBE GOLD ISSUES BUT
IT IS THE NUMBER THEY CAN MODIFY
BASED ON THESE MARKET CONDITIONS
AND AS WE GET THE INFORMATION
BACK FROM THIS STUDY.
PERHAPS WILL IMPROVE ON IT AGAIN
SO IT'S NOT STATIC IS NOT STATIC
BUT WE WANT TO WE WANT TO GET
MORE RECYCLING ONE HAVE THESE
MARKETS THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
BE MORE ROBUST IN WE GET THAT
INFORMATION BACK SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE ADJUSTMENT THAT WE
MADE WITH THAT TO ANSWER TO
THOSE CONCERNS.
Q. AND FOR THE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
CENTER Y. CASKEY I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOUR BILL DOES JOYA.
IT PASSES AMENDED RECOMMENDATION
WAS LIFEGUARDS YEAH I WOULD --
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE I THINK WE DID
THAT CONCERN ABOUT WHAT THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS IS THIS WEEK
CLARIFIED THAT I BELIEVE WE'VE
WE'VE REACHED THAT THE RIGHTS
BALLOTS ITS ITS BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS IS WHAT WERE.
A WERE HERE AND WITH THAT ON
BEHALF OF CENTER STONE I WOULD
URGE AND I FELT.
ALL RIGHT MOTIONS MADE AND
SECONDED BROKE UP.
I DON'T TO S. B. ONE SIXTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR MURKOWSKI THE MUSCLES
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ROUTE SICHUAN MURATSUCHI
AYE ACOSTA [inaudible]
CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
REYES.
WHERE IS AYE STONE?
STONE I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU.
NEXT -- TO
WE HAVE SENATOR WIENER SIGNED UP
BY CITIES.
AND SEE WHO WE HAVE HERE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY AUTHORS HERE.
WE HAVE CENTER BRADFORD
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
[inaudible]
ONE ONE ONE ZERO SO CALLED.
I'M SORRY ES EVER BEFORE YOU
HAVE A PROCEED TO WHAT WAS THE
VOTE ON THE OKAY.
OUR THE LAST BILL BY CENTER
WHITE HOUSE KEY THE VOTERS FOUR
ZERO SO THAT BUILDS ON CALL.
SENATOR WELCOME THINK YOU MISSED
YOUR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
S. B. ELEVEN TEN AND I ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS PROVIDED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND I MAKE THE
COMMITMENT WILL CONTINUE
WORKING.
WITH YOUR STAFF AND MAKE SURE
THIS BILL IS IMPLEMENTED IN THE
MATH THAT IN WHICH IT'S INTENDED
PART TWO THESE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
ALL THIS IS TO REPORT MEASURE
THAT ADDRESSES SOME PUBLIC POWER
PLANTS.
THERE WERE PROACTIVELY BUILT
DURING THE ENERGY CRISIS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE
RESPONDING --
TO THE NEED OF KEEPING PACE LOW
POWER GOING --
THIS IS GOOD POLICY AT THE TIME
AND THOSE UTILITIES ARE STILL
PAYING OFF THIS DEBT.
SPILLED SIMPLY ALLOWED HIM TO
OPERATE AT A 20% LEVEL UNTIL
THAT DEBT IS PAID FOR IT WILL
SAVE CALIFORNIANS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
S. BILLETED ZERO NO VOTE SO FAR.
AND HOW WOULD NEED TO DAY WILL
GET GREAT COOK IS NOT HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE SECRETARY HURTS ON
BEHALF YES [inaudible]
THE MELANOCYTES.
YES I AM.
ALRIGHT I HAVE A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT --
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION
TODAY AND WE ARE DRIVE OUT.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD [inaudible]
SAY NOT.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
MOTION MADE AND SECONDED --
AND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T SEVEN S. B. ELEVEN TEN
BY SENATOR BRADFORD THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA LIMON MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE RAYOS.
RHYS I STONE AYE STONE AYE
[inaudible] FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
THE BILLS ON THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE HAVE
.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT IS ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN SP --
FOURTEEN OH THREE MOTION'S BEEN
MADE AND SECONDED.
MADAM SECRETARY IS CALL THE
ROLL.
TO PASS OUR EFFORT
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CONSENT RECOMMENDATION MEMBERS
ARE OUT SEARCHING AYE ROUTE TO
AYE ACOSTA CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DESIROUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ON CALL.
WE ARE WE HAVE SENATE JACKSON
HERE.
THIS IS THE ITEM NUMBER.
BUT SAY YOU HAVE TWO ITEMS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. B..
EIGHT THREE FOUR AND ITEM NUMBER
NINE SP TWELVE SIX ZERO COULD WE
OWE START WITH TWELVE SIXTY IF
YOU WOULD MIND I'VE GOT SO YOU
MAY GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH I
COME CENTER.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON ALMOST GOOD
EVENING --
THIS IS A MEASURE OF THE S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY THIS IS THE AND ON
THE BUS FIRE PREVENTION OF
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT BILL.
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY PROMOTE LONG
TERM FOREST HEALTH AND WILDFIRE
RESILIENCY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
DURING THE PAST YEAR AND INTO
JANUARY AND NOW YET AGAIN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCING IN HAS
EXPERIENCED THE LARGEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES.
AND WHILE FAR SEASON IN ITS
HISTORY.
NEARLY NINE THOUSAND WILDFIRES
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN IGNITED
ACROSS THE STATE BURNED OVER ONE
POINT TWO MILLIONACRES OF LAND
DESTROYED MORETHAN TEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED STRUCTURES.
AND KILLED AT LEAST FORTY FOUR
PEOPLE.
WITH ANOTHER TWENTY THREE BEING
KILLED EARLY IN JANUARY AS A
RESULT OF THE THOMAS FAR THEY
CREATED A DEBRIS FLOW.
THAT UP.
I KILLED THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
MY COMMUNITY.
POOR MANAGEMENT POLICIES THAT
INTERRUPTED NATURAL FOREST
LIFECYCLES COMBINED WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE HAVE LEFT OUR FORESTS
VULNERABLE TO CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES.
THIS BILL AIMS TO BREAK THAT
CYCLE BY REORIENTING
CALIFORNIA'S FOREST MANAGEMENT
POLICIES.
TOWARD LONG TERM FOREST HEALTH
AND RESILIENCY.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY ENABLES
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
TO ENGAGE IN COLLABORATIVE
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT.
AND CREATES NEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LAND
MANAGERS TO MITIGATE WILDFIRE
RISKS INCLUDING THROUGH THE
EXPANDED USE OF PRESCRIBED FIRE.
MEMBERS NOW IS THE MOMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO AGGRESSIVELY
TACKLE ITS STATE WILD WIRE
STATEWIDE WILDFIRE RISK IN A
PROACTIVE MANNER.
AND WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
OUR LEAGUE LIZ FROSTBURG FROM
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND STACY
HEATON FROM THE RURAL COUNTY.
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED
SENATE JACKSON BEFORE WE PROCEED
WITH YOUR WITNESSES --
THERE ARE A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS
SUGGEST WE WILL ACCEPT THOSE AS
AUTHORS MOMENTS AND WE'RE THANK
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US THIS I THINK
I THINK WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU AND FOR THE RECORD
THOSE WILL BE TAKEN UP IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
UFC.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ FORCED
BURKE I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
SIXTY AND WOULD LIKE TO THINK
SENATE JACKSON FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THE SPELL --
I STATED S. B. TWELVE SIXTY THE
COMPREHENSIVE FIRE AND FORCED
HEALTH BILL THAT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA INCREASE FIRE
PREVENTION IN FORCE MANAGEMENT
TO BODIES. TO MITIGATE WILDFIRE
RISK IN THE WAKE OF THE WORST
FIRES IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
IN PARTICULAR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY'S. TWELVE SIXTIES
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE LOCAL
PLANNING RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
PRODUCE WILDLAND FIRE RISK.
INCREASE THE STATE'S USE
PRESCRIBED FIRE.
AND ENSURE THE STATE MAY SPEND
FUNDS AND ALL CALIFORNIA WILD
LANDS INCLUDING THOSE OWNED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S FORESTS ARE AT RISK
HISTORIC MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
AND DECADES OF FIRE SUPPRESSION
COMBINED WITH DRYER HOTTER
CONDITIONS HAVE LEFT HER FORCE
BONNEVILLE TO CATCH OF
QUALIFIERS.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY INCREASES
THESE PRESCRIBED FIRE TO HELP
RETURN LANDSCAPES TO THEIR
NATURAL BALLOTS WITH FIRE.
ENHANCING COMMUNITY SAFETY AND
IMPROVING FOREST HEALTH.
IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING NOTICING
HIM AND ANALYSIS THAT MANY
ASPECTS OF THE BILL ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
RECENT EXECUTIVE ORDER.
AND FUNDING IN THE BUDGET TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE PACE
AND SCALE FOR FRUSTRATION.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY WERE PROMOTE
FORCED HEALTH AND WEALTH FIRE
RESULTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THREE GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M STACY HEAT WITH
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
THIRTY FIVE RURAL COUNTIES
STATEWIDE.
AND MANY OF OUR COUNTIES ARE
HEAVILY FORESTED COUNTIES AND
HAVE SUFFERED SOME OF THE MOST
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES OVER THE
LAST DECADE PLUS.
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD THAT
THERE'S FIVE LARGE SCALE
WILDFIRES HAPPENING RIGHT AS WE
SPEAK IN FACT UP IN OUR MEMBER
COUNTIES.
AND THIS HAS BEEN A LONG NEED --
TO INCREASE AND ENHANCE THE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR FORCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE FEEL THAT S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
GOES A LONG WAY IN ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE BY ENHANCING AND
EXPANDING USE OF PRESCRIBED FIRE
IN CALIFORNIA IN WORKING WITH.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL
AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE
STATE TO GET THAT DONE AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT WHEN YES MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE HERE FOR THE
CALVET LICENSE FORCE ASSOCIATION
WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTS A PRIEST
PRECEDE THE AUTHOR FOR THAT IS
THE BILL GETTING MORE SEARCHES
OF PRESCRIBED FIRE.
IT'S ONE OF MANY TOOLS THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING TO ADDRESS
SITUATION THERE ARE OTHERS THAT
WE WOULD SUPPORT AS WELL.
THINK.
MR TURN MEMBERS HIS HOLD ON
SALAS POTTER HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION THE CHECKS WEAPONS
FROM SPRINTING KEPT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
REYES ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY
VENTURA SENATOR JACKSON'S BEEN
JUST A TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR THE
REGION IN THE WAKE OF THE THOMAS
FIERY THINKERS SO MUCH FOR
LEADERSHIP.
WERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FENCED MAKER FOR THE SUMMER
COUNTY AG OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
THE CINEMA COUNTY WATER AGENCY
BOTH EXPERIENCED HORRENDOUS
WILDFIRES THIS PAST YEAR SIMILAR
TO WHAT WAS EXPERIENCED IN SANTA
BARBARA.
THANK YOU TO CENTER JACKSON FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
WHEREIN STRONG SUPPORT.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THINKING.
CHAIRMAN BY REBECCA LEE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON ALSO IN SUPPORT.
RENDON TOOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WHICH IS
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM ALL
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
A WARRANT SUPPORT WE APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
I HAVE PARTICULARLY PLEASED WITH
THEIR THE WAY THAT PROVISIONS
ARE AYE WITH AIR QUALITY IN
SMOKE MONITORING IN THE BILL
THAT'S IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS
AFRICAN EX EXPAND PRESCRIBED
FIRE AND WE THINK THE AUTHOR IS.
A DELICATE JOB ADDRESSING THAT
ISSUE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LOCAL CONSERVATION
CORES IN THE FOURTEEN NONPROFIT
LOCAL ENTITIES THEIR REPRESENTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THINK YOU.
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF BIG SUR
LAND TRUSTS AND THE WILD LANDS
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
NIGGLING AT NINE THIS GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY WE ARE ALSO
VERY SUPPORTIVE AND THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SUGGEST AB. ONE SMALL
AMENDMENT OR CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR TO CLAP.
PERHAPS IMPROVE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN WHEN THE PRESCRIBERS ARE
HAPPENING WITH THE UTILITY
COMPANIES WE'VE BEEN AS STRONG
PARTNER WITH THAT WITH THE STATE
AND HAVE THEM AND AND PROGRAMS
IN OUR OWN CITIES RIGHT TREE
RIGHT PLACE. TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MITIGATE --
THAT THREAT OF FIRE SO WE JUST
WANTED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SARAH TO HARRY
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY ALSO IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER JACKSON FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE --
THIS BILL DOES HAVE A AYE
RECOMMENDATION AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE TAKEN
AND THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
SELECT CLUBS LISTA THANK YOU ALL
AND IN A LOT OF ADVERSITY
SOMETIMES COMES OPPORTUNITY
WE'VE HAD PLENTY OF OUR OUR
ADVERSITY WITH A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION DEAD TREES
IN THE STATE --
WE REALLY HAVE GOT TO GET ON
THIS AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN SO
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. TO HIM THE MOTIONS.
YET SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND --
MADAM SECTOR PLEASE.
FOR ITEM NINE S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
BY SENATOR JACKSON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS A REFER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT SEARCHING Y.
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA CHAU
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA LOW MOAN
MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S I REDUCE.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THE
BILL'S ON CALL.
NEXT WE HAVE --
S. B..
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
A THIS IS S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FOR
A BILL THAT PROHIBITS THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION FROM APPROVING
LEASES IN STATE WATERS.
THAT WOULD SUPPORT OIL AND GAS
PRODUCED FROM NEW LEASES IN
FEDERAL WATERS I KNOW THAT THE
CHAIR IS FAMILIAR WITH THIS
ISSUE CARRYING A VERY SIMILAR
BILL.
UP ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE AND AS
PEOPLE WHO REPRESENT COASTAL
AREAS WHICH ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
THIS WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF PROTECTING OUR COASTLINE.
BOTH IN TERMS OF PROTECTING OUR
MARINE LIFE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR QUALITY OF
LIFE --
FIRST AGAIN I WOULD LIKE --
TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR CONTINUE
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE A
WHICH HAS BEEN INVALUABLE IN OUR
EFFORTS AND I ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LING MOUNTS.
A CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND
PARTNERSHIP AS WELL.
WE HAVE ALL I THINK WORKED HARD
TO ENSURE THAT OUR BEAUTIFUL
DISTRICTS ALONG WITH THE REST OF
THE STATE.
REMAIN PROTECTED FROM EXPANDED
OFFSHORE DRILLING.
AND CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF PROTECTING ITS COSTA
NOTIONS FROM THE STROLLING
STARTING IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE WHEN WE
WITHDREW CERTAIN OFFSHORE AREAS
FROM OIL AND GAS LEASING PERIOD.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR UPON
FINDING THAT OFFSHORE OIL AND
GAS PRODUCTION POSED TO NOT
ACCEPT UNACCEPTABLY HIGH RISK TO
OUR STATES MARINE ENVIRONMENT.
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
LANDMARK SANCTUARY ACT WHICH
PROHIBITED NEW OFFSHORE OIL AND
GAS PRODUCTION IN STATE WATERS.
THIS BILL CONTINUES THAT
TRADITION BY RESPONDING TO AN
ACCELERATED PROPOSAL BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO OPEN UP
WIDE SWATHS OF FEDERAL WATERS TO
NEW OFFSHORE OIL DEVELOPMENT.
AS THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS FULL
WELL.
THE NEW FEDERAL FIVE YEAR
OFFSHORE LEASE PLAN WILL OPEN UP
SEVERAL NEW LEASES AWFUL WEST
COAST WITH SIX NEW RELEASES
TARGETED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS THE FIRST NEW PROPOSED
SALE OF LEASE TRACKS OFF OF
CALIFORNIA SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY EITHER
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS.
WHILE WE CANNOT LEGISLATE
LEASING ACTIVITY IN FEDERAL
WATERS WE HAVE NO JURISDICTION.
WE CAN'T TAKE ALL MEASURES TO
PROTECT OUR STATE WATERS AND
ENSURE THAT STATE WATERS TO NOT
FACILITATE THE TRANSPORT OF OIL
PRODUCED FROM THESE NEW FEDERAL
LEASES.
BY MAKING THE ON SHORING OF NEW
OIL MUCH MORE DIFFICULT WE STAND
THE BEST CHANCE OF KEEPING NEW
LEASES FROM BEING DEVELOPED IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
AS THE MATH JUST ISN'T THERE TO
MAKE OTHER OPTIONS VIABLE AND
PROFITABLE IN OTHER WORDS IT
WON'T PENCIL OUT.
AND THAT IS OUR GOAL.
IN FACT THIS MODEL PROHIBITING
LEASING IN STATE WATERS WAS
FIRST INTRODUCED IN A BILL I DID
LAST YEAR S. B..
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT OF MY OFFSHORE
OIL BAND WE BILL FROM LAST YEAR
AND HAS NOW BECOME THE PRIMARY
BASIS FOR STATE BANS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IN FACT NEW YORK IN DELAWARE ARE
DEBATING THE SAME BILL IN THEIR
LEGISLATURES AND NEW JERSEY HAS
ALREADY SIGNED THIS.
ASSIGNED ONE OF THESE BILLS INTO
LAW LEAH LEADING TO SEVERAL
PRESS OUTLETS INCLUDING THE
WASHINGTON POST TO POINT TO NEW
JERSEY.
AS THE NATIONAL LEADER IN THE
OFFSHORE OIL FIGHT.
NEW JERSEY.
I'VE BEEN TO I'VE BEEN TO NEW
JERSEY RECENTLY HARD TO BELIEVE
THEY ARE TAKING THE LEAD BUT
INDEED THEY ARE.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE GOOD
PEOPLE OF NEW JERSEY.
UP REPUBLICAN STATES.
REPUBLICAN STATES LIKE SOUTH
CAROLINA FLORIDA ARE DIRECTLY
NEGOTIATING WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO BE EXEMPTED.
FROM FUTURE LEASE SALES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
BLUE AND RED STATES ARE SAYING
NO TO OFFSHORE DRILLING AND IT'S
TIME WE HEARING CALIFORNIA
FINALLY DO THE SAME.
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE TWO
WITNESSES TO SPEAK ON THE
ECONOMIC IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL.
MY FRIEND COLLEAGUE OF LONG
STANDING LINDA CROP WHO IS THE
SENIOR COUNSEL FOR THE SANTA
BARBARA BASED ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE CENTER.
AND NO OPEN HIME REPRESENTING
THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
OF FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS
[inaudible]
NO CONSECUTIVE [inaudible]
PLACE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FOUR DOES
ENJOY BROAD SUPPORT FROM
ENVIRONMENTALISTS BUSINESSES
LABOR FISSURES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
IT IS CONSISTENT WITH ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY NINE
WHICH PASSED EARLIER THIS YEAR.
AND AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED IT
IS ALSO CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING
LAW THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
SANCTUARY ACT WHICH PROTECTS
STATE WATERS.
FROM LEASING BUT THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT OUR STATE
FROM THE THREATS OF FEDERAL WE
SING.
OFF OF OUR COAST --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK BACK AND
REALIZE THAT BOTH IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE OIL SPILL AS
WELL AS THE MORE RECENT TWENTY
FIFTEEN REFUGIO OIL SPILL.
BOTH WERE RELATED TO FEDERAL
OFFSHORE LEASES AND DEVELOPMENT
SO OUR STATES COAST IS QUITE
VULNERABLE AND CAN BE IMPACTED
EVEN FROM LEASING AND
DEVELOPMENT IN FEDERAL WATERS.
BOTH OF THOSE BILLS NOT ONLY
IMPACTED THE ENVIRONMENT BUT HAD
DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON OUR
COASTAL ECONOMIC SECTORS.
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FOUR IS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT OUR COAST
FROM THE THREAT OF NEW FEDERAL
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT
AND PROTECT OUR COASTAL
RESOURCES AND ECONOMY.
WE THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
BILL AND THANK YOU ALSO FOR YOUR
WORK ON AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY PLUG
SHAMELESS PLUG [inaudible]
ECHOING THAT.
LACK OF SHAME NOAH OPPENHEIM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS --
ORGANIZATION IS A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE BUSINESS ALLIANCE
FOR PROTECTING THE PACIFIC COAST
JOINING OUR COLLEAGUES IN BLUE
INDUSTRIES REPRESENTING MULTIPLE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN REVENUE
--
FROM THE SUSTAINABLE AND AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY USE OF
OUR OCEANS --
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING IS
INCOMPATIBLE WITH THE VALUES
THAT CALIFORNIA'S HOLD DEAR.
AS WELL AS THE VALUES THAT
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN AND
STEWARDS OF THE RESOURCES HAVE
FOR THE LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE
PROTECTION OF THE RESOURCES THAT
OUR MEMBERS NEED FOR THEIR
LIVELIHOODS.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL OUT WE MUST PROTECT OUR
OCEANS FROM THE SCOURGE OF
OFFSHORE OIL PRODUCTION.
THANK YOU FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER TURNED MEMBERS SILVIUS
ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTY OF
CINEMA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON PAGEANTS CIRCLE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SO DON'T TELL US WHAT ARE YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
EMISSIONS POINTING TO OTHER.
THREE SEPARATE A* BEHALF OF
FEEL THE BAY AND SUPPORT.
RICHARD CHARTER THE OCEAN
FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION WILD COAST
IN THE OTHER NINE MEMBERS OF THE
CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY VETERANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE OF THEM DONE ON BEHALF
ABOUT ONE CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
EVAN MINTON WITH CALIFORNIA
VOICES FOR PROGRESS WE REPRESENT
BUSINESS OWNERS ENTREPRENEURS
INVESTORS AND PLANS ARE PASTED
DEPEND ON A CLEAN.
AT COAST AND FOR THEIR BUSINESS
AND AND IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND DAVID WHY SCOTT
FOR NEXT IN CALIFORNIA A THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE TO THE CHAIR AND TO THE
CENTER --
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL?
MARTIN NEED FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AARON
EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL ALONG WITH OUR SIXTY
ON THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL CITIES
THANK YOU.
AND ONLY SERVER OATH DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
JEFF CHESTER REPRESENTING
OCEANIC AND STRONG SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON.
BRIAN CLING ON BEHALF OF
CALPERS.
DAVID ISSUE WAS ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DANIEL INCH ON BEHALF OF THE
OCEAN CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
THEY HAD A BASKET ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ROOMS JUST SIGNS
OF SUPPORT AND ALSO READ SHE
SUPPORT FOR A SOLUTION.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME.
FOR AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE VERY BRIEFLY SUCH AS WHAT
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE LAST
COMMISSION CURRENTLY HAS
EXISTING REGULATORY.
AUTHORITY TO RESIDE OVER THESE
MATTERS IN ADDITION BASED ON THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS --
ANALYSES AS WELL OTHER PRO
DIVISION OF RENEWING --
PROSPECT THAT LEASES --
CAN ALSO PROVIDE --
POTENTIAL FISCAL IMPACTS ON THE
LOSS OF PERSPECTIVE REVENUES AS
WELL SO.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU THINK YOU ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
A CALIFORNIA JUNIATA RIGHT THEN
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WERE OPPOSED FOR THE
ISSUE THAT IT MAY AFFECT
EXISTING LEASES THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EQUIPMENT
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SO.
IF THE GOAL IS.
TO IF THE GOAL IS --
TO DECREASE.
OUR PRODUCTION IN FEDERAL WATERS
--
WELL THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID YOUR
GOAL WAS THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING
THAT QUESTION KNOW THE GOAL
ISN'T TO DECREASE THE GOAL IS TO
PREVENT FURTHER LEASING FOR
EXPANSION OF LEASING IT DOESN'T
MEAN ANYTHING REDUCE.
IT DOESN'T DO ANYTHING FOR
EXISTING LEASES THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO DRILL SADLY.
BUT THIS BILL DOES NOT DEAL WITH
ANYTHING OTHER THE EXPANSION OF
LEASING THIS DEALS WITH RENEWAL
AS WELL CORRECT.
IT IT DEALS WITH THE
TRANSMISSION ALL OF FEDERAL DOVE
A OF OIL THROUGH STATE WATERS
TOO THE OF THE VARIOUS
REFINERIES AND SO FORTH IN OTHER
WORDS THE CLOSEST THE STATE OFF.
AS IT CREATES A WALL IF YOU
WILL.
IT CREATES A WALL IN A SO THAT
NEW.
OR EXPANDED LEASING OFF OF OUR
FEDERAL WATERS CANNOT WE CANNOT
--
DEVELOP NEW INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ACCOMMODATE THOUGHT THAT
ADDITIONAL OIL SO.
SO I UNDERSTAND --
THE POSITION THAT YOU AND THOSE
LIKE YOU HAVE RELATING TO OPTION
OFF SHORE DRILLING I DO --
I I DISAGREE BUT I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND IT WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS IF THESE TYPES OF
RESTRICTIONS ARE PUT INTO PLACE
--
THEN WHERE WILL THE FUEL SOURCE
THAT SO MANY RELY ON COME FROM.
ELECTRIC VEHICLES CRIME
DELIGHTED TO HAVE ONE I HAVEN'T
HAD TO PUMP A DIME'S WORTH OF
GAS IN MY OF CAR TO SINCE I
PURCHASED IT A ON EVERYBODY HAS
AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE WILL
HOPEFULLY WILL START MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION WE'RE NOT
STOPPING OIL DRILLING.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS WE DON'T
WANT TO EXPAND IT THERE ARE
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE
SHOULD BE DEVELOPING TODAY BUT
TO REPLACE THE FOSSIL FUELS
SENATOR CREATING THE PROBLEM IN
OUR CLIMATE AND ENERGY?
I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT AS YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
CONTINUES TO GROW RIGHT SO THERE
IS OUR NEED INCREASES --
AS OUR POPULATION GROWS IT
DOESN'T DECREASE SO I KNOW THAT
THERE IS AN EFFORT TO USE MORE
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
AND BUT WE CERTAINLY CAN'T OUR
WHOLE PORTFOLIO CANNOT RELY
SOLELY ON RENEWABLE ENERGY IT
CERTAINLY DOESN'T EXIST RIGHT
NOW I MEAN FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
DO SO SO I'M JUST.
I FEEL LIKE.
YOU HAVEN'T THOUGHT THIS THROUGH
WITH RESPECT TO THE COST THAT
WILL BE TO CALIFORNIA MOTORIST
AND BUSINESSES AND THOSE WHO
WORK IN THESE --
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
I JUST FEEL LIKE IT'S THAT
WASN'T EVEN CONSIDERED
[inaudible]
WELL.
IF YOU HEARD WHAT I SAID.
I SAID WE'RE NOT STOPPING OIL
DRILLING WHICH ASSERTING WE'RE
NOT GOING TO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ALLOW IT TO BE EXPANDED BEYOND
AND RIGHT NOW FRANKLY OUR
REFINERIES OR A CAPACITY.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE WE DON'T HAVE
OIL BEING DRILLED BUT WHAT WE DO
HAVE IS THE POSSIBILITY OF
WEANING OURSELVES OFF OF OIL
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS. TO
USE OTHER.
NON FOSSIL FUEL ENERGY SOURCES
SO THAT WE CAN.
WE CAN STOP WORK CLIMATE CHANGE
FOR EXAMPLE WHEAT YOU KNOW ALL
THE EXPERTS ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS IS BASED UPON FOSSIL FUELS.
AND WE ARE HOPEFULLY GOING --
TO REDUCE AND ULTIMATELY
TRANSFER --
AS TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE TO THE
NON A INVASIVE NON --
FOSSIL BASED FUELS LIKE I
MENTIONED ELECTRIC CARS WERE
TALKING ABOUT HYDROGEN THERE ARE
ALL SORTS OF NEW OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE SO WE CAN WEAN
OURSELVES OFF WHAT WE KNOW IS A
DIRTY FORM OF ENERGY.
AND THIS BILL DOESN'T STOP US IT
DOESN'T AFFECT A THE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE --
IN OUR STATE OF PEOPLE CAN START
USING ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF
TRANSPORTATION THAT'S SOMETHING
ELSE WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
A RAIL FOR EXAMPLE GET PEOPLE
OUT OF THEIR CARS LOT MORE
PEOPLE ARE BICYCLING TO AND FROM
WHERE DEVELOPING TECHNIQUES THAT
WILL HELP US WIN OURSELVES OFF
OF THIS.
A DIRTY FOSSIL FUEL AND THE
NOTION THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
EXPAND IT WHEN WE KNOW IT'S
IMPACT THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
ALLOW IT TO TO GROW IN ITS USAGE
IS ANATHEMA. TO THE POLICIES OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS.
THANK YOU MS MONEY HAS ANY
FURTHER.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE CENTER JACKSON AYE
[inaudible]
AND VERY THANKFUL TO YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP --
YOU INTRODUCE THE SPELL LAST
YEAR AND YOU'RE BACK AGAIN.
AND OUR I AM PROUD TO BE A
PARTNER WITH YOU --
IN SUPPORT OF THIS EFFORT
[inaudible]
AND AND I STRUGGLING SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
IT'S LIKE CLOTHES APPRECIATED A
LAST YEAR I IT WAS INTRODUCED
BECAUSE WE HEARD RUMBLINGS THAT
THERE WAS GOING TO BE AN EFFORT
FOR THE FIRST TIME AND OF THREE
DECADES.
A TO OPEN UP THE FEDERAL WATERS
AND THEN THAT MODE THAT MOVE
CAME THIS YEAR AND SO THIS IS
NOW.
MORE IMPERATIVE THAN EVER AND
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
I'VE.
VERY MUCH SO MUCH IT'S BEEN MADE
AND SECONDED ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM FIVE SP EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
BY SENATOR JACKSON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT SEARCHING Y.
FOR OUTSIDE SHE AYE ACOSTA.
CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA LAMONT.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELINDA'S KNOW VARIOUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I FOR ONE FOR ONE BILLS ON
CALL THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER AND
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ETCETERA LEYVA HERE.
WE ARE GO BACK INSIDE IN ORDER
ITEM NUMBER.
SIX SP TEN SEVENTY TWO BY CENTER
LABOR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE I'M --
FOR ALL THEIR WORK AND THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE WILL BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY TWO CREATES A
REGIONAL CLIMATE.
COLLABORATIVE PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL TO EMPOWER UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO PARTICIPATE IN CLIMATE
PROGRAMS AND ACHIEVE TANGIBLE
SUCCESS.
TOWARDS HELP YOUR ENVIRONMENTS
EACH YEAR THE STATE RECEIVES
LARGE REVENUES FROM A VARIETY OF
RESOURCES TO COMBAT POLLUTION
AND CLEAN OUR AIR.
ALTHOUGH WE HEAR MAYOR YOUR MARK
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR POLLUTED
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BOTH
RURAL AND URBAN THOSE VERY
PLACES ARE STRUGGLING TO ACCESS
THOSE DOLLARS.
THEREBY COMPROMISING OUR CLIMATE
ACTIONS.
WITHOUT LARGE BUDGETS AND STAFF
FOR OUTREACH OR GRANT WRITING
FINDING AND APPLYING TO PROGRAMS
IS DAUNTING AND A NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TASK.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY TWO RESPONSE
TO THE URGENT NEED TO ALIGN OUR
CLIMATE PROGRAMS WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT AND PASSIONATE LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
THESE REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE'S
WILL PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND CAPACITY BUILDING
TO CREATE THE SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED. TEN SEVENTY
TWO ENSURES THAT THERE IS AN
ACQUITTAL ACCESS TO FUNDING
PROGRAMS THAT IMPROVE HEALTH THE
HEALTH OF ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH BUSINESS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS WITH ME TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT IS THE ANIMAL LEAN
WITH THE TRUCK A TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND.
AN EMMY* WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE SPONSORS OF SP
[inaudible]
TEN SEVENTY TWO LADIES.
GET AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS STAN A MOLINA WHAT THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND.
AND WE ARE CALL SPONSORS OF SP.
TEN SEVENTY TWO I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SHARE WITH YOU
OUR EXPANDS WORKING AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. TO
DEMONSTRATE AND THEN THE NEED OF
THIS FOR THIS BILL AND HOW THAT
INFORMED OUR REASON FOR BEING CO
SPONSORS HERE TODAY.
WITH THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE
[inaudible]
THEN -- AMY
WILL TALK ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF
THE BILL AND HOW IT ADDRESSES
THE PROBLEMS WE WANT TO SOLVE.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
STATE HAS MADE A BIT.
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE INVESTMENT AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY THIS
IMPARTIALLY POLITIC COMMUNITIES.
ARE A PRIORITY AS A RESULT.
WE HAVE PUT POLICIES IN PLACE TO
ENSURE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
RECEIVE FUNDING [inaudible]
NOW WHETHER IT'S CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS S. B. ONE FUNDING OR THE
RECENTLY PASSED PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT BOND PARK ON WE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT.
WE ARE DIRECTLY TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE DOLLARS ARE
VERY COMPETITIVE.
AND AS A RESULT.
THESE ARE THE SAME COMMUNITIES
THE HOW TO HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
ACCESSING THE DOLLARS INTENDED
TO SERVE THEM.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WE ARE
TRYING TO SOLVE WITH SP.
TEN SEVENTY TWO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THESE INVESTMENTS THE
MOST ARE THE LEAST LIKELY
EQUIPPED. TO PUT COMPETITORS
GRANT APPLICATIONS TOGETHER TO
RECEIVE THE FUNDING.
THEY OFTEN DON'T HAVE GRANT
WRITERS [inaudible]
PROJECT MANAGERS.
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS OR PLANNERS
TO COMPETE AGAINST THE
COMMUNITIES TAT DO IN FACT.
WE WORK IN THESE COMMUNITIES AND
HAVE BEEN SEEN THIS PLAY OUT FOR
DECADES.
MUCH OF OUR WORK IS PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT AND GRANT
WRITING ON BEHALF OF LOCAL
NONPROFITS AND GOVERNMENTS.
AND WE ARE VERY PROUD TO HAVE
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
ACHIEVING GRANT FUNDING FROM
SOME STATE.
FROM THE STATE.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO PROVIDE THAT KIND OF CAPACITY
EVERYWHERE IT'S NEED IT.
WE NEED TO BUILD THAT CAPACITY
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY TO REALLY
SEE THE DOLLAR SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT IN THE NEEDIEST PLACE
THIS.
LASTLY I WANTTO THANK SENATOR
LEAVE UP FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE.
ARE CO SPONSORS.
AND OVER A HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING THE BROAD SPECTRUM
OF STAKEHOLDERS FORCE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
I GOOD EVENING AT THIS POINT --
ME WHEN WITH THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE AM THRILLED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE I'D LOVE TO SPEND A LITTLE
TIME TALKING ABOUT.
THE CONCEPT AND WHY WE'RE SO
EXCITED TO SUPPORT.
AND SEND IT.
TO I'M S. B. TENS OF NEED TO IS
A THREE INTERRELATED INTER
RELATED LAYERS RELATED TO
CAPACITY BUILDING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND TO BUILD CAPACITY IN OUR
MOST UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
THE FIRST LAYER IS CAPACITY
BUILDING THROUGH OVERCOMING THE
REGIONAL CLIMATE CLEVERNESS WE
SEE THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
CLEVERNESS AS THE LOCAL BOOTS ON
THE GROUND THE BACKBONE AND
CITY.
THAT'S THERE TO CONVENES TAKE
ALTOGETHER AROUND OUR REGION
EDUCATION PROJECT IDEATION
RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT PARTNERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT I'M ALL THESE
CAPACITY BUILDING ACTIVITIES.
A SECOND LAYER IS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ADMINISTERED BY THE
STATE --
ONCE A GIVEN COMMUNITY COMES
TOGETHER AROUND A PROJECT IDEA
THE TECHNICALS CONSIDERATIONS
OFTENTIMES STILL REMAIN A
CHALLENGE.
I'M ARE A BILL --
SIMPLY SAYS THAT --
CLIMATE GRANT PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
A SHOULD ALL HAVE A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE COMPLEX SYSTEMS
COMPONENT TO THAT WORK.
I'M IN THE LAST LAYER IS SIMPLY
A COORDINATION ALIGNMENT AND
CENTER NUYS ATION ARE BILL
IDENTIFIES AS SHE DID GROWTH
COUNCIL. TO DEVELOP A SET OF
GUIDELINES AND TO BUILD BEST
PRACTICES TO THE TOP AND BRING
IMPLEMENTERS TOGETHER TO
MAXIMIZE EMISSION EFFICIENCIES
--
AND BUILD BEST PRACTICES AROUND
BOTH IMPLEMENTING IMPLEMENTING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING.
WITH THAT WE ARE CHEN I'D VOTE
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA THINKING.
GOOD EVENING CARE ROUGHLY HAVE
TO CITY OF STOCKTON IN SUPPORT.
THE SILENCE WAS PUTTING HER ON
BEHALF OF THE NVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE MINISTER OF SPORT THINK
THAT.
WELCOME IT ON A WITH A LOT OF
ONE CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT.
PORTANTINO THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
HOLLY MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THINK.
GENEVIEVE OUT ON ON BEHALF OF
SEVEN GENERATION ADVISORS AND
SUPPORT.
COACH OF THE CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS
DANIELLE INCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AS FRIENDS OF
THE LA RIVER ALLEY NEIGHBORHOOD
LAND TRUST CENTRAL COAST ENERGY
SERVICES AND MAKE PENINSULA.
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
GEN A PRICE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTER SUPPORT.
I COOPER SO CALIFORNIA'S HINTS
HUESO I THINK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR FRETTING COUNTERSUNK
ALMOST RESENTMENTS THANK YOU.
AND IN ABOUT THIS WITH
CALIFORNIA ARMS TO SCIENCE IN
SUPPORT OF BILL AND THINK YOU
FOR INTRODUCING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ISRAEL'S.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE THE GOOD
SENATOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS
LEGISLATION.
OF I KNOW YOU HAVE A COMMUNITY
THAT [inaudible]
NEED CSUS.
AND I'M SURE THE COMMUNITY AND
ON THAT NOTE --
IF THE FEAR OF APPROPRIATE I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF YOUR BILL WE WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE THE ADDED ON THINK
THAT YOU THINK IS SIMPLY WOMAN.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WHAT ARE
OF QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR FOR
INTRIGUED IN THIS BILL WHICH
ELECT CLOSE RESPECT WESTERN AYE
VOTE RIGHT.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED
AND MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
I DON'T SIX S. B. TEN SEVENTY
TWO BY SENATOR LEYVA OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ARE OUT TO CHOI ROUTE TO
GI ACOSTA CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES KNOW RAYOS.
CHRIS AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE I FIVE ONE FIVE ONE THE
BILL'S ON CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THINKING
MEMBERS.
RHI SLEAZE SENATOR WINNER HERE.
SO WE WILL PROCEED TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE SP.
SEVENTY ONE I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF FOR US SCHEDULING
THIS BILL AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF.
OFFER WORKING SO DILIGENTLY WITH
US ON AMENDMENTS OUGHT TO THE
BILL WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
I KNOW I TOOK SOME WORK --
AND WE'RE HAPPY --
TO EXCEPT I THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS ARE AND INCLUDING YOU
ARE SPECIFICALLY MAKING SURE
THAT OUR ATTORNEYS FEES AWARDS
ARE RECIPROCAL IN ADDITION TO
THE OTHER AMENDMENTS THAT WE
AGREED TO SAID THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- I
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
DIVE THE OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL
TIME IF WE'RE ABLE TO GET.
A PASS TODAY'S HEARING UNTIL WE
GET TO APPROPRIATIONS OF THANK
YOU.
THAT'S TRUE SEVENTY ONE IS A
BILL. TO ADDRESS WHAT WE BELIEVE
IS A FUNDAMENTAL OVERSIGHT ARE
REGARDING THE THEFT OF
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL FROM SOLID
WASTE ENTERPRISES.
AUDITOR'S SANCTION MY LOCAL
AGENCIES --
I KNOW --
HIM IN MY TWO RECYCLING FAST IS
A BIG PROBLEM THAT UNDERMINES
OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM --
AND ENDS UP COSTING CONSUMERS
SIGNIFICANTLY.
I CURRENTLY AS YOU KNOW MANY
CITY SIGN FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS
WITH WASTE ENTERPRISES WHETHER
THROUGH COLLEGE HERE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION OR ANY OTHER.
A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS IS
CURBSIDE COLLECTION PROGRAMS
RECEIVE REVENUE OF A VARIABLE
RATE MAKING BASED ON TIME IS SO
WHY WASTE COLLECTED.
THE PROBLEM OF COURSE IS AN
UNAUTHORIZED HOLDERS ARE
COLLECTING SOLID WASTE BY
ILLEGAL BUSINESS PRACTICES OR
THEFT OF RECYCLING MATERIAL FROM
THE CURB.
OVER TIME THE STAFF HAS INVOLVED
INTO LARGE SCALE CRIMINAL
OPERATIONS WITH FLEETS OF
VEHICLES MONITORING COLLECTION
ROUTES OPEN THE OPERATING
COMMUNITIES ON THE DESIGNATED
COLLECTIONS DAYS AS A SHOP A
LITTLE BIT BEFORE --
THE GARBAGE TRUCKS RECYCLING
TRUCK SHOWS UP AND TAKE
EVERYTHING WELL BEYOND ITS AYE
AYE STEVENSON MY OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE I LIVE AND
I'VE BEEN SAYING IT FOR YEARS
AND I SAW MY NEIGHBORS.
AND VERY FRUSTRATING OUT TO ALL
OF US AND PEOPLE WONDER WHY
ISN'T ANYONE DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT THESE --
CRIMINAL SYNDICATES --
CURRENT LAW AND THE REASON IS
THE CURRENT LAW REALLY DOES NOT
PROVIDE A REAL DISINCENTIVE --
TO FOR PEOPLE TO REFRAIN FROM
STEALING --
VIOLATIONS ARE RARELY PROSECUTED
--
BECAUSE PERPETRATORS ARE HARD TO
TRACK AND LITIGATION COSTS ARE
HIGH -- THIS
BILL WOULD THEREFORE I PROHIBIT
ANY PERSON OTHER THAN A SOLID
WASTE ENTERPRISE AUTHORIZED BY
THE COUNTY.
FROM COLLECTING REMOVING OR
TRANSPORTING SOLID WASTE --
AND IT AUTHORIZES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES TO PURSUE
CIVIL ACTIONS FOR THE THEFT OF
RECYCLABLE MATERIALS.
AND OF THE PLAN IT PREVAILS IN A
CIVIL ACTION OTHER COURT WILL
WORD ARE REASONABLE ATTORNEYS
FEES RECIPROCALLY --
AND OTHER COSTS INCURRED --
SUPPORTING OTHER SPILL OVER
FIFTY LOCAL LOCALLY AUTHORIZE
WASTE COLLECTION ENTERPRISES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY ARE --
DETACHING FROM ECOLOGY HELGA
FROM REPUBLIC SERVICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S ERIC PASSION WITH
RECOLOGY RECOLOGY PROVIDES WASTE
RECYCLING IN ORGANIC SERVICES TO
OVER A HUNDRED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
A BUSY DEL NORTE COUNTY ALL THE
WAY DOWN THE CURRENT COUNTIES
OUR FOOTPRINT.
SO IS THE CENTER SAID WE ARE
EXPERIENCING THESE --
FAT ALONG LARGE SCALE THEFT IN A
RECYCLING PROGRAMS --
WE'RE ALSO SEEING WHERE WERE AND
MORE AMBITIOUS HONESTLY WITH A
RECYCLING PROGRAMS.
ON AUTHORIZED HOLLERS COMING IN
GOING TO CUSTOMERS THAT FRANKLY
ARE JUST LOOKING FOR CHEAP
SERVICE AND PROVIDING THAT
SERVICE WHERE NOT AUTHORIZED TO
DO SO --
WITH ACTION PROVIDE ME ACTUAL
RECYCLING A BENEFICIAL SERVICES
AT BOTH THE STATE MANDATES IN
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MANDATE.
THE IN THE DAY ARE --
PROCESSES IN OUR PROGRAMS ARE
BASED OPERATE MODEL THAT RAY
MODELS BASED ON TONNAGES
CUSTOMER ACCOUNT IN REVENUE OFF
OF RECYCLABLES NAM AS ROSSINI'S
OF ACTIVITIES A GROWING GROW.
THAT RATE MODELS CAN CHIP AWAY
AT AN HONESTLY THAT.
THE PROGRAM WHETHER IT'S
FISCALLY SOUND POSTED BY PAY
UNION WAGES FOR THE DRIVERS IN
THE SORTERS ALL THAT GETS UPSET.
AS THE SENATOR SAID THE ABILITY
TO COLLECT ATTORNEYS FEES WILL
GIVE US A CHARITY THAT WE SHOULD
GO AND GO AFTER THESE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN A WAY THAT WE
KNOW THAT WILL AT LEAST BE ABLE
TO STOP THIS ACTIVITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOT CHUCK CHO IT SEASON.
AND THE COPS CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE.
I WANT TO START OFF BY THANKING
THE STAFF WORKING ON THIS.
FOR OVER THREE YEARS NOW AND
WE'VE SEEN DIFFERENT RATIONS OF
THE SPELL AND IT'S BEEN PRETTY
CONTENTIOUS AT TIMES.
THE AMENDMENT AS PROPOSED REALLY
DO ADDRESS MOST OF THE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
ANY POTENTIAL CONCERNS OF
UNFAIRNESS.
OR OR ANY SORT OF ABUSE WAS
REALLY ADDRESSED IN THAT MEN
MINTS THAT ARE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
WHICH IS WHY WE'VE NOW COME ON
IN SUPPORT --
WE'VE PASSED A VARIETY OF LAWS
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS TO A
RECYCLING CALIFORNIA REALLY BE A
LEADER NATIONALLY.
AND I IN ORDER TO SUCCEED AND
THOSE GOALS.
WE NEED THAT THAT'S ALWAYS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD --
PROJECTS AND FACILITIES THAT
COST TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND THAT'S SIMPLY NOT POSSIBLE
WITHOUT FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS IN
LONG TERM.
FEEDSTOCK COMMITMENTS AND THIS
BILL GUARANTEE THAT IN A WAY
THAT'S FAIR.
AND HAS A THREE YEAR SUNSET TO
ALLOW US TO COME BACK IN REVIEW
HOW IT'S BEING IMPLEMENTED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU OKAY.
FUTURE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHUCK HELD IT TO REPRESENT
REPUBLIC SERVICES SO WE PROVIDE
SOLID WASTE RECYCLING COMPOSTING
AND COLLECTION SERVICES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
JUST VERY BRIEFLY THE A
FRANCHISE SYSTEM SAID BOTH OF
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
I MENTIONED ARE A PROCESS THAT
WE GO THROUGH IT WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IT'S AN OPEN PUBLIC
PROCESS.
AND THROUGH THOSE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ESSENTIALLY
IMPLEMENT AB NINE THIRTY NINE
AND THE OTHER STATUTES THAT HAVE
BEEN HANDED DOWN AND RECORD OF
THEM -- TH
AND IT IS AN OPEN PUBLIC PROCESS
IN AND WE THINK THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE ARE BEST
SUITED TO MAKE THOSE THOSE
DECISIONS.
FOUND THIS BILL DOESN'T AFFECT
THAT PROCESS IN ANY WAY IT IT'S
SIMPLY ADDS ATTORNEY'S FEES TO
OUR ACTIONABLE.
ITEMS WHEN WE TRIED WOULD FORCE
OUR FRANCHISE AGREEMENT THANK.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
TENNIS LOW PURPLE WASTE
CONNECTIONS IN SUPPORT.
JOSH PUNNY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSE RECYCLING COUNCIL
SUPPORT.
JEAN IRVINE ON BEHALF OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THEY MOVED INTO.
DO YOU THINK CLEAR ONE CHAIR AND
VICE IN SPACE FOR THE
OPPOSITION.
WELL.
THEY DENNIS ALBION HIM ON BEHALF
OF THE COMFORTING GREEN FEES
ASSOCIATION THE PACIFIC EGG AND
POULTRY ASSOCIATION.
ON THE PACIFIC COAST RENNER'S
SUSPICION.
AND I THINK OF YOU FOLKS ARE
GOING TO SPEAK TODAY ARE ON
BEHALF OF ORGANIC RECYCLAGE
WE'VE BEEN RECYCLING ORGANICS
FAR BEFORE.
THERE WAS CAL RECYCLE OR MANY
THESE ENTITIES WERE INVOLVED IN
THE RECYCLING SIDE THAT WAS THE
THAT WAS THE IT WAS A SOLID
WASTE I THINK [inaudible]
INTERCHANGEABLY.
AND IN FACT IF YOU LOOK AT SOME
OF THE RECYCLERS LIKE THE BOTTLE
BILL.
JUST OVER THERE SO THIS IS
REALLY THIS EXTENDS THIS TO THE
SOLID WASTE TO THE GARBAGE SIDE
OF THE BUSINESS OR IN OUR BILL
WHAT WE DEAL WITH THIS ORGANICS.
AND THE CONCERN IS THAT SOME OF
THE ORGANICS.
WE'LL BE THAT THAT THESE CHURCH
OR CONTRACTS WILL BE ENFORCED
AGAINST BOTH FOLKS THAT MAY BE.
UP PICKING UP THAT ARE AT A
CHARGE OR EVEN AGAINST FOLKS
THAT ARE NOT --
THAT ARE THAT ARE PAYING FOR THE
MATERIAL THEY WILL STILL GET A
AGGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
AGAINST THEM AND THEN HAVE TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
AND THAT'S A YOU KNOW THAT'S A
THE TO COST SYMBOL OF OUR
CLIENTS AND MEMBERS OF THE
VARIOUS ASSOCIATIONS OF OUR
SMALLER ENTITIES.
THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ENFORCE
IT SO THEY JUST WALK AWAY FROM A
LEGITIMATE BUSINESS INTERESTS
THAT THEY HAVE.
AND IT LIKE TO REMIND FOLKS THAT
EARLIER THIS YEAR YOU PASSED A.
B. THIRTY THIRTY SIX NOW HAS NOT
BECOME LAW YET BUT IT IS MOVING
TO THE PROCESS.
THAT WAS TO DRESS THIS VERY STE
ONE NARROW PART OF OUR CONCERNS
[inaudible]
WHICH IS.
THAT WOULD ALLOW IT --
MATERIAL THAT'S INTENDED FOR
LIVESTOCK FEED TO BE NOT DIE --
TO BE CATEGORIZED AS ALWAYS SO
THAT ONE SMALL SO THIS GOES ON
THE EXACT OPPOSITE DIRECTION --
WE WOULD LOVE TO IF.
WE WE PROPOSE SOME.
OUR ALTERNATIVES AND SOME SOME
THINGS SAY HEY IF YOU'RE A
LICENSED BUT DEPARTMENT WHO DIED
TO DO GRAIN FEED IF YOU'RE THOSE
CUTTINGS.
THOSE ARE TYPES OF IDEAS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO ADVANCE FORWARD --
WE'RE TALKING TO THE TO THE
FOLKS.
THAT THEY'RE PROPOSING THIS IF
THEY WANTED TO REMOVE ORGANICS
FROM IT THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER
OPTION SO LOT OF OPTIONS CAN BE
BROUGHT FORWARD TO TO MAKE THIS
OUT WORK A LITTLE BETTER.
ARE BASICALLY COMMENT NUMBER
THREE FROM THE ANALYSIS IS
REALLY WHERE WE ARE THAT THOSE
ARE THE FOLKS THAT WE REPRESENT.
OTHER WORKING IN MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS.
PROVIDING WORK PROVIDING THE
SERVICE AND WE THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS SO THAT'S
WHERE WERE YOU A THAT'S WHO WE
REPRESENT AND WE OPPOSE --
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR TO WORKING OUT AS
IT MOVES.
GOOD AFTERNOON ABOUT CREAMERS A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
VIRTUALLY WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED
BECAUSE OUR MEMBERS RELY ON SOME
OF THESE ORGANIC MATERIALS. ONE
THERE HELPING TO PRODUCE THEM
BUT TO THEIR ALSO HELPING TO USE
AND THE END PRODUCTS IN THOSE
BYPRODUCTS. FOR ANIMAL FEEDS A
41% OF A DAIRY COWS DIET IN
CALIFORNIA IS MADE UP OF
BYPRODUCTS FROM OUR FOOD
PROCESSING INDUSTRIES AND SO WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IN
MAKING IT HARDER TO ACCESS SOME
OF THOSE MATERIALS AND SO WE
WANT AS MISTER ALBION MENTIONED
ON?
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORTED AND
PASSED A. B. THIRTY EARLIER
WHICH WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE STILL CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE MATERIALS AND WE
THINK THAT THIS BILL DOES THE
EXACT OPPOSITE MAKES IT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT AND ADDS COSTS TO
THAT [inaudible]
SO AND WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THOSE
ACTIVITIES ARE NOT INCLUDED
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME.
FOR CODY BOILS AND A BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED ABOUT HIS
ALLIANCE NEVER POST [inaudible]
IF YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE MS
EGGMAN --
THANK YOU AND I'M.
SO MIKE MY CONCERNS URBAN MAN
BAG BRAZIN ERIC AREA WITH A LOT
OF AGRICULTURE AND THAT THE
DEFINITION OF WASTE IS TOO
BROAD.
COM IF THE YOU LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE FROM AB THIRTY THIRTY
SIX IF IT DOES.
IT.
MOVES IT DEBT IT MOVES IT FROM
THERE AND IT DOESN'T EVEN
INCLUDE BY PROCESSING AND AND
FOOD PRODUCTS --
SO I THINK THAT IS UP DIRECTION
YOU WANT TO MOVE I MEAN I THINK
WE NEED THE MARKET SO WE NEED TO
HAVE THAT CERTAINTY ON THAT.
HOWEVER.
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
NOT BEEN GOING TO THE HOLLERS
ARE HISTORICALLY HAVE NOT BEEN
GOING TO LANDFILLS OR EVER THE
TYPES OF PROCESSING PLANTS I
DON'T THINK SHOULD BE.
INCLUDED IN THAT AM.
I GREW UP ON A FARM THERE'S A
LOT OF APPLICATION TO THE
ORCHARDS THAT HAD NO WASTE
HAULER WANT --
BUT HELPS THINGS GROW SO THOSE
ARE MY CONCERNS ARM AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOU CONTINUE TO MAKE
AMENDMENTS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
I THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I KNOW THERE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
INCORPORATING AN EXEMPTION FROM
AB THREE A THREE SEX.
I GUESS IT'S AYE SIR OF BE FOR
ABOUT WHICH UPRIGHT POT
BYPRODUCTS OR EXEMPTED AND WE
ARE.
GOING TO DO THAT --
IF IT'S INCLUDED IN THAT
EXEMPTION WERE INCLUDED IN ITS
ENTIRETY THERE WAS SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER WE
WOULD BE THAT ENTIRE EXEMPTION
OR OR ONLY.
A MOVED --
SOBRE OPEN THE DOING THAT --
AND AND AND JUST TO BE VERY.
CLEAR ABOUT THAT I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WAS DISCUSSED ARE NOT
CORRECT.
I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
THANK YOU AS IT COMES MY
COMMITTEE NEXT.
I HAVE SIMILAR CONCERNS ARE
COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDS.
THIS NOTION OF THE THEFT OUT OF
THE SYSTEM.
BUT IN A LOT OF AREAS THAT ARE
RURAL SORT OF MIXED RURAL.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS THAT EASY TO DO
AND IT'S AND THERE'S NOT ALWAYS
A SITUATION WHERE.
SOMEBODY WHO IS.
HAULING OR CLEANING UP IS PER SE
AUTHORIZED BY THE JURISDICTION
TO GO CLEAN UP AND THIS IS WHAT
WE HAVE TO THREAD HERE PREVENT
THE THEFT OF IT BUT ALSO.
ALLOW THE FUNCTIONS THAT WERE
THERE WHEN THAT FRANCHISE
AGREEMENT WAS PUT INTO PLACE.
BECAUSE IT'S KNOWN THERE ARE.
DIFFERENT ENTITIES HAULING
THINGS LIKE WHO CARDBOARD OR
WASTE FROM RESTAURANTS AGO
RENDERERS OR THAT.
ITO YARD TRIMMINGS OR
AGRICULTURAL WASTE OR ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS AND ESPECIALLY AREAS
WHERE YOU HAVE THE MIX --
OF OR OR FRINGES OF HIS IT THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY COVER THE
ENTIRE JURISDICTION BECAUSE A
LOT OF PLACES DON'T HAVE
CURBSIDE.
RECYCLING OR WASTE ALL THAT SO
THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S A REAL
MIX OF OF ENTITIES THERE AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
BREAKING DOWN THOSE EXISTING
SERVICES THAT ARE THERE.
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO FUNCTION
AND OPERATE IN THE WAY THAT WAS
INTENDED BUT THEN STOP THAT
WOULD.
THE THEFT OF WHAT WOULD BE
EXPECTED WHEN THAT FRANCHISE
AGREEMENT WAS PUT IN PLACE NOW
THAT'S COULD BE DIFFERENT FOR
JURISDICTION JURISDICTION
FRANCHISE AGREEMENT FRANCHISE
AGREEMENT THAT'S I THINK WHAT'S
DIFFICULT.
ABOUT THIS BILL AND ENSURING
THAT WE'RE WE'RE STOPPING THE
THOUGHT THAT THE FRANCHISE.
THE FRANCHISEE GETS THE BENEFIT
OF WHAT THEY HAD.
NEGOTIATED AND TRY TO GET BUT
ALSO ALLOW FOR THE EXISTING
KINDS OF OPERATIONS THAT HAD
BEEN THERE THAT WEREN'T
NECESSARILY CONTEMPLATED THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL SO THIS COULD BE SOME
AMENDMENTS COMING UP IN THE NEXT
MILLION JUDICIARY.
I'M GONNA SUPPORT YOU HEAR
MOVING FORWARD BUT I I HOPE WE
CAN ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES WE GET
THAT EXTRA UP THROUGH IT WILL
CONTINUE TO OUR OWN WE WE WANT
TO DO EXACTLY THE SAME AND
MISTER HOGAN I THINK CAN.
RESPOND RATHER JUST JUST A QUICK
QUICK RESPONSE TO THAT
ASSEMBLYMAN STONE AND TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
ON THIS BILL DOESN'T.
EXPAND OUR AUTHORITY UNDER
FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS IT THOUGH
WHAT'S IN PLACE RIGHT NOW IN
TERMS OF THE FRANCHISE AGREEMENT
WHICH CONTINUE TO BE IN PLACE.
IT GIVES US THE AUTHORITY UNDER
AND ADDITIONAL PIECE OF
AUTHORITY. TO ASSESSED LEGAL
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
FRANCHISE --
WITH THOSE EXISTING FRANCHISE
AGREE SO WE'RE NOT EXPANDING THE
FRIGHT BUT WHAT I DON'T WANT TO
SEE IS FOR SOMEONE WITH A
FRANCHISE AGREEMENT NOW.
IRRITATED AT SOME OPERATION THAT
HAS BEEN THERE IN BECAUSE THERE
IS THE LEVERAGE OF ATTORNEY
CAESAR AND AND OTHER
IMPLICATIONS SAY I'M GONNA GO
SHUT YOU DOWN [inaudible]
WHEN?
WHEN THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT?
POTENTIALLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CONTEMPLATED BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY SOMEBODY WAS HAULING
SOMETHING THAT IS APPROVED BY
THAT JURISDICTION.
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU
THAT AUTHORITY TO GO AFTER
SOMEBODY I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE THAT JURISDICTION
THAT THE OTHER PARTIES WOULD
AGREE OKAY THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WE GAVE YOU.
SO YOU CAN GO STOP SOMEBODY ELSE
FROM INFRINGING ON YOUR
FRANCHISE BUT I DON'T WANT THE
FRANCHISEE TO GO BEYOND.
WHAT THAT EXPECTATION THIS WHICH
IS WHY?
SINCE WE'RE DOING STATEWIDE MAY.
THERE NOT BE THAT EASY TO A
SURLY DICTATE BY.
BECAUSE OF SOME THE IT BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE COMPLEXITIES AND
IN VARIOUS JURISDICTIONS
INTERSECTIONS LIKE MY EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS WE'VE DONE THIS.
IN IN MY COUNTY.
THAT DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU'RE DOING BUT I'M ALSO A
LITTLE BIT LEADER MAKE SURE WE
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TOO FAR OR
INTERRUPTING THOSE OPERATIONS
THAT THE COMMUNITIES COUNTY.
THAT'S A AND I WHO OWNED A
BELIEF THURSDAY SIR.
THURSDAY I THINK WERE GOING TO
BE INTO SURE.
YEAH NEXT NEXT WEEK.
IF NEXT WEEK MY APOLOGIES --
SO WE'LL HAVE SOME TIME TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL DO
SO.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
XENA A SENATOR [inaudible]
I WE HAD A BRIEF CONVERSATION ON
THE FLOOR YOU KNOW LAST WEEK I
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S YOU MADE OF
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS --
NOT A WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
THAT --
FURTHER.
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS TO BE
HAD WITH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND SO ON DUH.
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND OF FOR
THAT REASON HELPING SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU MISTER WHICH
LIKE CLOTHES.
I RESPECT WESTERN IVA.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
RIGHT THERE ROLL CALL PLEASE
ITEM ONE SB SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT SO SHE AYE
ROUTE TO CHI AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NOT VOTING CHAU
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING FLORA.
LOW MOAN.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE I THREE ZERO CHRIS HELD
THE BILL'S ON CALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT SO I SEE THE NUMBER OF
SENATORS BEFORE SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE CENTER HERTZBERG
IS HERE AND SO.
CENTERS.
FOR I CAN START WITH SENATOR.
DOLE IN PRESENTING HER MANAGER
OKAY.
THAT WOULD BE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
SP THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BELT.
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
INCLUDES THE RIGS TO REEFS
MEASURE INTO THIS BILL ON THE
HAVE A PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
VERY GO EXOTIC BECAUSE THEY LOVE
IT.
BUT GIVE ME JUST TELL YOU REAL
QUICKLY THAT ON THIS BILL DEALS
WITH THE SAN DIEGO RIVERS
WATERSHED CONSORTIUM PROGRAM IN
THE PLACENTA REVERSES WATER
CONSORTIUM AREA.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THIS IT SPANS
FOREIGN FORTY SQUARE MILES
INCLUDING SIX MAJOR RESERVOIRS
FOR CITIES A LARGE AREA OF
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY LANDS.
CLEVELAND NATIONAL FOREST NATIVE
AMERICAN RESERVATIONS FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVING
WITHIN THAT AREA.
THE EXPECTED OVER THE NEXT
NUMBER OF YEARS TO REACH BY
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR MILLION PEOPLE
AND SO WHAT THE PRO TEM IS DOING
WITH THIS MEASURE JUST VERY
BRIEFLY.
IS PUTTING TOGETHER A SERIES OF
ADVISORY PANELS TO HELP DESIGN
THE DIRECTION.
OUR INTO ASSISTED HI RIVER
SWEETWATER RIVER --
WANNA RIVER BY CREATING THESE
PANELS TO IN IN THAT RESTORE
ENHANCE THESE RESOURCE US YOU
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE HAVE
WITNESSES. TWENTY PROCEED AS
STARTER YOU WERE ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS AND UPLOAD DATA
BREAKS TO REEF.
MOTIONS YET IN THEM WITH HIM
EVENTS WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
BRICKS REPEATS YEAH THAT'S OKAY
WE'RE GONNA MINUTE YOUR BILL
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF SAN DIEGO MAYOR KEVIN
FAULCONER IN THE ENTIRE CITY
COUNCIL WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE.
OF THE RIVER COULD FINAGLE RIVER
CONSERVANCY --
IS A INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM THE CITY HAS ON A NUMBER
OF REPRESENTATIVES --
ON THE CONSERVANCY AND THE THREE
RIVERS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ADDING INTO THE CONSERVANCY
THROUGH THIS BILL ALL OPERATE --
ARE ALL FLOW THROUGH THE THE
CITIES --
LIMITS AND WE THINK THAT THERE
ARE SOME GREAT --
ECONOMIES OF SCALE THAT CAN
REALLY BE EMPLOYED HERE --
BY ADDING IN THESE --
ADDITIONAL REVERSE TO REALLY --
ENHANCE OF THE WONDER AND BEAUTY
THAT ISN'T SAN DIEGO WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE PORTA
SAN DIEGO ALSO IN SUPPORT BOTH
THE SWEETWATER RIVER IN A TIGHT
RIVER FLOWED DIRECTLY INTO SAN
DIEGO BAY --
AS THE STEWARD OF SAN DIEGO BAY
THAT IS DIRECTLY IMPACT THE PORT
WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING THROUGH
THIS BILL ON THOSE AS WELL THAT
HE WON A RIVER WHICH IMPACTS THE
TIDE WENT OF IMPERIAL BEACH
WHICH IS ANOTHER. ONE OF OUR
MEMBER CITIES PARENTS SUPPORT
AND FOR THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT SO ELEMENT SALAS PARTY
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION IS THIRTY AND
STRONG SUPPORT THINK PRO TEM AND
SENATOR HERTZBERG FROM THE WORK.
DANIELLE AND TOM BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORT.
MILLION OR TEASE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN THE WEAPONS CONSERVANCY IN
SPORT THINKS.
MORGAN CLEAN FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
AND HE THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOTION WAS MADE AND SECONDED.
CENTER WAS LIKE CLOSE AYE VOTE
PLEASE.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I DON'T TWELVE SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR ATKINS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ROUTES RICHIE
AYE MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE.
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
LIMO.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ BREASTS.
REYES AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE I FIVE ZERO BY ZERO THE
BILL'S ON CALL.
WHICH USES LIKE TO GO WITH NEXT
SENATOR --
THE SP.
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN ALRIGHT THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SP ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN GREAT.
THERE TWENTY SEVEN OFFSHORE
PLATFORMS OFF OF THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA TWENTY SEVEN OF THEM.
AND WE'RE TRYING THROUGH
RESPONSIBLE POLICY FOR THE LAST
THREE AND A HALF FOUR YEARS IN
THE RIGS TO REEFS BILL OF THIS
IS NOT THE RICH TO BE BILL
LEVELS THAT TOMORROW YOUR BILL.
CHAIRMAN BUT THE THE THE ARE
WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH THESE
THINGS IN A WAY THAT IS
THOUGHTFUL ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ON THE ONE HAND AND YET ON THE
OTHER HAND.
DEALING WITH THE EXTRAORDINARY
FINANCIAL CHALLENGE THAT WE
FACED.
AND THE HOUSE WE WERE DEALING
WITH THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR THE
PLATFORM HOLLY AND RINCON
ISLAND.
HAD BIG GIGANTIC PROBLEMS.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS UNDER THE LAW
THE WHEN THESE PLATFORMS WERE
CLICK QUICK CLAIM BACK TO THE
STATE BECAUSE THEY FILED
BANKRUPTCY IN THERE WAS NO MONEY
AVAILABLE? TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR
THIS STUFF.
THERE'S A BOND THAT'S THAT'S
POSTED IN THE BOND I THINK WAS
--
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS MY
RECOLLECTION WITH RESPECT A
PLATFORM HOLLY BUT WE JUST HAD
TO TRANSFER A HUNDRED EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL
FUND JUST TO PAY FOR PHASE ONE
OF DECOMMISSIONING THE PLATFORM
OF THE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
MONEY THEY COULD USE FOR
EDUCATION MONEY WE COULD USE TO
CLEAN UP THE BEACHES MONEY WE
COULD USE --
FOR FOSTER KIDS AND ALL SORTS OF
OTHER THINGS BUT BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A PROPER MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM FOR THESE VARIOUS THINGS.
WHAT WE AFTER WE WERE TRYING TO
FIX THIS IN A SERIES OF BILLS
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY?
IS BASICALLY ASKING THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF FOR A BONDING THAT
THEY HAVE FOR THESE THINGS WHEN
THEY GO UPSIDE DOWN.
AND SO THIS IS THIS BILL CAME AS
A RESULT OF THOSE TWO
BANKRUPTCIES LAST YEAR.
AND I'M ASKING THAT YOU SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE [inaudible]
LET ME.
REQUIRES BOTH DAHLGREN THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION TO SEEK THOSE
HIGHER BONDING AUTHORITIES
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT JENNA PRICE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAVE
CONSERVATION VOTERS CHAPLAIN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU.
AND FOR THE WAY THIS ISN'T PART.
CNN ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
I'M FOR IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS WE
CENTERS WITH THE WESTERN SICK
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WE
REGRETTABLY ARE HERE.
AND OPPOSITION TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG STILL S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN BUT BEFORE.
I BEGIN I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
GET TENDERNESS STAFF FOR THE
OPEN DIALOGUE --
THE BILL AS A MAN I'M VERY
CONCERNED --
AND WE'RE PRIMARILY OPPOSITION
BECAUSE THE LACK OF SPECIFICITY
ON IN REGARD TO THE FUNDING
SOURCE.
AND IT CREATES A CONCERN THAT
EVEN OWNERS AND OPERATORS OF OF
WELLS ARE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
HOLD THE STATE LEASE MAYBE FORCE
THINKER NEW FEES.
AND COSTS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY'RE IN GOOD COMPLIANCE --
AND YOU KNOW FULFILLING THE THE
THE REQUIREMENTS TO THE
SATISFACTION OF THE STATE --
THERE ARE WHISPER MEMBERS WITH
ACTIVE --
OPERATIONS IN STATE WATERS THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
BONDING AND DECOMMISSIONING
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE AT THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION --
STOOD THE EXISTENCE OF THE
FINALIZED AGREEMENTS AYE NASCENT
RESOLVES PART OF WHAT THE BILL
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS --
ALTHOUGH WELL INTENTIONED AYE WE
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL OF FINANCIAL EXPOSURES
THAT MAY BE INCURRED BY --
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS THAT HOLD
THE A LEASE WITH THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION SO FOR THOSE REASONS.
WE MUST --
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY WITNESS
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAY NO QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTIONS WERE MADE THEIR SECOND.
QUESTIONS --
MUCH HAS BEEN SECONDED --
CENTER WAS REALLY CLOSE.
YEAH I JUST I JUST WANT TO
MENTION WITH RESPECT TO THE
OPPOSITION'S WHERE THERE ARE
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE THEIR
GRANDFATHER IN WE SEE THAT THE
HUNTINGTON BEACH OIL FIELD.
AND THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
THAT'S HAPPENED AGAIN WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IN TRYING TO
ESTABLISH RESPONSIBLE --
ACT THE BUSH FOR THAT FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY WITH RESPECT TO
THESE OIL WELLS --
WE WERE JUST SIMPLY REVIEWING
THE SIZE OF THE THESE OLD ON THE
BOND AUTHORITIES TO FIND OUT
IMMEDIATE IN AND FIND OUT WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE AND IF YOU NEED TO
TO LOOK AT THEM AGAIN.
WHAT HAPPENED A PLATFORM ONLY
WORKED FOR UPSIDE DOWN RIGHT
THAT'S THE REASON WHY I'M TRYING
TO REACH A REEF BECAUSE I'M
TRYING TO CREATE A REVENUE
STREAM? TO AVOID THIS PROBLEM
AND DEAL WITH RESPONSIBLE OF
PLANNING WITH RESPECT TO
DECOMMISSIONING OF THESE SIR.
TWENTY SEVEN NINE OFFSHORE OIL
WAS US WHO SUPPORT.
BECKY MOTIONS MAY BEEN MADE AND
SECONDED ADAM SECTOR OF
POLITICAL.
I AM A SB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS
TO PASS ONLY FOR TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ROUTE SWITCHING AYE MURATSUCHI
AYE ACOSTA [inaudible]
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
LIMON MCCARTY MELENDEZ REYES.
CHRIS AYE STONE [inaudible]
THREE ZERO RESULT OF THE BILL'S
ONCOL.
OKAY THANK YOU IN MY LAST BILL
I'M GONNA PULL AND PUT THE
CONTENTS TOMORROW IN YOUR BILL
AND BUT SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
IT WE HAVE AUTHOR OF CENTER
GLAZER.
S. IS ITEM NUMBER THREE SB.
FOUR FIFTY TWO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WANNA FIRST --
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE.
THANK THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR WORKING SO CLOSELY
WITH OUR OFFICE IN OUR
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL HE'S
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE DETAILED IN
THE HANDOUT PROVIDED BY THE
COMMITTEE HELP FOCUS THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
ON RETURNING LONG TERM STABILITY
TO THE RECYCLING COLLECTION IN
CAPTURE.
WHILE PROTECTING THE CONSUMERS
ABILITY READING CONTAINERS.
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
ACT WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
IN ORDER TO MARKET BASED SYSTEM
TO REDUCE LITTER.
AND INCREASE RECYCLING AT BOTH
BY BACK CENTERS AND CURBSIDE.
THE SYSTEM KNOWN AS THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM
WHERE THE BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM.
HAS DIVERTED TONS OF BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS FROM LANDFILLS.
AND FOR MOST OF THE LAST THREE
DECADES HAS BEEN SEEN AS A MODEL
RECYCLING PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROGRAM
SUFFERED A SIGNIFICANT SETBACK
BEGINNING IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN STEMMING FROM A
REDUCTION IN FEES PAID BY THE
STATE. TO RECYCLERS AND A
PRECIPITOUS A CLIENT IN GLOBAL
COMMODITY PRICES.
IT'S ONE TWO PUNCH LED TO THE
CLOSURE OF NEARLY ONE THOUSAND
RECYCLING CENTERS.
ROUGHLY 38% OF THE STATEWIDE
TOTAL.
LEAVING CONSUMERS IN MANY
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT A LOCAL
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITY.
THERE ARE NOW ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE CALIFORNIA CITIES
INTO ENTIRE COUNTIES WITH NO
OPERATING REDEMPTION CENTERS.
SUBSEQUENTLY RECYCLING RATES
HAVE DROPPED FROM A HIGH OF 85%
FOUR YEARS AGO TO GET 75% LAST
YEAR.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CONTAINERS
ARE STILL REDEEMED BY CONSUMERS
FOR CASH.
BUT BECAUSE OF CENTER CLOSURES
CONSUMER REDEMPTIONS BEEN REDUCE
BY UPWARDS OF THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PER MONTH COMPARED. TO
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES THIS BILL AS
AMENDED WILL IMPLEMENT THREE KEY
ELEMENTS TO STABILIZE THE BOTTOM
OF THE BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM.
FIRST THE BILL RESTORE RECYCLING
INCENTIVES TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN LEVELS.
REFLECTIVE OF COST OF LIVING AND
REASONABLE FINANCIAL RETURN
ADJUSTMENTS.
SECONDLY THE BILL RESTORE
PLASTIC RECYCLING MARKET
DEVELOPMENT INCENTIVES THAT
SUNSET AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND RECYCLERS WE'RE
STILL EXPERIENCING DEPRESSED
RECYCLING MARKETS.
AND FINALLY THE BILL OR REFOCUS
CAO RECYCLE.
THEIR RESOURCES ON BRINGING
RECYCLING OPPORTUNITIES TO
HUNDREDS OF UNDERSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
WHILE PROVIDING LIMITED
TEMPORARY RELIEF TO DEALERS FACE
WITH TAKE BACK REQUIREMENTS AT
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
AND WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN I
ASK RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY I'VE THREE
WITNESSES WITH ME. TO ELABORATE
OUT FIRST MARK MURRAY.
I WOULD CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE SECONDLY JEFF DON LEVY
FROM THINGS RECYCLING.
AND THIRD JIM STATURE FROM
VALLEY SPRINGS RECYCLING WITH
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU SIR
BEFORE YOU PROCEED --
ARE YOU ACCEPTING ALL LOWER
PROPOSED COMEDIAN AMENDMENTS FAN
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK MURRAY
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE FOR THREE YEARS NOW --
THAT ALMOST A A PERFECT STORM OF
A GLOBAL DROP IN COMMODITY
PRICES COMBINED WITH A A
REDUCTION IN PAYMENTS AND FROM
CAL RECYCLE THE REDUCTION IN THE
PAYMENTS WASN'T THE FAULT OF CAL
RECYCLE.
IT WAS THE FAULT OF AN OUTDATED
FORMING SURVEYED EXPENDITURES.
AND LOOK WHAT HAPPENED WAS WHICH
AS AS CAL RECYCLE WAS SURVEYING
THE EXPENDITURES TO DETERMINE
THE NEXT PAYMENT.
THEY WERE SERVING IN ENVIRONMENT
WENT RECYCLERS WERE LOSING SO
MUCH MONEY FOR BECAUSE OF THIS
PRECIPITOUS DROP IN SCRAP VALUE.
THAT ALL THEY COULD DO IS REPORT
THE EXPENDITURES SO THAT'S WHAT
WE GOT IN THIS MESS.
THIS THE THREE SOLUTIONS THERE
IN THIS BILL HAVE BEEN PART OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
BUDGET IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I THINK THAT
WERE NOW ALREADY. TO ADVANCE
PEACE PROPOSALS THAT DETAILS --
A SOME OF THE THE CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN WORKED OUT IN TERMS OF
THESE AMENDMENTS VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE TIME IN THE
ENERGY OF THE STAFF --
THIS IS GOING TO RETURN PAYMENTS
TO TWENTY FIFTEEN LEVELS AND
THAT'S THE CORE ISSUE THAT WAS
HARMING THE RECYCLING SECTOR.
CLICK HERE FROM SOME REAL LIVE
RECYCLERS.
URGING AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEFF
DONLEVY WITH WINGS RECYCLING.
PLANT MEANS RECYCLING HAS
FACILITIES IN HAYWARD AND
SACRAMENTO.
THE COMPANY WAS STARTED BY A
VIETNAMESE IMMIGRANT BACK IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND WE'VE
GROWN TO BE ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROCESSORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
DEATHLY IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
--
WE BUY MATERIAL FROM OVER A
HUNDRED RECYCLING CENTERS SO
YOU'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO THE OPERATORS.
PRETTY MUCH EVERY WEEK AND
BUSINESS IS JUST NOT GOOD --
COMMODITY PRICES ARE HURTING THE
FORMULAS THAT THE STATE USES ARE
DEATHLY OUTDATED --
WE'VE HAD FRIENDS THAT HAVE BEEN
IN THE BUSINESS TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS AND THEY JUST COULDN'T
MAKE IT WORK ANYMORE.
BECAUSE TOO MANY THINGS ARE
IMPACTING THEY'RE BUSINESSES
WE'VE HAD FRIENDS UP IN CRESCENT
CITY THAT SHUT DOWN THEIR
BUSINESS ANTICA.
SAN JOSE.
ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST RECYCLING
CENTERS IN FRESNO WAS THINKING
ABOUT GETTING OUT OF THE
BUSINESS.
AND I JUST TALKED TO ONE OF THE
LARGEST RECYCLERS IN CINEMA
COUNTY OVER SANTA ROSA.
AND BECAUSE THEIR COSTS HAVE
GONE UP SO MUCH RECENTLY BECAUSE
OF FIRES LAST YEAR THEY CAN'T
GET LABOR THEY CAN'T GET
TRACKING THEY'RE LOOKING AT
SHUTTING DOWN THEIR OPERATION.
SO WITH THIS --
PROPOSE BILL IT DOES CREATE SOME
STABILITY OVER THE NEXT FEW.
A FEW YEARS AND GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE RECYCLERS TO
WORK WITH POWER CYCLE. TO COME
UP WITH SOME MORE LONG STE LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS SO WITH THAT I
WOULD RECOMMEND YOU SUPPORT THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM SHIP SATCHER WITH VALLEY
SPRINGS RECYCLING I WILL PUT
OPERATOR RULE RECYCLING CENTER
IN CALAVERAS COUNTY --
AND WE STARTED TWO THOUSAND SIX
WITH ONE LOCATION VALLEY SPRINGS
--
WE GREW TO WHERE WE WERE
ACTUALLY DOING ALL THE MIX
RECYCLING INTO IS SOME SORT --
OFFERING A SMALL MURPH --
AND WHICH WE CLOSE IN JANUARY
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
WERE THE ONLY RECYCLING CENTER
LEFT STANDING A CALAVERAS
COUNTY.
A SINCE THAT TIME WE HAVE --
OPENED SOME OF THESE CONVENE
ZONE LOCATIONS HE SPENT BACK
FIVE OF THEM ACROSS THE COUNTY
RIGHT EFFORT --
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO RECYCLE BUT QUITE
FRANKLY IS IT'S NOT A BUSINESS
MODEL THE SUSTAINING ITSELF.
AND IF SOMETHING IS NOT CHANGED
TO A I CAN SEE WILL WE WILL BE
RICH CLOSING THOSE LOCATIONS AND
RESORTING BACK TORN --
YOU ARE FAR ARCHED ORIGIN THERE
AND VALLEY SPRINGS --
AN EXAMPLE THAT I LIKE TO USE
HERE IS THAT IN JULY ON JULY
FIRST CAO RECYCLE IS GOING TO
MANDATE THAT WE INCREASE OUR PAY
OUT OF A TWO DOLLARS TWENTY
EIGHT OKAY [inaudible]
THESE FEES THAT WERE TALKING
ABOUT OR THESE --
FUNDS THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT
REMAIN STAGNANT.
SO I WILL IN SENSUALLY HAVE TO
PAY MORE FOR THE PRODUCT BECAUSE
YOU'RE TELLING ME I HAVE.
TO AND I'M GONNA RECOVER LESS ON
THE LOSE MARGIN ABOUT 2% MARGIN
IN ALREADY.
YOU KNOW.
A LOSS LEADER SO.
WE NEED HELP ME HELP IF YOU WANT
US OUT THERE WE NEED YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THIS IS A
JOKE NO WAS.
I DON'T KILL IT IN THE RECYCLING
INDUSTRY TODAY SO ANY HELP THAT
WE CAN GET FROM YOU --
WOULD HELP US SERVE THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S REALLY ALL
WE'RE TRYING TO DO SO
[inaudible]
THANK.
WE WILL WRITE MOTION'S BEEN MADE
AND SECONDED ARE THERE FOR THE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
I'M.
FOR GENEVIEVE ABBOTT ON ON
BEHALF OF HILL THE BASE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION AND THE
REST OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
FOLLOW TREAT ON BEHALF OF SEE
OUR PC IN TO PORT.
JOHN LATERAN HAVE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS IN SPORT.
THERE'S JUST NOT OR PLANT
RECYCLING SOMETIMES SOME
FRANCISCO --
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF TORRENT
THOMAN WITH AMERICA WANT TO
THANK SENATOR AYE GLAZER IN THE
STAFF WORKING WITH US.
ON AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE WE'VE
TAKEN A DAY WORKING A FEW MORE
THINGS AND WHAT WE'RE JUST ABOUT
THERE THANK YOU.
AS CHAIRMAN OF THIS COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
JEAN IRVINE REPRESENTING WASTE
MANAGEMENT WE SUPPORT A BILL
THANK YOU.
CHECK OUT GOOD WITH REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MURS ANIMAL
REPRESENTING REPLANT IT WHICH IS
THE LARGEST CONVENIENCE ON
RECYCLING THE STATE.
I'M WE'RE ACTUALLY MOVING WITH
THE AMENDMENT SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE WERE MOVING OUR
OPPOSITION A OPPOSE LESS AMENDED
TO SUPPORT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT STAFF.
THE AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MS RESTS.
I DO APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
FROM THE RECYCLERS I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE THOSE.
CASUAL IS THEY MAY HAVE BEEN IN
SHORTS -- IT
STILL PROVIDES THAT --
THAT FLAVOR IT THEY LET LETS US
KNOW EXACTLY.
WHAT THE WORK IS ALL ABOUT?
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ARE AT THAT THANK YOU SIR FOR A
YOUR WORK ON THIS I KNOW THAT
THERE WERE.
ALSO ON THIS BILL PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF INTO --
I SEE THAT WE ARE FIRST NEED TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION --
FOR URGENCY CLAUSE TO BE ADOPTED
--
IN SO WITH.
PERSONS BILLION SECONDED THAT
THIS IS THE MOTION AS TO A
URGENCY TO BE ADOPTED ON THIS
BILL --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THAT THE AGENCY BE ADOPTED
MEMBERS SMART SEARCHING AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA
[inaudible]
CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
SIMONE.
MCCARTY MELENDEZ BRAOSE.
PRESS I STONE.
STONE I FIVE ZERO ALRIGHT.
SO THAT IS ON CALL.
AND AS TO THE BILL --
I REOMMEND.
AND I WITH THE AMENDMENTS --
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
S. MADAM SECRETARY IS CHOLERA.
I DON'T THREE SB FOR FIFTY TWO
BY CENTER GLAZER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE REFUGEE
AYE ACOSTA.
CHAU TRIAL AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE IN LIMON [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELINDA'S RAYOS.
REYES AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE I FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THE
BILLS ON THE COFFEE THANKS FOR
YOUR HELP WISHES.
SEE CENTER SKINNER IN THE
AUDIENCE SO WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SP [inaudible]
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE YEAH
[inaudible]
JUST LOOK.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
SP THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE
RECOGNIZES THAT HYDROGEN.
HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN OUR BOTH
OUR ELECTRICITY STORAGE AND AND
OTHERWISE --
ESPECIALLY IF IT IS ME PRODUCED
THROUGH OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY
SOURCES --
HYDROGEN THE PRODUCTION OF
HYDROGEN IS QUITE ENERGY
INTENSIVE BECAUSE YOU NEED TO
SPLIT [inaudible]
WATER INTO.
HYDROGEN AND OXYGEN IN ORDER --
TO TO THEN OBTAIN THE HYDROGEN
THAT'S THEN USED FOR FUELING OR
ANY NUMBER OF PURPOSES.
AND WITH CURRENTLY WITH OUR
INCREASE AND RENEWABLE THE
GENERATED ELECTRICITY WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PRODUCE ELECTORAL
THROUGH ELECTROLYTIC PROCESS
PRODUCE THAT HYDROGEN IN A MUCH
CLEANER WAY WHICH GIVES US THAN.
TWO ZERO EMISSION SOURCES --
WHAT S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE
DOES IS DEFINED A NEW FORM OF
STORAGE GREEN ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN AND ALLOW FOR UP TO
THREE PILOT PROJECTS OF NO MORE
THAN FIVE MEGAWATTS EACH --
WE IN THIS COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
IN. OH WAIT TILL THE I JUST WANT
TO SPECIFY IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
POLICE HERE AND CORRECT ME IF WE
WILL BE TAKING AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE AGREED TO IN THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE.
AND WE'VE HAD EXCELLENT
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AROUND SOME LANGUAGE THAT IT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
COMMITTEE STAFF HAD.
WHICH WHEN SWEET WE'VE JUST NOT
LANDED ON THAT LANGUAGE WE'VE
WE'VE STARTED TO LOOK AT SIMON
WE'RE GETTING CLOSE BUT WE WOULD
TAKE THAT LANGUAGE IN APPROACH
WOULD WHATEVER WE AGREE TO WITH.
YOUR COMMITTEE WE WOULD TAKE IN
A PROBES THANK FUND OF HEDGE
THEIR SO THERE WERE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE AYE A PROPOSED AND
DISCUSSED IN THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND AND THAT --
YES CENTER YOU ARE AGREEING TO
ADOPT AND BECAUSE THIS WAS
DOUBLE REFERRED AND AS TO THE
REMAINING ISSUES THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS RAISED.
YOU ARE GOING TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS --
WITH ANY AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN
IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
NOTES FOR TIMING OF THE ALRIGHT
PLEASE PROCEED.
RIGHT SO --
I THINK I ALLOW MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND THEN ANY OTHER
DETAILS I CAN DO IN MY CLOTHES.
FULLER MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE MY
NAME IS JACK BRAUER I'M A
PROFESSOR IN MECHANICAL AND
AEROSPACE ENGINEERING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE.
I DO RESEARCH ON THE DYNAMICS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND ALSO ON
ELECTRIC CHEMICAL ENERGY
CONVERSION AND STORAGE.
AND I'VE BEEN INVESTIGATING ALL
KINDS OF FORMS OF STORAGE --
THAT INCLUDE BATTERIES AND
ELECTROLYSIS AND HYDROGEN AND
PUMP HYDRO AND HEART DISEASE.
AND I DON'T KNOW OF ANY OTHER
FORM OF STORAGE THAT WOULD
ENABLE THE FEATURES WE NEED. FOR
MASSIVE AND EVEN A 100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY ECONOMIES
THERE'S NO OTHER THING THAT CAN
DO THAT WITH ZERO EMISSIONS.
OTHER THAN HYDROGEN.
HYDROGEN IS THAT --
ONE HAS THESE FEATURES THAT CAN
ENABLE LONG TERM.
AND MASSIVE ENERGY STORAGE THAT
WE WILL EVENTUALLY NEED FOR A
100% RENEWABLE ECONOMY --
IT ALSO ENDS UP BEING A VERY
GOOD TOOL FOR D. CARBON ISING
WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE AS OUR
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S ONE OF
THE ONLY WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN DO
IT ON A MASSIVE SCALE.
EVEN IF WE USED ALL THE BIO GAS
AND BIOMASS THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
US WE COULDN'T DE CARBONIZED IT
COMPLETELY [inaudible]
BUT HYDROGEN.
MADE FROM RENEWABLE ENERGY COULD
DO THAT FOR US.
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO MENTION
THAT.
CURRENTLY IF WE GO ON THE SAME
PATH OF ELECTRIFYING EVERYTHING.
AND TRYING TO MEET ALL THE
DEMANDS WE CURRENTLY MEET WITH
BOTH GAS AND ELECTRICITY WE
WOULD HAVE TO MORE THAN TRIPLE.
OUR ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS IDEA OF MAKING HYDROGEN
FROM RENEWABLES ENABLES US TO
ELECTRIFY EVEN THOSE VERY
DIFFICULT TO ELECTRIFY END USES
THE MASSIVE AMOUNT OF STORAGE WE
NEED.
THE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND
THINGS LIKE THIS --
AND OFFERS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO DO THIS IN A WAY THAT'S A
MUCH LESS COSTLY.
THAN TRYING TO REPLACE ALL OF
THOSE CURRENT GAS PLANTS THINGS
LIKE THAT TO REPURPOSE THOSE
THINGS OKAY WITH ZERO OMITTING.
HYDROGEN FROM RENEWABLES.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
IT'S HARD TO FOLLOW THAT.
LORRAINE PASS GADSON WITH BUT
YOU NORTH AND I'M ALSO HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THAT
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL.
I'M ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR THAT ASSOCIATION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND WE ARE THRILLED THAT SENATOR
SKINNER HAS TAKEN A LEADERSHIP
ROLE AT A TIME IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN WE HAVE A VEIL OF ABUNDANT
AVAILABLE --
LOW COST SOLAR AND OTHER
RENEWABLE RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
LEVERAGE AND OPTIMIZING
CONVERTING TO HYDROGEN USE
HYDROGEN FROM MULTIPLE AND USES
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE OF A LOT OF
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE CHIEF
CONSULTANT HAS DONE WITH US TO
TRY TO RESOLVE SOME OF THE
ISSUES -- IN
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF OF FOR A
RESOLUTION ON THAT SIR THANK YOU
IN WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
SPELL.
THANKS VERY MUCH. FOR THE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT A GOOD
EVENING SILVIO FURRY MAP THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PATRICK
WHAT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION.
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPOSING LESS
AMENDED POSITION OUR CONCERNS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS WITH
AUTHORED APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION WITH HER ON THIS IN
THE SPONSOR'S WELL --
ARE WITH THE I RP LANGUAGE IN
THE AND THE BILL AYE WE AGREE
WITH THE ANALYSIS THAT THAT
REQUIRING CONSIDERATION OF GREEN
HYDROGEN EACH IRP IS PREMATURE
--
AT THIS TIME WE WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
RECOMMENDATION TO REMOVE THAT
LANGUAGE --
FROM THE BILL UNDERSTAND THAT.
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE --
ON THAT PROVISION WE'VE
SUBMITTED ALSO --
SAN ADDITIONAL IDEAS ADD TO THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR FOR THEIR
CONSIDERATION AND AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM IN
THIS COMMITTEE --
AS WE WORK ON THAT LANGUAGE AND
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
OUR POSITION THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU.
SENIOR FOR THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY OF QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MS RICE.
I DO APPRECIATE THAT.
VM.
THE LESSON FROM THE PROFESSOR --
IT HITS IT SO.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT I'M GLAD IT'S A PILOT
PROJECT.
UP BECAUSE IT IS SO EXPENSIVE I
KNOW THAT YOU YOU PRESENTED IT
IN SUCH A WAY THAT YOU'RE
COMPARING YOU KNOW.
MOVING RESOURCES FROM ONE AREA
TO ANOTHER BUT IT STILL IS ONE
OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE ONES BUT
SOMETHING WE NEED TO LOOK AT SO
I DO APPRECIATE THIS AS A PILOT
PROJECT AND I'M PREPARED TO SAY.
TO SUPPORTED I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
ALRIGHT --
SEE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SATYR WHICH LIKE CLOTHES THANK
YOU AND IT IS THE I RP SECTION
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH STAFF
ON TO PLANNED ON APPROPRIATE
LANGUAGE SO [inaudible]
AND I THINK THE I CARRIED THE
BILL ON STORAGE BACK IN.
SEE WHAT YOUR WAS IT NOW 201-1 I
THINK -- A
COULD BE OFF BY YEAR BUT ANYWAY
AND AT THAT POINT I WOULDN'T
HAVE CONSIDERED HYDROGEN BECAUSE
WE WERE NOT WE DID NOT AS THE
STATE HAVE THAT ARE AMOUNT OF
ELECTRICITY.
THAT WE ARE PRODUCING THAT WAS
GENERATED FROM RENEWABLE SOURCES
WAS NOT YET THAT HIGH IT WAS
ALSO STILL RELATIVELY EXPENSIVE
IT'S COME DOWN A GREAT DEAL IN
PRICE.
AND OBVIOUSLY WEARE WE'VE NOW
ADOPTED IT --
A 50% GOAL AND WE MAY EVEN GO
HIGHER BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT AS
WE GENERATE MORE RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY THERE ARE TIMES IN
THE DAY WHERE WE ARE NOT
UTILIZING AS MUCH OF IT.
AND SO IF WE HAVE A WAY TO
CAPTURE THEN.
SO THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO GIVE US THAT ABILITY
TO PILOT AND TEST THE GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN PROCESS
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR IDEA.
ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO MOVE SECOND.
RIGHT.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I AM THIRTEEN SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR SKINNER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ROUTE TO CHU LAI RATS
RICHIE I ACOSTA.
CHAU EGGMAN FLORA EGGMAN AYE
FLORA LIMON MCCARTY MELENDEZ
REYES.
CHRIS AYE STONE [inaudible]
THREE ZERO BRAZIL OF THE BELLS
ON CALL THANK YOU.
SENATOR WAS SO.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS --
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B..
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR AND ITEM
SIXTEEN SP.
FOURTEEN FORTY NO IT BEGINNING
WITH THE MAYBE. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
ELEVEN FIFTY WELL LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE A TYPO ON THE STANDING
HERE.
ELEVEN OF FIFTEEN AT LEAST ON MY
COPY OF THE AGENDA SO THAT IS
THE I AM A LEVEL ITEM ELEVEN SP.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE AND ITEM
SEVENTEEN SP [inaudible]
FOURTEEN FORTY HOW.
SO YOU WANT TO DO THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE FIRST WHICHEVER YOU PREFER.
OF I THINK --
WILL DO THIRTY SIX TO FIVE OKAY.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE IS ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS --
FOR SPORT LIKE TO BEGIN BY.
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
AND SIMPLY ASK --
JUST. FOR YOUR SUPPORT ITEMS
BILL THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT --
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
CNN AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
RIGHT -- I
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I WILL LET
SECOND THE MOTION.
AND ASK OF YOU.
LIKE CLOSE.
IT SIMPLY US FREE AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU ARE THANK YOU.
MOST THEN MADE AND SECONDED THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SP.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE MADAM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I AM ELEVEN SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE BY SENATOR HUESO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ROUTES WHICH I
MURATSUCHI I ACOSTA CHAU EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA LIMON MCCARTY
MELENDEZ REYES STONE TWO ZERO
TWO ZERO BILLS ON CALL.
THANK YOU THE FLIGHT TICKET
NEXT.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND AGAIN ON THIS
BILL I'D LIKE --
TO EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
THAT -- WERE
AGREED UPON IN THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE.
HI THIS IS A SIMPLE CLEAN UP
MEASURE NEEDED TO CLARIFY.
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION'S
INTEGRATED ENERGY POLICY REPORT.
AND IT ALSO ENSURES THAT THE CDC
HAS ENOUGH SERVE AT THIRTY
STREAMLINED ITS CONTRACTING
PROCESS --
THE AMENDMENTS I MAKE THE BILL
BETTER BILL AND WE SIMPLY ASK
THREE I PUT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
SARAH WOULD LIKE THOSE SINCE
THAT'S FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU --
MADAM SECRETARY IS CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM FIFTEEN SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR HUESO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA CHAU
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORIDA LIMON MCCARTY
MELENDEZ VARIOUS STONE. TWO ZERO
RIGHT THAT BILL IS ALSO ON CALL.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST --
SP.
FOURTEEN FORTY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
I LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND AND YOUR STAFF. FOR
THE TIME THAT YOU'VE SPENT WITH
US -- AND
FOR THE WONDERFUL COULD
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED.
I WOULD LIKE --
TO COMMIT FOR THE ON THE RECORD.
THEN I'M WILLING TO ACCEPT THE
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WITH
ONE MINOR CLARIFICATION LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT FOR YOU.
RIGHT NOW THE BILL TODAY.
HAS A TYPO THAT SETS A EQUIPMENT
REQUIREMENTS. THIRTY TO BE CF
UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY AND THEN I I
THINK WHAT WAS MEANT WAS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND THAT WOULD --
I I'D LIKE.
TO ASK YOU TO MAKE THAT ONE
MINOR CHANGE AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WAS ADDED IN THE
REPORT THAT CAN BE.
S. AS SORRY FOR THOSE ALL THE
LITTLE DETAILS MATTER
[inaudible]
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO INCLUDE
THAT.
IN YOUR STAFF SPREAD THROUGH
RIGHT OF THE BILL THAT COULD BE
PLEATS IF WE CONCLUDE THAT.
YES -- I
WANT TO ASK GOOD.
A LESSER ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AS TO THE NATURE THE
MAN MEANT --
THAT HAS BEEN --
VETTED BY COMMITTEE STAFF AND
AND I THINK THAT WAS JUST A
LITTLE IN ADVERTISED FOR THAT WE
CAN CORRECT VERY EASILY.
BUT JUDGES GENERALLY --
WHAT THIS BILL DOES [inaudible]
HERE'S A IT WOULD --
CREATE A NEW PROCUREMENT
STRATEGY. FOR FOR BIO GAS IN AND
WITHIN OUR OUR OUR GUESTS
NETWORK.
AND THIS --
THIS BILL AGAIN WOULD HELP US
ADDRESS.
THE ONGOING CLIMATE CHANGE --
TROUBLES THAT WE'RE FACING.
WE KNOW THAT --
CALIFORNIA AS AS WELL AS THE
REST OF THE WORLD ISSUES FACING.
THE THREAT OFCLIMATE CHANGE
EVERY SECTOR OF OUR ECONOMY
ECONOMY.
IS INVOLVED IN.
A FIT INTO A CARBON CONSTRAINED
FUTURE. SIXTEEN YEARS AGO THIS
LEGISLATURE BEGAN WORK ON THE
CARBONATES IN THE ELECTRIC
SECTOR.
THROUGH THE ADOPTION OF A
PROCUREMENT MAN MANDATE.
KNOWN AS RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD.
TODAY WE ARE AHEAD OF OUR
SCHEDULED TO GET 250% RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY [inaudible]
BY [inaudible] TWENTY THIRTY IN
LIGHT OF THIS PROGRESS STUDIES
SHOW THAT NATURAL GAS WILL
CONTINUE.
A PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE.
AS A RELIABLE FUEL SOURCE FOR
HEAT AND ELECTRICITY GENERATION.
WE'VE SANE AND SOME CASES AS
WE'VE RETOOLED.
THE AN IN GAS USED.
THIS YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT.
THERE ARE SOME STRATEGIES THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A FUTURE
WITHOUT GAS BUT THAT IS VERY
VERY FAR IN THE FUTURE.
TODAY WE CAN ACTUALLY.
IF AT ALL ACTUALLY BECAUSE TODAY
WE WE ARE NOW SEEING THAT GAS.
IS NOT ONLY --
CLEANER THAN MANY FUEL SOURCES
BUT ACTUALLY HAS A NEGATIVE.
CARBON FOOTPRINT.
WE'RE SEEING THAT --
WERE SEQUESTERING GAS THAT.
AT A LANDFILLS AND IN --
GARY FARMS DIFFERENT PLATE PARTS
OF THE OF THE STATE.
AND WE CAN USE THAT SEQUESTERED
GAS INTO OF FUEL.
THAT WOULD HELP US ACTUALLY
CLEAN THE EARTH CLEAN THE AIR
AND CREATE A VIBRANT ECONOMY.
WHEN I FIRST GOT TO THE SENATE I
CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE?
THIS IS ONE STRATEGY OF
ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S IN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE WHY IS THAT
IMPORTANT.
THE MORE MONEY WE SPEND.
ON LOCALLY GENERATE ELECTRICITY
MEANS THE MORE.
JOBS WE CREATE AND STATE.
THE THE MORE OF OUR OUR OF OUR
ECONOMIES DOLLAR STATE WITHIN
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY WHICH HELPS
TO BUILD WEALTH.
WITHIN OUR ECONOMY AND IT'S A
STRATEGY TO HELP CONTINUE TO
BUILD OUR ECONOMY CALIFORNIA.
IS NOW THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD.
AND WE GOT THERE.
BY MAKING INVESTMENTS WITHIN OUR
STATE MAKING SURE OUR STATE
PRODUCES THINGS.
AND THAT WE CONSUME CALIFORNIA
GROWN PRODUCTS.
RIGHT NOW 80% OF OUR NATURAL GAS
COMES FROM OUTSIDE THE STATE.
THAT IS AN ENORMOUS AMOUNTOF
MONEY LEAVING OUR ECONOMY EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
AND WE ARE NOT ONLY IMPORTANT
IN.
A GAS THAT POLLUTES THE AIR WERE
ALSO --
POLLUTING THE AIR IN
TRANSPORTING AND HEAR FROM AS
FAR OFF AS A STRAY LEAH.
THIS IS --
SOMETHING'S GOT AT WE'VE GOT
WORK TO TO MINIMIZE BUT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GRIP CHU CHU
EXPAND CERTAIN BUSINESS PLANS IN
OUR STATE WITH THIS POLICY.
AND AND OUR OUR OUR OUR FARMERS
CAN CAN TAP INTO THE ENERGY
MARKETS NOW THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE.
AND BECOME --
SUPPLIERS OF OUR OF OUR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS A A
MEASURE THAT IF YOU IF YOU
SUPPORT CREATING JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A GREAT MEASURE TO
SUPPORT.
IF YOU SUPPORT CLEANING THEIR
THIS IS A GREAT MEASURE TO
SUPPORT.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
AND MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD --
WERE WERE SO MAKE MAKING
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL WE HAVE
WE HAVE --
WELL WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD ON
AT EACH AND COST CONTAINMENT
MEASURES THAT WERE REQUIRED OF
US IN AND ENERGY COMMITTEE WE
HAD WORK THAT HONORS OUR SIMONE.
SOME OF SOME OF OUR OWN COST
CONTAINING.
OF MEASURES UP OR LANGUAGE I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THAT I
HAVE I COMMITTED LAST COMMITTEE
TO WORK WITH TO CHAIR. TO MAKE
SURE WE COME UP WITH THE RIGHT
LANGUAGE WE ASK THAT YOU GIVE US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE.
TO WORK WITH CHAIRMAN HOLDEN I
UNDERSTAND THE IMAGE CHAIR ARE
ALSO INTERESTED IN THE SUBJECT
AND WE ARE.
WE WILL WORK WITH YOU TO COME UP
WITH THE RIGHT LANGUAGE.
IF YOU KNOW IF WE DON'T WILL
WILL WILL START MOVING FORWARD
BUT WE WILL DO IT ONLY.
WITH WITH THIS COMMITTEE'S
APPROVAL.
AND OF COURSE AND WITH ENERGY
COMMITTEES APPROVALS WELL WE
THINK WE'RE VERY VERY CLOSE ON
THE DETAILS.
AND AND WE WILL GET THERE WITH
YOUR SUPPORT.
HAVE BUT FOR TODAY I ASK FOR YOU
ARE ABLE TO HELP US MOVE FORWARD
AND CONTINUE TO WORK ON
CRAFTING.
THE THE YOU KNOW THE DEVIL'S
ALWAYS IN THE DETAILS WE WANT TO
GET TO THOSE DETAILS IN CRAFTING
THIS LANGUAGE.
AND AND WE ASK THAT YOU ALLOWS
--
THE THE UP TO TO CONSIDER DO
THAT.
WE HAVE TODAY --
TO TO BE A TEST OF FIRE ANSWER
ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS HOWEVER
THE COMMITTEE --
WISHES WE HAVE NICK POOR WITH
THE COALITION FOR NO RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS.
WE HAVE TIM KARMIC.
CARMICHAEL WITH SO CALLED GAS.
AND KATIE DONAHUE DURAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
LABOR'S TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND TO
ALSO ASK YOU QUESTIONS IF YOU
SHOULD HAPPEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RIGHT
STYGIAN MEMBERS EVENING ACTUALLY
I NEED TO GO FOR COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS I AM PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL --
THIS BILL IS CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF LANDMARK LEGISLATION
PASSED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE LARA WHICH
REQUIRED A 75% REDUCTION IN THE
AMOUNT OF ORGANICS GOING TO
LANDFILLS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IN A 40%
REDUCTION METHANE STATEWIDE BY
TWENTY THIRTY IF.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
EXPLICITLY STATED IN A TRUCK
LIVE CLIMATE POLLUTANT STRATEGY
THAT ORDER TO MEET OUR METHANE
REDUCTION GOALS THE STATE'S
ORGANIC WASTES SHOULD BE PUT TO
BENEFICIAL USE AS PIPELINE
INJECTED RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS.
ALSO AS PART OF THAT THOUGH
THERE IS AN ANALYSIS DONE BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
THAT I WILL I DISTRIBUTE AS SOON
AS I'M DONE TESTIFYING --
THAT FINDS THAT THERE'S
CURRENTLY MORE THAN EIGHTY
BILLION CUBIC FEET OF
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE METHANE
BEING EMITTED TODAY FROM
LANDFILLS DAIRYMAN NOR AND WASTE
OUR TREATMENT PLANTS IN YOUR
DISTRICTS.
SO THE QUESTION BECOMES WHY
WOULDN'T WE USE THIS DOMESTIC
FUEL SOURCE TO DISPLACE FOSSIL
NATURAL GAS WHICH IS BEING
IMPORTED FROM OUT OF STATE.
ALTHOUGH NOT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WOULD BE A VOTE IN FAVOR OF
THE STATUS QUO OF USING FOSSIL
GAS ROUTE OF STATE.
WHEN THERE'S A DOMESTIC RESOURCE
AS COST EFFECTIVELY AVAILABLE?
CURRENT ESTIMATES THAT ORGANIC
WASTE CAN SUPPLY ENOUGH
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS TO SUPPLY
AN OUTSTANDING TWO MILLION
RESIDENTIAL UNITS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS BEING SUPPORTED BY
OVER FORTY TWO ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
LIKE THE CLIMATE TRUST AND
ENERGY VISION.
LABOR GROUPS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA COUNCIL
OPERATING ENGINEERS.
BUSINESS GROUPS LIKE THE LA
COUNTY LABOR FEDERATION ARE TO
BUSINESS FEDERATION.
AND PUBLIC ENTITIES INCLUDING
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION DISTRICT SOME OF THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU.
MEANING CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE TIM CARMICHAEL
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY
--
WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS. FOR WHAT IT CAN DO TO HELP
THE STATEMEET IS SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS PLAN DELIVER
ON THAT.
S. SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT PLAN FOR THE AIR QUALITY
BENEFITS THAT.
THIS PROGRAM CAN HELP DELIVER
AND FOR THE THE BENEFITS ARE
REAL RELATED TO OUR ORGANIC WAY
STREAMS IN CALIFORNIA THAT THIS
LEGISLATION CAN HELP --
WITH -- WE
CONTINUE SUPPORT THE BILL
KNOWING THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
ASSEMBLY CHILES COMMITTEE.
ON APPROPRIATE COST CONTROLS AND
A MECHANISM TO RECOVERING RATES
--
THE COST OF THE FUEL THERE WILL
BE REQUIRED TO PURCHASE.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS KITTY DONE HIT AROUND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LEVERS HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB.
FOURTEEN FORTY ALSO NOTE THAT
OUR DIRECTOR JOSE ME HERE ALSO
CURRENTLY SITS ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE THAT NATURAL GAS.
BY OMITTING PRODUCTIVE
FACILITIES ATTRACT BETWEEN TEN
TO SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT AND CREATE UP TO ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE JOBS
PER PROJECT.
WE BELIEVE THE PROCUREMENT GOALS
SET FORTH IN S. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY WILL ENABLE UP TO ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY NEW PROJECTS TO BE
DEVELOPED CREATING OPPORTUNITY
FOR INVESTMENT OF UP TO TEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND TWENTY SIX THOUSAND NEW JOBS
IN THE STATE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABLE THIS EVENING THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
RESEARCHER REMEMBER SCOTT WHICH
I'M AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PATRONS COUNCIL AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES IT REPRESENTS ALL THE
GAS WORKERS IT.
ATA IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON AND AT PACIFIC GAS
ELECTRIC WE'D URGING AYE VOTE.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHUCK HELD IT REPRESENTING
REPUBLIC SERVICES WERE MOVING
OUR OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE MET THE BILL AS
AMENDED BY THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH
PANEM BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSE RECYCLING COUNTS WHEN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
JERRY MEMBERS MIGHT DILLON
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES AND COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT.
HI GOOD EVENING WRITING KENNY
CLEAN ENERGY WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR WORKING WITH US WE ARE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED THANK YOU.
JEAN IRVINE REPRESENTING WASTE
MANAGEMENT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU. TO THE
ELEVEN BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WERE SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED THAT HOPE TO MOVE TO
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL VOCAL OR ON BEHALF OF
THE AG ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WHERE IN THE UNIQUE
POSITION THAT WE HAVE BOTH.
PROPONENTS OF PROJECTS AS WELL
AS SOME OF THE LARGEST NATURAL
GAS USER SINCE AND STATE.
SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO HEAR
SENATOR WAY SAYS EXPLICIT
COMMITMENT TO INCLUDE COST
CONTAINMENT LANGUAGE.
OR HE WON'T MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD THAT'S ARE CRITICAL
AMENDMENT WE'RE STILL LOOKING
FOR WITH THAT WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WAS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOW
ANTI JACK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA DAIRIES
IN CALIFORNIA TOMATO GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN ACT
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
EVENING VALERIE TRAIL OF LA
HOSTS WITH PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY NO FORMAL
POSITION BUT WANTED TO TESTIFY
SORT OF WITH THIS SEGMENT OF
WITNESSES --
THAT WE ARE VERY --
THE CONVERSATION IN THE
COMMITTEE'S WILLINGNESS TO WORK
ON THAT STRICT COST CAP.
LIKE MANY OTHER COLLEAGUES SAID
WE WANT TO BE A PART OF OUR
MEETING ARE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS GOALS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILK FORCE WORKING
WITH YOU CLOSELY.
YOU FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME
.
FOR GETTING CHAIR MEMBERS PHOEBE
SETON LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY ALSO
ON ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
A WELL WE ARE OF COURSE VERY
SUPPORTIVE REDUCING SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS IN CALIFORNIA
SP FOURTEEN FORTY SIMPLY DOES
NOT CREATE.
AN EFFECTIVE OR ENVIRONMENTALLY
SOUND MEANS OF DOING SO.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERNS WITH SP
FOURTEEN FORTIES APPROACH ARE
THAT IT'S PREMATURE IT
PRIORITIZES BY A METHANE
PRODUCTION OVER OTHER MEANS OF
REDUCING METHANE.
AND DOES NOT ADEQUATELY CONSIDER
LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
MANEUVER GENERATION AND
CONVERSION INTO ENERGY.
BIO METHANE PRODUCTION FROM
DAIRIES HAS AN UNPROVEN TRACK
RECORD THE COST FEASIBILITY
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF BIO
METHANE PRODUCTION FROM DAIRY
SHOULD BE BETTER UNDERSTOOD.
BEFORE SETTING PROCUREMENT
MANDATES CONVENIENTLY THE CPUC
IT'S CURRENTLY ASSESSING THE
FEASIBILITY OF DARROW TERRY BY A
METHANE PROJECTS.
THROUGH A PRIVATE PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WILL THAT AVAIL EVALUATE
SCALABILITY GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION COST EFFECTIVENESS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
RATHER THAN RUSH TO PROCUREMENT
MANDATE WE SHOULD WAIT TILL
THESE PILOT PROJECTS HAVE RUN
THEIR COURSE AND ARE EVALUATED.
FURTHER BY FOCUSING ON MANDATORY
PROCUREMENT REQUIREMENTS IN
PRIORITIZING BY A METHANE
GENERATION SP FORTUNE FORTY
WOULD LIMIT MEANINGFUL
CONSIDERATION OF STRATEGIES.
THAT CAN REDUCE METHANE AT A
LOWER COST WITH FEWER
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AND MARCO
BENEFITS A SET OF EVER EXPANDING
INCENTIVES FOR BY A METHANE
PRODUCTION THAT FURTHER
COMMODIFIED METHANE.
MAY RESULT IN PERVERSE
INCENTIVES TO GENERATE MORE
METHANE FROM DAIRIES THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE OCCUR AND FACILITATE
THE COULD FACILITATE THE
CONSOLIDATION OF DAIRY
OPERATIONS.
WITH A CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
THE SEVERITY OF ASSOCIATED.
LOCAL AIR WATER AND UBER
IMPACTS.
S. B. FOURTEEN FORTIES
PREFERENCE FOR METHANE
GENERATION RATHER THAN RESTING
AVOIDANCE WILL LIKELY LEAD TO
SIGNIFICANT LOCALIZED
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS BY
INCENTIVIZING LARGER HERD SIZES
THAT CAN BETTER CAPITALIZE ON
THE REVENUE FROM THE SALE OF
NOTHING.
THE DAIRIES IN THE SOUTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY ARE THE REGION'S
LARGEST SOURCE OF OZONE FORMING
VOLATILE ORGANIC COMPOUNDS IN AN
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPROMISED AIR
BASIN.
EXPANDED DAIRY OPERATIONS AND
INCREASED WILL LEAD TO INCREASED
EMISSIONS FROM SILAGE WEANED
YOUR INTERCONNECTIONS --
LEADING TO INCREASED EMISSIONS
AND VOCS AMMONIUM KNOCKS
HYDROGEN SULFIDE REACTIVE
ORGANIC.
GASES AND SO ON AND SO ON
RESULTING IN INCREASED
PARTICULATE MATTER AND OZONE
WHICH IN TURN --
EXACERBATE RESPIRATORY
CONDITIONS SUCH AS ASTHMA.
AND PREMATURE DEATH --
EH ADDITIONALLY INCREASED --
HEARD SIZE AND DAIRY OPERATIONS
CAN IMPACT GROUNDWATER AS WELL
WITH INCREASE ANYWHERE AND ANNA
NITRATE LOADING TO GROUNDWATER.
WE UNDERSTAND THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL EARLIER TODAY
CIRCULATED A TABLE THAT
EXTENSIVELY DEMONSTRATED
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS FROM DAY
DIGESTERS.
IT IS UNCLEAR TO US WHAT DATA
AND ASSUMPTIONS UNDERLIE THESE
ANALYSES AND QUESTION WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
DIGESTION ARE ASSESSED IN
COMPARISON [inaudible]
TO IF. FOR EXAMPLE DIGEST
OPERATIONS ARE COMPARED TO OPEN
ONLINE LAGOONS AND RELIANCE ON
DIESEL ENERGY THAT ANALYSIS
FAILS TO CONSIDER THE MANY MANY
LESS CENTRAL SCENARIOS INCLUDING
OF COURSE.
ALTERNATE MINOA MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND LOWER EMISSION OR
ZERO EMISSION ENERGY SOURCES.
WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE.
ERICA MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
EARTH JUSTICE AND WE ARE A
NONPROFIT LAW FIRM AND I'M HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
COMMUNITY VOICES.
THAT AND THE REASONS WE JUST
HEARD THEM OUTLINED WHY THEY ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY LEADERSHIP CONTINUE BUT
THAT THE VOICES OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
THAT WILL BE MOST IMPACTED ARE
ALSO PART OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT
CALIFORNIA BRINGS FORWARD.
PACIFIC LEAVE FOR ITS JUSTICE WE
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO OPPOSE
THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU BECAUSE
IT'S PREMATURE. TO SET A
PROCUREMENT MANDATE UNTIL PILOT
PROJECTS ARE COMPLETED TO
DETERMINE FEASIBILITY OF BIO
METHANE PRODUCTIONS FROM
DAIRIES.
AS YOU LOOK AT CALIFORNIA ENERGY
POLICY.
THIS BODY HAS MADE A DECISION
THAT WE NEEDED MORE INFORMATION
FROM THE PILOT PROJECTS NOW
YOU'RE REVERSING.
THAT STANCE [inaudible]
AND ACTING [inaudible]
PERHAPS PREMATURELY.
AS YOU CONSIDER THE BILL BEFORE
YOU WOULD ASK YOU TO PLEASE.
TAKE A MOMENT.
TO WORK WITH COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY THE SPILL TO INCLUDE
ALL VOICES IN ENERGY POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA AND TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
RE REPRESENT OVER FORTY UP
PUBLICLY AND ELECTRIC UTILITIES
RUN THE STATE MANY OF WHOM OWN
AND OPERATE THEIR OWN A NATURAL
GAS AT GENERATING UNITS AND
THEIR CUSTOMERS OF THE GAS
CORPORATIONS EITHER FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
OR FOR THE GAS ITSELF WE HAVE
HAD CONCERNS ALL ALONG THAT THAT
THE BIO METHANE MANDATE IN THIS
BILL WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY RAISE
COSTS ON OUR MEMBERS AND
THEREFORE.
BECAUSE ON A STICK NEED TO
CONSIDER RAISING ELECTRICITY
RATES TO COVER THOSE ACCESS
COSTS WINNERS IN THAT AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN.
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
UTILITIES COMMITTEE THAT MAY
REMOVE THE MANDATE IN THE BILL
THAT THOSE COST BE PASSED ON TO
GAS CORPORATION CUSTOMERS.
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT BEEN
PROVIDE ABOUT AN HOUR AGO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE TAKEN IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
SO WILL BE REVIEWING THE BILL
ONCE EVERYTHING IS IN PRINT WE
SEE WHERE THINGS ARE AT AND TO
REASSESS OUR POSITION BUT AGAIN
OUR NUMBER ONE CONCERN ABOUT
THIS BILL IS IMPACT ON ON
CONSUMERS.
AND AND REPAIRS THANK YOU.
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION YEAH
GOOD AND EVENING ON MY NAME IS
AND I ASKED HIM HOW BEHALF FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ROOMS TO SCIENCE
AND WE JUST ONE ALIGN OURSELVES.
WITH THE COMMENTS INDICATED PART
OF JUSTICE AND ALSO LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL THAT YOU THINK THAT THIS
DISPOSABLE PREMATURE AND ALSO
WERE WORKING WITH ON THE
AGENCIES ARE ACTUALLY GOING
THROUGH REGULATORY PROCESS AND
IMPLEMENTING AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
SPECIFICALLY IS PILED PROJECTS
IN THE DATA OR CIRCLED. FOR
THOSE REASONS PROPOSED.
BACK CLUB AND STEAM WITH SMUD --
SIMILAR TO SENIOR WAY WE HAD
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
OUR REVIEWING WERE REVIEWING THE
NEW AMENDMENTS THAT WE GOT TODAY
THINKING.
REBECCA MARKETS REPRESENTING
FOOD AND WATER WATCH OPPOSED.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY WHICH HAS CONSISTENTLY
ADVOCATED AGAINST INVESTMENT
OBJECT GRF DOLLARS FOR DAIRY DIE
JESTERS OWING TO THEIR
INEFFICIENCY.
LOCALIZE POLLUTION ISSUES AND
BIAS SCALE FACTORY DAIRIES WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IN
REQUEST YOU KNOW VOTE.
KYLE JUSTICE HERE WHO CALIFORNIA
ALSO OPPOSED AFTER THE REASONS.
MENTIONED BY OUR MINDS JUSTICE
FRIENDS THANK YOU.
SHE CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN WHITE BUT
THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL WERE OPPOSED TO LESS
AMENDED BECAUSE THE BILL NARROWS
THE A DEFINITION OF RENEWABLE
GAS THAT WAS CONCLUDED IN SP
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH WE
WORKED ON RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
NEEDS TO BE INCLUDED.
IN.
A PARTLY BECAUSE IT'S CLEANER UP
AND THEN THE OTHER USES HAVE WE
WE WOULD HOPE TO KEEP WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT.
CAME UP ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY WE CURRENTLY HAVE
OPPOSE POSITION THE BELL ALIGNER
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MUNICIPAL
UTILITY CESSATION.
IN THE QUARTER FOR THE I THINK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING SIR TO HARRY WITH
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY.
AT GOING THE COMMENTS OF MY
PUBLIC ON PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY
COLLEAGUES I'M ARE CURRENTLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS AND RECONSIDER
OPPOSITION IF NEEDED.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AS EGGMAN [inaudible]
IS IT BUT LET'S YEAH ARE YOU
ACCEPTING THE MINUTES.
MOVE THE BILL.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A QUESTION I DON'T TO
BRING ALL THE WITNESSES BACK
THAT BUT BOTTOM SAID.
I OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED IS YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE UNDERSTANDING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THAT YOU AGREE
TO TO WORK OUT WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
I WAS IN THE UTILIZING COMMERCE
ME DOES THAT.
IN YOUR EYES ADDRESS.
THE MAJORITY BUT LIKE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE ISSUES WERE
STRUGGLING THROUGH ON THIS BILL
IS THAT --
YOU KNOW THIS THIS IS GOING TO
BE A VERY SPECIFIC TYPE OF GAS
IT'S GOING TO BE USED.
WITHIN THE GAS PIPELINES OR A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF QUALITY OF GAS.
THE NEEDS TO BE USED --
WE CAN JUST PUT ANY KIND OF GAS
IN THERE OTHERWISE IT WOULD
DAMAGE.
YOU KNOW STOVES AND ANYTHING
THAT BURNS ON NATURAL GAS SO.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T PRODUCE
NATURAL GAS AT THAT QUALITY.
THEY WANT TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL.
AND THERE YOU KNOW I THINK.
IT'S IMPORTANT I I I THINK IF
IF.
THEIR ARE SOME PEOPLE STILL HAVE
DEVELOPED TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ALLOW THEM TO CLEAN GLASS CAST
AT THAT LEVEL BUT I I BELIEVE.
THAT IF.
IF THIS BILL.
HAS HAS A REQUIREMENT TO PICTURE
THE GASES IS CLEAN.
AND AN EFFECTIVE AND AND USEFUL.
WITHIN THE THE YOU KNOW THEY'RE
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS IN
DIFFERENT STATES.
AND SO --
BUT CALIFORNIA HAS ITS SEPARATE
REQUIREMENTS AND AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT.
THAT HAS BEEN WORKED ON BY.
BY DIFFERENT --
COMMISSIONS THAT.
REGULATE WHAT THAT NEEDS TO BE
IN ORDER TO BURN SURE YOU KNOW
THAT'S A PRACTICAL ISSUE ON ON
THAT FISCAL ISSUE THAT WE HEARD
FROM THE HON AND THIS WILL
UTILITIES AND I MIGHT LOCAL HERE
*.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE A FOR EFFORT WE HAVE NOT
MEDICARE LOOKED AT HER FOR MY
TASTES AS AS THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL COST ADDING COST
CONTAINMENT TO THIS BILL VERY
IMPORT?
VERY IMPORTANT POP FOR ME IT
IT'S GOT A IT'S GOT A FIT WITHIN
A CERTAIN.
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T BLOW UP OUR
OUR OUR RATES YOU CAN'T --
AFFECT COSTS IN A WAY THAT ARE
[inaudible]
RATEPAYERS BUT AND AND THERE'S A
THERE'S A THERE'S AN AREA WHERE
WE CAN START BUILD OUT.
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T.
THEIR CIRCLE ABLE YOU START A
BUSINESS THERE'S A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF A YOU KNOW OF OF
INVESTMENT YOU NEED TO MAKE.
THE GONNA MAKE A CERTAIN
EXPENDITURE TO HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS.
THIS IS THE ONLY THE ONLY
BUSINESS THAT FROM DAY ONE WE'RE
GONNA START REALIZING
I RETURNED WE'RE GONNA GET
CLEANER AIR WE'RE GONNA START --
EQUESTRIAN --
THE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS WE'RE GONNA START.
CREATING JOBS.
BUT THE YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE
WANT.
THE ENTIRE --
SYSTEM TO BE PAID FOR BY RATE
PAYERS AND HOPEFULLY WE STRIKE
THE RIGHT BALANCE TO MAKE SURE
WE WE HAVE A COMP COMBAT
COMBINATION INVESTMENT DOLLARS.
AND AND REPAIR DOLLARS.
BUT ONE THING IS CERTAIN WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T THEM LIKE WE DID
WITH ENERGY WOULD NOW WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW WHEN POWER THIS REALLY
CHEAP SOLAR POWER THAT'S REALLY
CHEAP THAT THAT STARTED WITH THE
ANNOYING AND INJECTION OF OF
INVESTMENT.
WE WOULD HAVE NEVER GOTTEN HERE.
IF IF IT WASN'T FOR THE STATE
CREATING A MANDATE IN THAT AND
AND REQUIRING BECAUSE CERTAIN.
RATE PAID DOLLARS TO BE PUT
TOWARD THE TASK WOULD HAVE NEVER
HAPPENED.
WE'RE NEVER GONNA ACCOMPLISH
BRING IN BIO METHANE ONLINE
WITHOUT A PROGRAM.
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN ON ITS
OWN.
THE MARKET ALONE CANNOT MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
AT BUT WE WILL BE CREATING
RIBBON RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS IN
STATE CREATING THOSE JOBS AND
STATE ANDIT'S A HE AND AND
THERE'S A VALUE TO IT I WANT TO
STRIKE.
THAT.
MEDIUM.
THAT THAT MEDIAN THAT THAT
CREATES THE JOBS GETS THE
PROGRAM STARTED AND PUTS IT ON A
PATH TO BEING.
VERY AFFORDABLE CHEAP GAS IN THE
FUTURE.
BUT YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING WE CAN'T JUST SIT HERE
AND WAIT. FOR THE PROBLEMS TO
SOLVE THEMSELVES.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS HAS
BEEN --
EXPECTED AS PART OF THIS PROGRAM
WE NEED THIS BILL THIS YEAR WE
CAN'T WAIT ANOTHER YEAR. TWO
YEARS FROM NOW --
CAR HAS HAS REQUESTED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ACT ON A PROGRAM TO
GET STARTED ON THIS WE HAVE.
THIS IN THE PILOT PROGRAM THAT
ARE WORKING SOME OBTAINED
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE BOTH.
NECESSARY THE BOTH IMPORTANT BUT
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD. FOR
THAT WITH THE PROGRAMS THAT
ACCOMPLISH OUR GOALS IN THIS
AREA THANK YOU [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR MR
HUESO THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND AND THE AMENDMENTS AND
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON THE BILL TRYING TO
WORK THE COST CONTAINMENT AND I
THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
STRICTLY.
FOR OUR REPAIRS THAT ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH.
YOU KNOW ALL THE FEES AND
REGULATIONS AND THINGS THAT.
SEEM TO BE PILING ON I DIDN'T
ONE QUESTION THOUGH BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I WHILE I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THIS GONNA HELP US
MEET OUR THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
GOALS --
THERE WAS ONE THING AT WORK WAS
IT ALWAYS YOUR INTENT TO HAVE
THIS --
THERE ARE CERTAIN SECTION SEE
HERE ON THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THAT.
YOU'RE ACCEPTING IS THAT RIGHT
WHEN I HEARD OKAY THIRTY DONE
OKAY.
SORRY.
I WAS OUT OF THE ROOM WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A BIT OF
THIS BLUNDER SEAT SAYS --
EACH GAS CORPORATION UP IF UP
HERE'S A PROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
A TOTAL OF THIRTY TWO BILLION
CUBIC FEET ABOUT NOTHING
ANNUALLY --
BY JANUARY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
THIRTY SUPPOSED TO UNTIL ALSO
WAS ALWAYS THIS IS IMPACT
PERPETUITY.
NOT A SUNSET IS THAT.
RIGHT CORRECT OKAY RIGHT.
NOW IT'S JUST A DRAFTING ERROR
ALRIGHT HE OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE [inaudible]
SAYS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SENATOR HUESO I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT A BECAUSE I'M GOING TO
ASSUME YOU'RE AWARE OF THE
CONCERNS --
FROM THE OPPOSITION AND THIS
RELATES --
TO THE FROM.
BURKE AND THIS KIND OF VIOLATING
A FEDERAL ORDER SO GIVING AN
ADVANTAGE --
YOU NO TWO ONE OVER ANOTHER ARE
YOU ABLE TO JUST THAT ON AND IF
YOU'RE WEARING THING WELL YOU
HAVE A GOOD ANSWER ON THAT OKAY
LET THAT BE FINE WHOEVER CAME
OUT HERE.
COALITION FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS WE HAVE CONSULTED WITH SUCH
COUNCIL THEY ARE ISSUING AN
OFFICIAL OPINION I'M ON THE
SUBJECT AND THEY THEY DO THINK
THAT WE ARE IN THE CLEAR ON THAT
ISSUE.
THANK YOU FOR FOR ASKING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT TELL US CENTER WEST SO I
THIS THE SECOND TIME THAT --
HAVE HAD A CHANCE.
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ON
YOUR BILL I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT.
TO ADDRESS THE THE COST ISSUE SO
THAT -- THE
REPAIRS WOULD NOT BE BURDENED
WITH.
THE THE THE COSTS OF THE BY
METHANE PROCUREMENT I LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT -- AND
I ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT.
TO THAT --
THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE
ACCEPTING TODAY WILL TIE THE
PROCUREMENT REQUIREMENT DIRECTLY
TO ACHIEVE THE STATE'S METHANE
REDUCTION TARGETS YES.
I WITH FATS I APPRECIATE THE
YOUR WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
I WILL BE SUPPORTING --
THE BILL HERE TODAY THANK.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE AS OUR SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY OF THE SENATOR
WHICH I CLOTHES A TO SIMPLY ASKS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SEVENTEEN SB FOURTEEN FORTY
BY SENATOR HUESO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE MY MURATSUCHI
AYE ACOSTA.
OUR COSTS ARE AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S
[inaudible]
VARIAS [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE NO [inaudible] FIVE ONE
FIVE ONE THE BILL HIS ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ONE ONE ALRIGHT SENATOR ALLEN WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER TEN SP.
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AYE I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS MEASURE I AM
VERY HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE. TO ADDRESS THE
UNRESOLVED QUESTIONS THAT ARE
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS.
I THIS IS A SIMPLE AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TOXIC
WASTE.
THAT PUTS OUR BEACHES OCEANS
INLAND WATERWAYS.
I JOKES ARE LANDFILLS LEADERS
ARE COMMUNITIES BY PHASING OUT
NON RECYCLABLE TAKE OUT FOOD
CONTAINERS AT STATE PARKS
BEACHES.
AND OTHER STATE FACILITIES.
THE BILL REQUIRES CALLOUS EICHEL
TO DEVELOP A LIST OF FOOD
CONTAINERS THAT ARE RECYCLABLE
AND THEN THOSE VENDORS WISHING
THAT CONTRACT.
WITH THE STATE WOULD ONLY USE
THOSE TESTING ALL PRODUCTS OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE ALREADY
PASSED SOME FORM OF LOCAL
MEASURE.
AIMED AT REDUCING WASTE.
FROM THE FOOD SECTOR.
AND HAVING THE STATE ALSO TAKE
ACTION WILL SPUR THE MARKET FOR
ALTERNATIVE PACKAGING AND DRIVE
DOWN THE COST FOR EVERYONE.
WHO ONE DO THE RIGHT THING?
WHO'S A BILL.
SINGLE USER WHO CATERS ADMITTED
ONE URBAN LITTER.
HAVE WE THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA I
CAN TALK MORE ABOUT IT WE HAVE
FOUND HOLLY MARTINEZ WITH THE
CONFERENCE THE PARKS FOUNDATION
MCMURRAY FROM CONFERENCE AGAINST
WAY SPEEDS FOR THE BILL.
AND HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HIGH AND HIGH MARTINEZ OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION OUR FOUNDATION IS A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS --
MANY OF OUR PARK PARTNERS AND
WORKS TO PROTECT AND ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY STATE PARKS --
ARE PART ARE CALIFORNIANS --
USE OUR PARKS TO RELAX AND WHY
AND ENJOY THE NATURAL SPLENDOR
OF OUR BEACHES MOUNTAINS AND
FORESTS AND OUR PARKS ARE PLACES
THAT NEED TO BE PRESERVED SAID
THAT CALIFORNIANS OF TODAY AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
AND CAN CONTINUE TO ENJOY THESE
WONDERFUL TREASURES AND MORE SO
I THINK THAT ARE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS ART ECONOMIC --
ENGINE WITH SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
VISITORS --
MADE ANNUALLY --
PARK VISITORS SPEND ABOUT THREE
POINT TWO BILLION ANNUALLY ON
GOODS AND SERVICES SUCH AS FOOD
LODGING SUPPLIES AND MORE.
NOT TO MENTION THE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE MILLION IN TAX.
MILLION AND LOCAL TAX NEWS ARE
GENERATED ANNUALLY AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TO
PROTECT AND PRESERVE.
OUR STATE PARKS AS AN ECONOMIC
ENGINE AS WELL AS FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO ENJOY THANK YOU
NICK.
SHARE MEMBERS MARK MURRAY WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
THIS IS A A POLICY THAT WILL
ONLY APPLY TO FOOD SERVICE ON
STATE FACILITIES --
DOZENS OF COMMUNITIES HAVE
ALREADY ADOPTED THIS VERY SAME
POLICY FOR THEIR INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES.
THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS THAT WE
HAVE BROUGHT THIS BILL FORWARD
TO COVER THE ENTIRE STATE
MULTIPLE TIMES THIS COMMITTEE IS
PASSED IT TO COVER THE ENTIRE
STATE -- WE
WERE NOT SUCCESSFUL IN
ULTIMATELY PASSING THAT
LEGISLATION.
AND THIS IS OUR ATTEMPT TO ALLOW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO MODEL
THE KIND OF SUSTAINABLE
PACKAGING WORLD.
THAT WE THINK.
CAN ULTIMATELY BE ADOPTED BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
STATE FACILITIES WILL BE
INCURRING THIS COST THAT EVEN
PLAYING FIELD OF OF ENTITIES
THAT ARE PROVIDING FOOD SERVICE
AT STATE FACILITIES OF THE ONES
THAT ARE GONNA HAVE TO BEAR THE
COST OF IMPLEMENTING IT.
IF THERE IS SUCH A COSTS.
ON THIS IS THAT WE CAN WE CAN DO
IT THAT WAY WE CAN TRY --
TO CONTINUE THE PATCHWORK OF
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF LOCAL
ORDINANCES BASED ON THIS.
THIS IS A AN ATTEMPT TO TRY AND
HAVE A UNIFORM WAY AND INVOLVING
THE STATE IN DOING THIS.
BUT PREVIOUS OBJECTION TO THIS
BILL HAD BEEN FROM THE THE
PACKAGING MANUFACTURES WAS.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WE'RE WE'RE
ASKING CAL RECYCLE TO DO LIST WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT KIND OF
PACKAGING WILL BE AVAILABLE WHEN
THIS IS IMPLEMENTED [inaudible]
THIS LEGISLATION OPPOSES.
STAR A STARTING POINT OF PAPER
PACKAGING P. T. PACKAGING SOME
OTHER SPECIFIC PACKAGING THAT WE
KNOW TO BE TECHNICALLY
RECYCLABLE NOW THE OPPOSITION IS
OBJECTING TO US PUTTING THAT.
PARTICULAR LIST IN THE BILL SO
AGAIN WE PUT THE SPECIFIC LIST
IN THE BILL AS A STARTING POINT
BECAUSE OF THEIR PREVIOUS
OBJECTIONS NOW THEY'RE OBJECTING
TO THAT --
YOU KNOW HONESTLY WE GO EITHER
WAY THEY JUST NEED TO TELL US
WHICH PART THEY'RE KNOCKING
OBJECT TO URGENT AYE VOTE ON THE
MEASURE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
KYLE JUST CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER FAN ON HOW THE
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU TO CREDIT WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
MAURICIO BELTRAN'S FROM
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
BRIAN CLING ON BEHALF CALPERS.
FOR MELISSA MELISSA CHAYTOR ANTI
ON BEHALF OF THE SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA AT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SPORT.
GENEVIEVE ABBOTT ON ON BEHALF OF
SEVEN GENERATION ADVISORS FIVE
TEARS INSTITUTE WHICH TOYO
CHUMASH FOUNDATION SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION PLASTIC POLLUTION
COALITION WILD COAST AND ALSO
HAVE BEEN ASKED BY DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE.
AUDUBON AND A SCHOOL IN SUPPORT.
TERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
ZERO WASTE USA UPSTREAM HILL THE
BAY AND ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY AND
SUPPORT.
THE SO A LITTLE SALAS PUT IT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN TRUCKS PARKED
THINK THE AUTHOR.
CHUCKLE GOOD REPUBLIC SERVICES
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME.
FOR I GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO JUST IT WITH
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
OF MY ORGANIZATION INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF FOOD SERVICE PACKAGING
MANUFACTURERS PAPER PLASTIC
COMPOSED DOUBLES --
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE OF ISSUES --
AND CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
THE BILL AS IS AS YOU KNOW
DIRECT POWER CYCLE DEVELOP A
LIST OF A FOR APPROVED TYPES OF
FOOD SERVICE PACKAGING.
UP AT THE SAME TIME IT
ARBITRARILY IN ARGUES SPECIFIES
A LIMITED UNIVERSE MATERIALS OF
THAT COULD BE UTILIZED.
OUT THE OUT SAID OTHER PACKAGING
MATERIALS THAT ARE ACCEPTED --
IN RECYCLING PROGRAMS AROUND THE
STATE --
WOULD BE SHUT OUT --
AT THE OUTSET AND SOME OF THOSE
MATERIALS --
I THINK ARGUABLY DEMONSTRATE
HAVE A A LIGHTER ENVIRONMENTAL
FOOTPRINT AND OTHER MATERIALS --
AND THIS LEGISLATION DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT SO IN OUR VIEW AT
A MINIMUM THE BILL SHOULD --
BE MATERIAL NEUTRAL AT THE
OUTSET AND NOT ARBITRARILY
CHAIRMAN THOSE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
ACCEPTABLE A AND THOSE THAT ARE
NOT THERE ARE SOME OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT WE
FEEL ARE VAGUE --
ANY CLARIFICATION OF THE BILL
REQUIRES CAL RECYCLE IN
DETERMINING A WHAT PRODUCTS ARE
ADDED TO THE LIST --
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION OF THE
PACKAGES PRONE --
TO BECOME LEADER OF VERSES
ANOTHER PACKAGE BUT THE BILL
DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY SORT OF
INSIGHT AND HOW THAT'S
TERMINATION WOULD BE MADE --
OTHER PROVISIONS THE BILL --
CHARGE CAO RECYCLED DOING SINCE
AND ASSESSMENT OF CHEMICALS THAT
MAY BE USED IN CERTAIN PRODUCTS
THAT WE THINK THERE ARE A
REGULATORY DUPLICATION ISSUES
HERE.
AT THE DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUCH
OVERSIGHT OVER CHEMICALS USING
CONSUMER PRODUCTS THEY RECENTLY
HAD FOOD PACKAGING TO THEIR WORK
PRIORITY PRODUCT WORK PLAN.
UNDER THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM --%
SO DIRECTING CALPERS.
AB -- WHERE
WE DON'T BELIEVE THEY HAVE A THE
LEVEL OF EXPERTISE --
AS WELL AS THE DUPLICATION THAT
--
WITH DTS SEE --
IS SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL SHOULD
BE DELETED OF FROM THE BILL WE
HAVE HAD SOME CONVERSATION
WASN'T BROWN'S OFFICE OF LAST
WEEK ABOUT A MORE SIMPLIFIED
APPROACH LOOKING AT A MATERIALS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY COLLECTED --
AND IN IN RECYCLING PRO
ENCOMPASSING PROGRAMS IN THOSE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AS BEING THE
STARTING POINT --
WE'VE SEEN AS A KID HAVING A
CONTINUE CONVERSATION ON THAT
REGARD.
AS WELL AS THE INDUSTRY I HAD TO
COME TO THE TABLE EARLY THIS
YEAR AND SUPPORTING US.
SIMBOLOS A PROPOSAL --
TO FIND --
INCREASE RECYCLING PROGRAMS
UPPER POLY STYRENE CONTAINERS A
COUPLE WITH THAT AND SOME
ADDITIONAL INDUSTRY GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT THERE WE
WE THINK THERE'S A BETTER
APPROACH --
THAT BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
OPT YOU TALKED SENATOR ALLEN ON
ON THIS ISSUE THE BILL BEFORE
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING KITTY HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE WOULD REQUIRE CAO RECYCLE
TO CREATE A LIST OF APPROVED
TYPES OF FOOD SERVICE PACKAGING.
SERIOUS GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
RECYCLABLE COMPOSTABLE USE AND
GOVERNMENT MANDATES BUT WE LIKE
THESE TO BE MATERIAL NEUTRONS.
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE LIMITS
THE MATERIALS THAT POWER CYCLE
CAN CONSIDER AT THE OUTSIDE.
THEN DIRECTS THEM TO COME UP
WITH THE FAVORITE LIST OF
PRODUCTS.
BUT IF BUT HAS NO DIRECTION OF
HOW POWER CYCLE WILL WILL
DETERMINE ULTIMATELY WHAT IS
APPROVED OR NOT. FOR EXAMPLE CAO
RECYCLE MUST MAKE A
DETERMINATION THAT A PACKAGE IS
PRONE TO BECOME LETTER PURSES
ANOTHER PACKAGE.
THE BILL HAS NO CRITERIA ON HOW
THAT DETERMINATION WILL BE MADE.
THE RESULT FOR SMALLER
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS LIKE
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS IS THAT WE
WILL FACE A VERY UNPREDICTABLE
VOLATILE PACKAGING MARKET WITH
LIMITED CHOICE ULTIMATELY
DRIVING UP COSTS.
WELL THIS ONE SINGLE ISSUE.
ALONE BY ITSELF WILL NOT DO THAT
THE ISSUE TAKEN INTO THE LARGER
CONTEXT OF THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT
OF WHAT THE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY
IS FACING STATEWIDE IS
PROBLEMATIC.
UNPRECEDENTED WAGE HIKES MANY
WHICH ARE YET TO COME IS MINIMUM
WAGE IS SET TO INCREASE.
RELATIVELY NEW PAID SICK LEAVE
REQUIREMENTS COMPLIANCE WITH THE
ACA INCREASING WORKERS
COMPENSATION PREMIUMS AND THE
RESTAURANT PAIN.
MASSIVE BILLS TO OFFSET A
DEFICIT THEY DID COULD NOT
CREATE TO THE STATE'S DIED AND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND.
ALL OF THESE COSTS ADD UP FOR
OUR MEMBERS.
STATE FACILITIES OFTEN ARE THE
CHOICE OF LOCAL INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS IN THEIR COMMUNITY
LIKE THE ONES HERE IN THIS
FACILITY. TO DO BUSINESS PLEASE
DON'T CREATE ADDITIONAL BARRIERS
TO THOSE INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS.
SERIOUS COMMITTED TO THE ISSUE
OF RESPECTABILITY AND COMPOSED
ABILITY WE HIGHLY INVESTED IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWS AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY ONE WHICH AN AXE
FINANCIAL COMMITMENTS A PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS TO INVEST IN A
STATEWIDE INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR
JUST THE SOLE PURPOSE A LONG
TERM SUSTAINABLE STRATEGY THAT
DOESN'T PREJUDGE OUTCOMES AND
FURTHER COMMITS THE STATE TO
RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING.
WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR MR LOW'S EFFORTS AS THAT
BILL FOR MOVEMENT CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD INTO NEXT ACTION.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK YOU TO
VOTE NO TODAY ON SB.
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME.
FOR I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
PRESSMAN YANNI ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN PLASTICS THE ASSOCIATION
OF PLASTICS RECYCLERS IMPACT OF
CORPORATION.
HAVE WE UNDERSTAND THEM LAUDABLE
GOALS OF THE SPONSOR OF THE
AUTHOR AND ECHOING SOME OF
MISTER SHAW SIX COMMENTS
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE I THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
AND I TO TRY AND RETURN
DIVERSION GOALS IS IT RIGHT NOW
BUT WE DO THINK THERE'S A
DIALOGUE
KEEP GOING TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
ON KHAKI MCCUE KEPT CAN ASSIST
IT'S ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO UP.
GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS KEEP
FELT CAPITAL ASKS HIM HAVE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR JUST
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF TECHNET IN
OPPOSITION.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOE ACT ON
BEHALF OF PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OF RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THEM BEFORE TO KEEP AND
DIALOGUE GOING THING.
THANK YOU SEAN THOSE OF THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
IN THE STATE ALSO POST.
ADEQUATELY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
SCOTT WHAT YOU'RE BETH IBEW
LOCAL ELEVEN LOS ANGELES UP.
JONATHAN CHOI WERE DARK
CONTAINER CORPORATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MISS MELENDEZ THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN DOES THIS BILL --
WOULD IT ALSO PROHIBITS ANY
MOBILE --
FOOD.
CONCESSIONAIRE OR NOT
CONCESSIONAIRES BUT TRUCKS I
GUESS YOU KNOW FROM USING THAT
TYPE OF MATERIALS WITH A
CONCESSIONAIRE ON STATE PROPERTY
LET'S NOT TAKE SOMEBODY'S A
CONCESSIONARY SEE PROPERTY THAT
THEY CAN STILL USE IT.
YEAH YEAH IT'S ONLY REALLY
THOUGHT WHAT'S THE PROPERTY.
AS OUR DOCUMENT I KNOW BUT YOU
CAN HAVE IT SOMEONE ON STATE
PROPERTY WHO'S NOT A
CONCESSIONAIRE.
BUT LIKE FOR INSTANCE I WAS JUST
OUT A GRADUATION PARTY THIS
WEEKEND DOWN AT A STEEP BEACH
DOWN IN ORANGE COUNTY --
IN THERE IF THEY HAD A TACO
TRUCK THERE AND THE PLACE THAT
THEY WERE USING THEIR WORD
STYROFOAM PLATES SO WHAT EFFECT
WHOEVER'S CONTRACTING WITH THE
STATE TO YOU HAVE TO BE INVOLVED
CONTACT WITH THE STATE.
SO IF I HAVE A PARTY AT THE
BEACH.
AND I HIRE SOMEONE TO COME WITH
THEIR TALK CHECK THE CAN USE.
THIS TYPE OF MATERIAL AND NOT
GET INTO ANY TROUBLE.
I WOULD THINK YES YES YES. FOR
THAT MATTER COULD LOOK HERE TO
PULL YOU FOUND ONE NO NO I'M
CLEAR HER HEAD. TO THE PARTIES
THAT MAKE ME.
I MEAN I JUST I I'VE.
I'M JUST NOT A IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE FAIRLY CERTAIN BUT NOT
ENTIRELY CERTAIN NO I THINK.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
HOUSE TO INVOLVE A CONTRACT WITH
THE STATE WOULD STATE AGENCY.
OKAY SO AND SO SO THAT IN THAT
CASE IT WOULD NOT BE INCLUDED.
OKAY AND SO MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I
MAY JUST --
ONE QUESTION [inaudible]
I'M JUST.
I DON'T LIKE TO SEE THAT STUFF
IN THE OPEN THE WATER EITHER --
BUT I'M JUST WONDERING.
EVERY CITY CAN ENACT THEIR OWN
ORDINANCES AND SAY YOU KNOW WE
JUST DON'T WANT THIS TYPE OF
MATERIAL --
BEING USED IN OUR CITY BECAUSE
WE'RE SO CLOSE TO WATER WAY OR
JUST BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
LIKE IT EVERY CITY CAN DO THAT
NOW.
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS TO WHY WE
WOULDN'T LEAVE THAT TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO LET THEM DECIDE WHAT'S
BEST FOR THEIR COMMUNITY GIVEN
THAT.
THERE CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE
SO CLOSE TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS
RATE BECAUSE THEY HAVE THEIR
MEETINGS TWICE A MONTH WHATEVER
THEY COULD.
WELL BUT YOU KNOW YOU.
IT'S DIRECT ACCESS I'M A LITTLE
MORE SO THAN US REPRESENTING
FORTY FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WHERE THEY CAN REALLY SAY THEY
WERE I THINK THEY WOULD GET A
GOOD IDEA OF GOSH THE COMMUNITY
REALLY HATES THIS OR THEY REALLY
LOVE IT.
HERE'S THE THING WE'RE WE HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER STATE PROPERTY
SO WHEN WE ARE THE STATE.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE FOCUSED THIS
BILLS JUST FOCUS ON CITY BUT I
DO SO.
SO BECAUSE I WAS ASKING THIS
QUESTION IF IF A CITY IN ACTS OF
LOCAL ORDINANCE THAT PROHIBITS
THIS THESE OF THIS TYPE OF
MATERIAL.
AND A STATE FACILITIES LOCATED
WITHIN THAT CITY LIKE FOR
INSTANCE IN MIND WE LAKE
ELSINORE IT WAS IT THAT THE
CAMPGROUND WAS RUN BY THE STATE
FOR A TIME.
YEAH YOU CAN THAT DOES THE
CITY'S ORDINANCE COVER YOU KNOW
ANYTHING WITHIN A BROWNSTONES
[inaudible]
HUESO.
AND YOU KNOW THAT IF I THOUGHT
FORTUNATELY OR UNFORTUNATELY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER STATE
PROPERTY.
EVEN IF THEY'RE CITY IS.
AT THE PARK THE STATE PARK IS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION --
WE'VE.
MANY.
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE ADOPTED
THESE VERY ORDINANCES HAVE RUN
UP AGAINST THAT [inaudible]
BARRIER [inaudible]
TIM.
YEAH RIGHT I WAS I WAS.
UP.
YEAH SO THAT THAT'S WHY THAT'S
WHY WE NEED TO STEP IN AND IN
THIS CASE.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT MANY CITIES ARE
STEPPING UP AND AND WE APPLY
THOSE EFFORTS A GREAT DEAL
[inaudible]
MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU SIR FOR BRINGING THIS
AYE AT I AM.
AND WILL BE DISAPPOINTED THAT IT
IS THIS LIMITED IS JUST A STATE
FACILITIES BUT IT'S PRETTY GOOD
PLACE TO START.
AND IN ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS
THAT WERE BROUGHT THE CONCESSION
AGREEMENTS.
THAT TO BE HONEST ON STATE PARKS
PROPERTY OR DOES DEPARTMENT
STATE PROPERTY IS IS FAIRLY
FORMAL IT IS DONE THROUGH A
CONTRACT.
FACT I I WORRY THAT OUR
COLLEAGUE HAS BLOWN THE WHISTLE
ON THE DESK WHO TOOK IT MIGHT'VE
BEEN OPERATING ILLEGALLY IN
WITHOUT PERMITS ON A STATE
FACILITY.
OR THEY TURNED OFF OPERATE
ADJACENT TO A STATE FACILITY
WHICH WOULD THEN BE LEGAL
DEPENDING ON THE JURISDICTION.
SO CITY IS NOT INTERFERE WITH
THE STATE PROPERTY STATES
KNOCKING INTERFERE WITH THE CITY
PROPERTY SO THIS IS NOT UP TO
THE LOCALS THIS IS UP TO US
CENTER. FOR A STATE AGENCY TO
TAKE ON THIS ROLE ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN MATERIALS THAT
ARE APPROPRIATE AND NOT
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THAT POTENTIAL
FOR HARM IN THE AMOUNT OF WASTE
THAT WE SEE.
IS GOOD MODELING ESPECIALLY FOR
PEOPLE ARE NOW COMING TO STATE
FACILITIES A COMING STATE PARKS.
AND A LOT OF LEASES THE PARKS A
MARRIED TO SPEND A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME AND ENERGY.
ON ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
WHAT'S APPROPRIATE WHAT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE TRYING TO GET A LOT
OF THESE MATERIALS OFF THE
BEACHES.
AND THE AMOUNT OF OF TIME AND
AND SPENT ON CLEAN UPS.
FOR THE EXACT KIND MATERIALS
THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT HERE
REALLY CAN BE EXTRAORDINARY SO
FOR THE STATE'S TAKE SOME LEAVE
FOR THE STATE TO SAY THESE ARE
MATERIALS THAT ARE APPROPRIATE.
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S GREAT FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO DO AND WOULD
NOT AT ALL INFRINGE ON A LOCAL
JURISDICTION OR THEIR ABILITY TO
DO WHATEVER THEY CAP THAT I
WOULD HOPE THAT A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SEEING THE
SUCCESS.
ADDED ADJACENT STATE PARK WOULD
ALSO STEP UP AND DO THESE KINDS
OF BANDS WE WE'VE DONE THIS IN
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
FAIRLY MUCH ACROSS THE BOARD AND
THE AMOUNT OF LITTER AND OTHER
MATERIALS THAT WE SEE PLASTICS
SARAH OVER THINGS IN IN THE
ENVIRONMENT HAS DECREASED
DRAMATICALLY SO THESE KINDS
ORDINANCES WORK.
THAT THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PRODUCTS AVAILABLE FOR
RESTAURATEURS INVENTORS TO USE
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS AND THAT
THEY OPERATE.
JUST FINE IN IN THE COUNTY WITH
THE THE BAN ON STYROFOAM AND AND
THIS TYPE PACKAGING THAT THIS IS
REALLY AIMED AT SO I THINK THIS
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL.
WE CAN GET THIS TO THE
LEGISLATURE THINK IT'S A GOOD
MODEL AT THESE VERY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE STATE TO TAKE THE STEPS
I ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT A BILL I
THINK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
WELL.
IT'S IT IT'S BEEN REYES WE'RE
TRYING TO CLARIFY I'D LIKE SOME
CLARIFICATION IF POSSIBLE CENTER
ALLEN -- IT
SAYS HERE.
ME LET ME GO BACK WHICH WOULD
PROHIBIT A FOOD SERVICES SOLELY
LOCATED IN.
STATE OWNED FACILITY.
ACTING IS CONCESSIONAIRES STATE
PROPERTY UNDER CONTRACT EMIT
THIS THIS LOOKS LIKE IT'S THIS
IS A WAR.
HERE SO IT IS LOCATED IN A STATE
OF FACILITY AND I GUESS THE
EXAMPLE WOULD FOLLOW THAT IF YOU
RENT THE FACILITY FROM IF YOU
HAVE A PERMIT TO BE THERE.
AND YOU BRING ANOTHER VENDOR.
FROM OUTSIDE HE WOULDN'T BE
USING THE HAMBURGER STAND
NECESSARILY FOR DOING A WEDDING
OR SOME OTHER EVENT --
WHICH WE'VE ALL BEEN AT AND YOU
BRING IN YOUR OWN VENDOR NOW
THEY HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THIS IT
CAN YOU CLARIFY THAT IT SEEMS TO
BE THAT IT'S IS AN OR AN ANYBODY
ON THOSE STATE.
FACILITIES THAT'S PROVIDING FOOD
SERVICE [inaudible]
INCLUDING THE FOOD TRUCK.
THIS IS FOOD SERVICES LOCATED IN
A STATE FACILITY.
SO YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THERE
IN THE FACILITY THERE THERE ARE
THE RARE IN THE PARKING LOT
UNDER PERMIT LIKE I HAVE THAT WE
PRESENT BOTH LIKE UP THE PERMIT
AGAIN.
BROUGHT IN THE VENDOR TO PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE --
IT IT IT YEAH I AGREE THERE SENS
ALTMAN HERE IT'D BE VERY EASILY.
ENFORCED ON ON A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER WHO.
THAT THE PEOPLE WRITING AND US
WOULD HAVE NO IDEA SO WE'D HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A PROCESS THAT
BOTH A PROCUREMENT PROCESS. TO
GET WITH SOMETHING THEY DON'T
NORMALLY USED AS A LOT OF
AMBIGUITY IN THAT ONE STATEMENT
ALONG I THINK I THINK.
THAT IF YOU CAN CLARIFY YEAH I
KNOW I KNOW THAT WHEN YOU.
WHEN I KNOW OF THESE FROM MY
LIMITED EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA
WHEN WHEN YOU GET YOU GET A
PERMIT RIGHT TO TO OPERATE ON
HAVE?
MADE A PUBLIC FACILITY AND AS WE
WOULD GIVE TO ONE OPPOSITE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE.
AND AND THEY'RE THEY'RE ALWAYS
PERMIT CONDITIONS RIGHTS OF
THEIR VARIOUS CONDITIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH.
GETTING THAT PERMIT --
I I AGREE WITH YOU THAT THE WAY
IT'S WRITTEN DOESN'T I'M.
YOU KNOW PROVIDE.
BONTA PRESENT CLARITY ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR CASE AND I SUPPOSE
LEASE AS IT'S WRITTEN THERE
WOULD.
PROBABLY HAVE TO THE TO THE
STATE PARK.
TO YOU KNOW TO TO TO DETERMINE.
HOW IT WOULD READ THIS IN TERMS
OF DRYING UP ITS PERMIT
CONDITIONS LIST?
WALT.
IT WOULDN'T BE UP TO THE
BUREAUCRACY TO COME UP WITH
GUIDELINES IT'S IN THE BILL.
SO WHILE IT'S A IT SAYS A FOOD
SERVICE FACILITY LOCATED IN A
STATE ON FACILITY I I THINK
THAT.
TYPICALLY OVER THINKING ABOUT AS
A NOW FOR EXAMPLE I JUST OUTSIDE
MARKET STATE BEACH THERE'S A
THERE'S A CONTINUE THERE'S OF
THE PIER RESTAURANT DOWN THERE
ALL RIGHT THERE.
YEAH.
BUT I THINK I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT PRIMARILY AT
YOUR INTENT BUT AND MIND A
PROBLEM IS IT'S NOT IN THE
LANGUAGE AND WHO KNOWS ABOUT
YOUR YOUR ANSWER THE QUESTION I
APPRECIATE YOU HAVE YOUR OKAY.
THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT
TO POINT OUT --
THE AMBIGUITY I'M CERTAINLY IF
IT WOULD MEAN THAT YOU WOULD
SUPPORT THE BILL I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN THAT [inaudible]
YEAH.
IN ADDRESSING IN YOUR FAVOR.
AND I APPRECIATE YEAH YEAH
[inaudible]
NO.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ALLEN.
FOR INTRODUCING GONNA.
PLAY WHAT I THINK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP TO ADDRESSING THE
PLASTIC AND OTHER POLLUTION
PROBLEMS AFTER NAY IS A REAL
CRISIS SO I THINK.
LIKE MRS JOAN INDICATE I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD.
GOOD BELT RICK YOU TO WHAT DATA
I WOULD CLARIFICATION YOU WILL
BE ACCEPTING ALL LESS COMMITTEE
MINUTES UP EARLY.
AND WE SAW A LITTLE MORE WORK TO
DO WITH THE COMMITTEE THIS
COUPLE AMBIGUITIES OR RENT A
COUPLE AND QUIT LOOK COUPLE
QUESTIONS ARE RAISED THE HOUSES
WE WANT WHEN PEOPLE FROM THE
STAFF TO GET THEM RESOLVED.
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND
AND THEN.
I'VE SUCCESS I WROTE THANK YOU
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I DON'T CHEN S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR ALLEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA
RESPECTFULLY REFUTED ACOSTA NO
CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
NO RADIUS.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE I THINK YOU MEMBERS.
SEVEN THREE ALRIGHT LAST
PRESENTING AUTHOR SARAH STERN.
AND YOU HAVE A GOOD EVENING.
GOOD EVENING SIR YOU HAVE --
I FOURTEEN SP.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY AND ITEM
EIGHTEEN SP FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN YEAH [inaudible]
I TO SO WITH THIRTEEN SEVENTIES
HONORING THAT.
YET AT YOUR PLEASURE OKAY.
THANK YOU --
NOT BEEN A LONG HEARING SO THANK
YOU FOR INDULGENCE MEMBERS --
SPILL NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART
IT.
AFFECTS A COMMUNITY THAT I
REPRESENT.
ALONG WITH US A MEMBER ACOSTA
HERE --
IMPACTED BY THE ELITES SO CANYON
BLOW OUT THE COMMITTEE STILL
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT CHEMICALS WERE
FAT PUMPED INTO THAT UNDERGROUND
STORAGE FACILITY.
BECAUSE OF A GAP IN STATE LAW SO
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE
THE GAS STORAGE INDUSTRY TO BE
SUBJECTED TO THE SAME DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE OIL INDUSTRY
IS CURRENTLY SUBJECTED TO FOR
WHO THE BILL [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
AND WITH THAT I HAVE A SIERRA
CLUB HERE AND WHICH RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THAT EVENING CAO JONES THE
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA --
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY WILL
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD TO MAKE
SURE THAT --
THE STORAGE INDUSTRY A IS IS
COMMITTED TO THE SAME RULES AS
EVERYONE ELSE --
ALLOWING THE PUBLIC TO KNOW WHAT
IS HAPPENING AROUND THEM AND
WHAT CHEMICALS THAT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY SO EXPOSED TO SO
THAT IN THE CASE OF ANY
POTENTIAL LEAK THAT PEOPLE BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE ADEQUATE SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS ARE WE ARE DRIVE
UPSTATE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU AT THE END FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOTIONS TO MADE AND SECONDED
SARAH WAS LIKE CLOTHES RESPECT
RESTAURANTS ARIAL AS MR ACOSTA.
I THINK YOU R. CENTER STERN --
APPRECIATE MY CONSTITUENT WHERE
WE HAVE OUR OVERLAP IF YOU LIVE
IN MY DISTRICT THAT'S GREAT --
AND THAT WE YOU KNOW WE DO SHARE
THIS ISSUE --
THAT'S BEEN VERY IMPORTANT. TO
KNOW OUR JOINT CONSTITUENTS AND
FRANKLY.
THE OVERALL AREA IT'S THERE'S A
THERE'S ISSUES THERE ARE SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS FOR I
THINK JUST THE THE FACT THAT
WILL GIVE SOME.
PEACE OF MIND IF WE IF WE CAN TO
THE FOLKS THAT LIVE THERE.
AND I WOULD CERTAINLY --
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW BEING A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS I'M NOT SURE WE
MISS I THINK WE MISSED SOME.
CORRESPONDENCE I APPRECIATE IT
VERY GOOD AUTHOR HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU AND STILL NEED A PUBLIC
HEALTH STUFF DO.
BUT WE WILL WORK CORRECTLY DO
YOU WORK ON THAT I THINK I GOT
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
ALRIGHT SOUNDS LIKE BIPARTISAN
LOVE THERE WAS LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ROCK OFFICE.
ITEM FOURTEEN SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY BY SENATOR CERTAIN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WERE OUT SEARCHING AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
SHALL I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA [inaudible]
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
REYES.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I EIGHT ZERO BUT ALSO.
I THINK YOU MEMBERS SECOND BILL
FOUR YEARS THAT BE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVENTY LOW EMISSIONS
BUILDING TECHNOLOGY MARKET
DEVELOPMENT ACT.
BUILDINGS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ABOUT 25% THE STATE'S GREENBELT
MISSIONS --
WE HAVE BOTH THE BUILDING SIDE
INITIATIVE AS WELL AS A
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION INITIATIVE
HERE A VERY UNIQUE COALITION OF
OF DEVELOPERS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AS WELL AS MANUFACTURERS
SO.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND VERY HOPEFULLY
YOUR AYE VOTE --
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
ALEX JACKSON TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE BENEFITS FROM A RATE AND
COST PERSPECTIVE BUT LET'S BE
BRIEF IN HONOR OF THEIR THAT I
THINK YOU SENATOR I THINK MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OUT JACKSON
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL.
PLEASE TO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
WHICH WE VIEW AS AN EXTENSION OF
THE SUCCESSFUL NEW SOLAR HOMES
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
INITIATIVE SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WHICH WAS INSTRUMENTAL.
IN PROVIDING INCENTIVES FOR
BUILDERS TO INTERVENE AT A TIME
WHEN OUR WE CAN GET THE MOST
BANG FOR OUR BUCK WITH OUR
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS AT THE TIME
AND DO CONSTRUCTION.
HELPING THE COST OF THAT
TECHNOLOGY DOWN IN STRIDE AS
WIDESPREAD ADOPTION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED TO DO THE SAME NOW FOR
CLEAN HE S. WHICH ARE --
REALLY THE NEXT FRONTIER FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY CHALLENGES.
SPACE HEATING AND WATER HEATING
ARE THE TWO LARGEST SOURCES OF
EMISSIONS AND BUILDINGS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVE COST
EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE
BUT WE FACE SOME OF THE SIMILAR
BARRIERS THAT WE FACED WITH SOME
OF OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES TEN YEARS AGO.
CONTRACTORS ARE AWARE OF THEM
RETAILERS ARE STOCKING THESE
PRODUCTS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES INCENTIVES --
NOT MANDATES TO GET US THERE IS
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND HAPPILY
SOME OF THE EARLY RETURNS FROM
CURRENT PROJECTS ARE DOING THESE
VERY SAME.
INTERVENTIONS ARE SHOWING
UTILITY BILLS SAVINGS FOR
BUILDING OCCUPANTS ARE WE HAVE
EXPLICIT PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL
TO GUIDE THAT SAME BEST
PRACTICES MOVING FORWARD AND WE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THIS EVENING MY NAME IS
CHARLIECORR MANY I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EFFICIENCY
FIRST CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE NONPROFIT TRADE
ORGANIZATION I REPRESENT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY CONTRACTORS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I JUST LIKE TO SAY THE COUPLE OF
QUICK POINTS THAT THERE ARE
CONTRACTORS ARE DOING THIS KIND
OF WORK AND WORKING TOWARDS
PROVIDING A LOW EMISSIONS.
ECONOMY THE NUMBERS ARE SMALL
THE NASCENT INDUSTRY AND IT
NEEDS TO BE SUPPORTED. ONE OF
THE BARRIERS WE FACE IS LACK OF
AWARENESS BY BOTH CONTRACTORS
AND HOMEOWNERS THAT THERE IS AN
ABILITY TO DO THIS.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS HERE IT'S IT'S
A PROVEN TECHNOLOGY THAT A LOT
OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS IN THE WAY
TO DO IT --
THAT SAID THE PRODUCTS ARE NOT
ALWAYS AVAILABLE DUE TO DEMAND
--
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT INCENTIVES
ARE FOSTER GROWTH IN THE
INDUSTRY SOMEBODY WAY THAT THE
CSI PROGRAM WORK WITH SOLAR --
WE SAW THAT PROP UP INDUSTRY
WHEN IT WAS STARTING OUT AS A
YOUNG INDUSTRY AND MATURE.
INTO COMPLETE MARKET
TRANSFORMATION WE BELIEVE THE
SAME THING CAN HAPPEN HERE --
WE SEE THAT INCENTIVE LOWER
COSTS AND INCREASED CONTRACTOR
PARTICIPATION AND ARE A VERIFIER
TO HOMEOWNERS IT'S A LEGITIMATE
CAUSE -- WE
THINK THAT WE HAVE THE SITUATION
THAT HERE WE CAN INCREASE --
THE THE MANUFACTURES WE SAW IT
WE HAVE A PROBLEM OF SUPPLY AND
DEMAND OF SOME OF THE THE
TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE.
MANUFACTURES HAD THE BILLY
PROVIDE THEM BUT THERE ISN'T
ENOUGH DEMAND AND WE'VE BEEN
TOLD REPEATEDLY THAT.
IF YOU CAN SHOW ENOUGH INTEREST
STATE WE WILL PROVIDE THE
PRODUCTS AND SEWER BEEN COURAGE
IN THAT THAT WILL BE A CASE.
HOW WE ALSO SEE THIS IS BILLY TO
TRAIN CONTRACTORS AND GET THEM
PARTICIPATE AND FINALLY WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS?
SERVES TO BENEFIT THOSE WHO NEED
IT MOST AS IT DOES ADDRESS LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WHICH WE THINK IS REALLY
CRITICAL.
AND I THINK IF YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBER SILVIO FOR OUR
IMPACT THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS
ARE WORK ON THIS IS ALWAYS NICE
FEEL TO BE THE BUILDER SET UP
HER NEXT AND RDCS JUST SAYING
HEY ECHO ECHO THEIR COMMENTS
ONLY THING.
I WOULD ADD TO WHAT ALEX SAID
YOU KNOW --
THIS IS THAT NEW SOLANO
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN BEING
TRANSFORMATIVE IN THE
MARKETPLACE WE BELIEVE THIS
PROGRAM COULD BE EQUALLY AS
TRANSFORMATIVE SPECIALLY FOR
ENTRY LEVEL FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS WHO ABSENT A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS COULDN'T.
A INVEST IN MAKING THEIR HOMES
MORE COMFORTABLE MORE LIVABLE
AND MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT I
STRONGLY URGE AND I'VE.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES SUPPORT
VACLAV AND SEE NOT BE HAVE THE
CENTER FOR STABLE ENERGY AND
SMOTHERED SPORTS THE MARKET
TRANSFORMATION ELEMENTS THE BILL
THANK YOU.
A CROWD JUST CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THREE SEPARATE* ON
BEHALF OF SERIES IN SUPPORT TO
GO TO THE CALIFORNIA SLEEP TILL
THESE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE MARKET TRANSFORMATION
PERSONALS THE BILL THINKING.
ERICA MARTINEZ WITH EARTH
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME.
FOR GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF VALERIE TRAIL OF
LAJOS --
REALIZING THAT I AM THE ONLY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION BETWEEN
YOU -- AND
YOUR DINNER --
SO WANTED --
TO JUST NOTE THAT WE ARE OPPOSED
--
WE'VE HAD SOME GOOD COVERS.
AUTHOR AND I DO LIKE --
THE TESTIMONY ABOUT THINKING
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN LEARN FROM THE
NEW SOLAR HOMES --
PARTNERSHIP --
THE COUPLE THINGS THAT WE'VE
ARTICULATED ARE OPPOSED LETTER
ARE -- WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS OF VISION
THAT THE BILL IS TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL --
BUT WE DO NOT THINK THAT I GAS
CUSTOMERS SHOULD PAY FOR ON MANY
OF THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT MOVE TO
ELECTRIFICATION SO.
MAYBE PERHAPS YOU KNOW JUST.
THERE SHOULD BE A FIREWALL THERE
--
THE AUTHOR'S LATEST AMENDMENTS
THAT I I THINK ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS P. GENIES CONCERNED
ABOUT ON DOUBLE DIPPING WITH --
EXISTING INCENTIVE PROGRAMS --
IT'S AN IMPROVEMENT THOMAS NOT
QUITE YOU KNOW BUT WE ASKED
WHICH IS --
NO TECHNOLOGY SHOULD OF TWO
SUBSIDY PROGRAMS BUT WE
APPRECIATE DEFINITELY ON THE
DIRECTION.
ON THAT'S GOING SO WE CAN HOPE
TO CONTINUE WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
IMPROVE THE BELL WE KNOW IT'S
DOUBLE REFERRED THINGS THAT WE
CAN LEARN FROM A NEW SOLAR HOUSE
PARTNERSHIP SUCH AS A PROGRAM
CAP KIND OF DEFINING AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE NEED --
LIMITING THE PROGRAM TO
RESIDENTIAL BEING ABOUT THEIR
SINGLE FAMILY AND MULTI FAMILY
HOMES -- AND
CREATING SOME SORT OF PROTECTION
SO NO MATTER THE ADMINISTRATOR
OF THE APPROACH OF THE PROGRAM.
IF -- ONLY
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY OF MONEY
CUSTOMER MONEY IS GOING INTO
FUND SOMETHING ONLY THOSE OF THE
CUSTOMERS THAT WOULD --
BENEFIT --
THINGS OTHER THINGS --
TO THINK ABOUT AND THAT WE CAN
MODEL OF THE NEW SOLAR HOMES
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
THINGS LIKE A DECLINING
INCENTIVE MAYBE PERFORMANCE
BASED INCENTIVES ALL OF THESE
PROBABLY --
AS A TOPIC THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
WITH THE AUTHOR ON AND SPONSOR
--
INDEFINITELY CONTINUE --
AS CROSSOVER IS WITH MANY OF
THESE MEMBERS IN THE UTILITIES
ALMOND ENERGY COMMITTEE THANK
YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTION MR MCCARTY HOME
[inaudible]
AS RATES.
I DO I DO IF.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
30%. FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND ALSO --
THE WORD THAT DUE CONSIDERATION
FOR THE LOW INCOME HOUSING.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THERE BE THOSE INCENTIVES
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE LOOKING --
FOR MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
HAVE AN INCENTIVE LIKE THIS
WHICH IS OF GREAT BENEFIT TO
THOSE WHO WILL PURCHASE --
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU AND THE GOAL IS TO
MAKE AFFORDABLE HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ALL THE PILOTS
WHO SEEN AT THEIR THE LOW INCOME
SPACE HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
SO.
THAT'S THAT 30% CARVE OUT SET
ASIDE IN THE IN THE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
MR MCCARTY THANK YOU JUST THAT
WOULD BE A TECHNICAL ISSUE
MISTER.
STERN SO I I I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GO AFTER HERE
THAT BUILDING HISTORY AS SAYS
HER ANNOUNCES THE SECOND LEADING
--
SOURCE THAT THAT GHG EMISSIONS
AND SO.
THIS AS THE COMMISSION HELPS
CREATE LIKE A PROGRAM INITIATIVE
AND THEN I'M I'M KIND OF
CONFUSED SO.
ASSUMING IS THERE THIS OBVIOUSLY
THESE EFFORTS ARE ALWAYS FREE SO
ARE WE LOOKING AT CAP TRIED
DOLLARS OR A PARTNERSHIP WITH.
WE UTILITIES SET TO HELP MAKE
THIS.
A PENCIL OUT.
HOW WILL THAT PLAY OUT?
IN THE END SO THE CURRENT
INTENTION --
IS.
TO IT'S BOTH THERE'S A THERE'S A
UTILITIES CURRENTLY BUY
ALLOWANCES FROM --
FROM THE AIRPORT AND CONSIGNED
THEM BACK TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION FOR RATE
PAYER BENEFITS SAID THERE'S BOTH
NATURAL GAS UTILITIES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PART IT'S A
SORT OF A SUBSECTION OF THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT SO IT'S A IT'S A IT'S
ONLY THE UTILITY.
CHUNK OF THE ALLOWANCE --
MARKET.
AND IT'S LOOKING AT BOTH THE
NATURAL GAS SIDE IN THE ELECTRIC
SIDE CURRENTLY I THINK 15% OF
THE ELECTRIC SIDE.
OF FUNDS THAT ARE COLLECTED GO
GO TO PROGRAMS AND I JUST A
DIVIDEND BACK.
RIGHT BUT BUT CURRENTLY THE
NATURAL GAS DOLLARS ARE SORT OF
JUST.
SITTING THERE AND THAT IF WE
DON'T DO ANYTHING IS LEGISLATURE
THEY'LL GO BACK AS A STRAIGHT
DIVIDEND I THINK THAT'S THE
ANTICIPATED FOCUS WE'RE
INTERESTED IN CARVING OUT A
SMALL PIECE OF THAT.
DESERT OF ADVANCE THE MARKET
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY SO DIRT
THAT'S THE LANE WERE LOOKING TO
PLAY WITHIN.
AND AND WE ARE VERY TO TIPPY
GINNY'S CONCERN WE'RE VERY OPEN
TO THE IDEA OF A PROGRAM CAP OR
SOME WAY TO CONSTRAIN THIS
BECAUSE I DON'T.
THE INTENTION HERE IS NOT TO GO
SUCK UP ALL THOSE FUNDS WITHIN
THAT CONSIGNED ALLOWANCE REVENUE
IT'S IT'S DESERTED TAKE WHAT THE
ELECTRIC MODEL IS AND AND LOOK
AT IT ON BOTH THE GAS AND
ELECTRIC SIDE.
OKAY [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
AND HOPEFULLY BY THE END OF THIS
WEEK AND GOING THROUGH ENERGY TO
WILL.
WILL RESOLVE SOME OF THOSE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES I JUST WANT
TO MAKE THE STATEMENT THAT I'M
I'M VERY OPEN TO TO SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS PUT FORTH BY THE
OPPOSITION LIKE I SAID IT ABOUT
PROGRAM CAP AND ALSO BORROWING
FROM MINUTES AND HAS.
HP PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES THOSE
KINDS OF MODELS SAID THAT WAS A
USEFUL GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES
THAT WITHOUT IT RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE RIFLE [inaudible]
IRAQ.
THE MOTION'S BEEN MADE INSECT.
AND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM EIGHTEEN S. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR STERN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
UTILITIES AND NERGY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WERE OUT SEARCHING AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA NO ACOSTA
NO CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ.
LENDERS NO REYES.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE I SEVEN THREE FELLOWS OUT.
ALRIGHT --
WE'RE LOOKING THE CALL ON
BILL'S.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING.
OUTSIDE WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
I DON'T SIXTEEN S. B. FORTINO
THREE CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE ABSENT
MEMBERS ACOSTA.
COSTS AYE CHAU CHAU AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LOW MOAN.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I TEND [inaudible]
ZERO ELISSA.
I DON'T WANT US TO BE SEVENTY
ONE CURRENT VOTE.
THREE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
SHALL I THE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
LINDA'S NOT VOTING. SIX ONE
BELLOWS OUT.
I DON'T TO SP ONE SIXTY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE FOUR TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA
[inaudible]
CHAU.
CHAU I'VE FLORA [inaudible]
LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I FLORA NO ON ITEM
[inaudible]
TO WHEN. SEVEN TO ONE BILL IS
OUT.
ITEM THREE SB FOUR FIFTY TWO WE
HAVE TO MOTIONS.
THE FIRST MOTION IS THAT THE
URGENCY BE ADOPTED.
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE MON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S I TENDER ON ADOPTING THE
URGENCY MOTION IS ADOPTED.
A SECOND MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE TWO
ZERO WITH YOUR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
FLORA.
THURMOND A BEST BEFORE FIFTY TWO
ITEM [inaudible]
THREE FLOOR [inaudible]
I LIMON.
LET ALONE I. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S NOT VOTING. EIGHT ZERO
BELLEZZA.
ITEM FIVE SB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
CURRENT VOTE FOR TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE ABSENT
MEMBERS ACOSTA.
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FOUR JACKSON.
ACOSTA NO CHAU.
CHAU I'VE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I SEVEN THREE CILLIZZA.
ITEM SIX SB TEN SEVENTY TWO
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ONE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE OF THE MOON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I NINE ONE ELIZA.
ITEM SEVEN SB.
ELEVEN TEN CURRENT VOTE FIVE
ZERO WITH THE TRAVELING I ABSENT
MEMBERS ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE FLORA.
LARA I'M LIMON.
LIMON NOT VOTING.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I NINE ZERO BILL IS A
ITEM EIGHT SB.
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN CURRENT VOTE
THREE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA.
ITEM EIGHT S. B..
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN ACOSTA NOT
VOTING.
CHAU.
CHAU I'VE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
LENDERS KNOW STONE [inaudible]
STONE I EIGHT TWO ONE BILL IS
OUT.
ITEM NINE S. B..
TWELVE SIXTY CURRENT VOTE FIVE
ZERO WITH THE TRUE VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA
[inaudible] TWELVE SIXTY ACOSTA
AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE FLORA.
FLORA I THE MOON.
THE MOON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I TEN ZERO BILL IS A
ITEM ELEVEN S. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE
TO DESIRE OVER THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA
[inaudible]
BLESSING.
YEAH I OKAY.
BUT IT SAYS OKAY.
OKAY I SAW ON SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE ACOSTA AYE.
CHAU.
CHAU I'VE FLORA.
FLORA I THE MOON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE I TEN ZERO ELISSA.
I DON'T TWELVE S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN CURRENT VOTE FIVE
ZERO WITH THE TRUE VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LIMO I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE.
MELENDEZ MUNDAS AYE TEN ZERO
FILL IS A ITEM THIRTEEN S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE CURRENT VOTE
THREE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE ABSENT MEMBERS
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NO CHILD.
CHAU AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
NO STONE.
STONE I SEVEN THREE BILL IS OUT.
I DON'T FIFTEEN SB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR CURRENT
VOTE TO DO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE ABSENT MEMBERS
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MELENDEZ MULLIN
DESIROUS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE TEN ZERO BILL IS OUT.
S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY ITEM
SEVENTEEN CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
TRIAL I LIMON.
LIMON NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
LENDERS NOT VOTING.
RAYOS. FOR IS NOT VOTING. SIX TO
ONE VILLOSA [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
IT MADE [inaudible]
THE JOURNAL